YOU CAN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO THIS HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC. AERIALS COMMITTEE-
SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE-
ABSENT MEMBERS- WE CAN START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT NOW
BETWEEN THE VICE CHAIRS MEDIAN
MYSELF- SO IF YOU CHOOSE ME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AND MYSELF
- GOOD AFTERNOON AND- IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. HAVE THE OPTION OF
TESTIFYING VIA PHONE LINE. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS YEAR IT
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. AGAIN
THAT NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. YOU CAN FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR SCREEN. IF YOU WERE CALLING
MAN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. IN PARTICULAR
MAKE SURE NO ONE ELSE IS-
LISTENING IN ON THIS BECAUSE
THAT'LL GIVE US FEEDBACK. OF
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTING YOUR
SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE NOTE THAT
CALL IN TESTIMONY WILL BE
COMBINED FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL BE TAKEN AFTER
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE TESTIFIED
. PRIMARY WITNESS TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
FOR EACH SIDE. ALSO PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS CALLING IN TO REMAIN
ALIVE LINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED ON
TO SPEAK. ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED TO
STATING THEIR NAME. ORGANIZATION
THEY REPRESENT ONE AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THEY WERE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA TWO OF WHICH ARE
ON CONSENT. ARE WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET SO WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE IS RIGHT HERE SO
PLEASE COME UP WITH THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE EARLY. AND.
PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE AND THAT'S RESOURCES
WORKING ON FROM OF PLASTICS IN
THE ENVIRONMENT FORREALLY QUITE
SOME TIME THIS IS A B. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FOUR AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT OR BETTER WAYS
THAT WE CAN START TO TAKE
MICROFIBRES OUT OF THE SYSTEM WE
KNOW THAT. WASHING MACHINES
DRYERS THAT THE PROCESS OF
CLEANING. CLOTHING BETTER MADE
FROM NON NATURAL FIBERS THAT
BREAKS DOWN AND WE GET
MICROFIBERS EVERYWHERE AND IT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK AT IN THIS
BILL IS STATE OWNED WASHING
MACHINES BECAUSE WE THINK THAT
THERE ARE TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE
TO ATTACH FILTERS TO THOSE IN
BECAUSE THEY ARE WASHING
MACHINES ARE MANAGED BY
EMPLOYEES AND PROFESSIONALS WE
OBVIATE THE NEED. FOR THE MORE
OBVIOUS THE CONCERN FOR NOT
HAVING APPROPRIATE MAINTENANCE
ON THOSE FILTERS SO I THINK THIS
IS A- IMPORTANT STEP AS WE TRY
TO UNDERSTAND. THE ISSUE OF
MICROFIBERS HOW THEY GET OUT
INTO THE ENVIRONMENT GOING
THROUGH WASTE TREATMENT PLANTS
AND OUT THROUGH SOME OF THESE
PROCESSES AND THINK THIS BILL IF
WE CAN GET THIS ENACTED WOULD GO
A LONG WAY TO SHOWING HOW THESE
KINDS OF FILTERS DO WORK WOULD
WORK. WHAT THE MAINTENANCE
ISSUES AND THE OTHER ISSUES ARE
AROUND THEM SO THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR ITEMS AND WITH ME IS CODY
PHILLIPS OF THE CALIFORNIA COAST
KEEPER ALLIANCE I BELIEVE ON THE
TELEPHONE YEAH HE'S ON THE PHONE
LINE SO- AT&T OPERATOR- COULD
YOU PLEASE HAVE CODY PHILLIPS
SPEAK UP. CODY. YES YEP. THANK
YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON CHECK
WORKING AND THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CODY PHILLIPS THE POLICY ANALYST
FOR CALIFORNIA CUT DEEPER
ALLIANCES SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR TODAY-
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
DESCRIBED MICRO PLASTICS ARE
EVERYWHERE. MULTIPLE SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES HAVE OBSERVED THESE
PLASTIC PARTICLES IN GUT BIOTA
AIR WATER SEDIMENT AND MOST
RECENTLY IN HUMAN BLOOD. WERE
EVER SIGNED AS THE VOTE THEY
HAVE FOUND THESE MICROPLASTICS
AND MICROFIBERS ARE ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON FORMS OF
MICROPLASTIC POLLUTION REPORTED
PUBLIC. ONE WELL UNDERSTOOD
POLLUTION PATHWAY FOR
MICROFIBRES ESTHER WASTEWATER
FROM WASHING MACHINES- BECAUSE
MICROFIBERS OF THE PRODUCT OF A
VARIETY OF SYNTHETIC TEXTILES
EACH LOAD OF LAUNDRY CAN RELEASE
UP TO ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
MICROFIBRES INTO THE ECOSYSTEM.
AND BECAUSE THE SERVERS ARE SO
SMALL MOST WASTEWATER TREATMENT
FACILITIES DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO FILTER THEM OUT OF
WATER. AS A RESULT AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
MICROFIBERS PASTOR WASTEWATER
TREATMENT FACILITIES EACH YEAR
POLLUTING CALIFORNIA'S
WATERWAYS. AND ONCE THEY ARE IN
THE ENVIRONMENT MICROFIBERS
COMMITTEE TO A VARIETY OF
HARMFUL OUTCOMES. BALL THAT CAN
INGESTED MICROPLASTICS CUTTING
STARVATION AND REPRODUCTIVE
ISSUES. EVEN WORSE THAT THE
FARMERS DO NOT BIODEGRADE AND
THEY COMBINED WITH CHEMICAL
POLLUTANTS IN WATER- AND
BIOACCUMULATE UP THE FOOD LAB.
STUDIES HAVE BEEN INDICATED. THE
MICROFIBERS AND UP IN OUR
DRINKING WATER. SO CONTROL THIS
WILL UNDERSTOOD POWER. THE
REASON OCEAN BUT COUNT STATEWIDE
MICROPLASTIC REPORT RECOMMENDED
THAT THESE MICROFIBER FILTRATION
DEVICES ARE USED IN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S WASHING MACHINES.
THE FILTERS ARE READILY
AVAILABLE AND ON THE MARKET AND
CONSUMER SURVEYS INDICATE THAT
THEY ARE POPULAR. ON THIS BILL
IS A NO REGRETS ACTION THAT
WOULD CAPTURE MICROFIBERS BEFORE
THEY ENTER THE ENVIRONMENT AND-
FOR THAT REASON I URGE YOU TO
VOTE HI ON A. B. U. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FOUR AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CODY PHILLIPS-
DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT JUST
KADAGA WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
CHARMERS NICOLE KOREAN
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT.
CAPTIONING PERSONAL COULD ALSO
BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURA WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE- ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OUR PRIMARY WITNESS
OR. ANYONE IN THE ROOM WAS SET
IN OPPOSITION. HOUSE SIGNON GOOD
- BUT THEIR NEXT STEP IS TO GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR AND
EIGHTY AND EIGHTY OPERATOR WE'D
LIKE- PEOPLE SPEAKING TO A. B.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR STONE. OUR
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND POSITION
ONLY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR. WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
PITTSBURGH ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
LINE ONE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS THEY WORK WITH ALL OF
THE HALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ON THE
LINE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS ERIN WILEY ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT ON
THE LINE ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD OPTIMIST SHOULD
JUST MOVE ON HERE ON BEHALF OF
HEAL THE BAY. AND THE CREAM
CHEESE LOBBY COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO THE LINE A ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOSH IT
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORT. YOU DO NOT HAVE A LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TO ALLOW YOU KNOW FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RYANAIR JACKING WITH THE
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY AND THE
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
JENNIFER COUNTERFEITED INVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREEN GENE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT- MISTER
VICE CHAIR ANY QUESTIONS. MISTER
CALDERON THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE AS A SUBSTITUTE
MEMBER AND YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
YOU MAY CLOSE I ASK FOR YOUR
EITHER ALL RIGHT- I SHOULD HAVE
GOTTEN THIS BILL PASSED A YEAR
AGO WHEN YOU FOR TWO YEARS AGO
ANYWAY. TWO YEARS AGO I'VE JUST
GOTTEN SMARTER SINCE- I BELIEVE
THAT. WITH IF WE HAVE GOOD
EXPERIENCE HERE- AND IF THE-
CLOTHES MANUFACTURERS AND THE-
CLOTHES WASHING FOLKS START TO
LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS. ARE THAT WE
CAN FIND THEM. I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD STEP TO FIND OUT WHAT IS
THERE. ARE THERE ARE MANY
POSSIBLE I KNOW I HAVE FRIENDS
ACTUALLY WORKING ON SOMETHING TO
MAKE. PLAST PUBLIC POLYSTYRENE
BIODEGRADABLE BY ADDING A
CHEMICAL COMPOUND. SO THERE ARE
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS AND WE DO
NEED THEM BECAUSE THIS PROBABLY
IS ENDING UP IN THE BIO SOLIDS
IN THE SEWAGE TREATMENT PLANTS
AND- HEY. WE AGAIN WE NEED TO DO
SOME MORE RESEARCH AND
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE BUT IT IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ONE BECAUSE
WE'RE SPREADING THOSE BIOSOLIDS
. ON THE- LANDSCAPE IN THE FARM
AREAS IN PARTICULAR AND FROM
THERE GOD KNOWS WHERE IT GOES.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO EAT ANY- SO
I RECOMMEND THAT I VOTE- WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO- BUT
I. WILL UP WILL VOTE LATER AND-
I THINK YOU'VE I THINK WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO GET THE BILL OUT
THANK. GOD. RIGHT MISTER
CALDERON. OKAY MISTER KALRA
PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL- ONE OF
MY FAVORITES- FLUORESCENT LAMPS
SALES AND DISTRIBUTION OF
PROHIBITION AND- EVEN BEFORE WE
START- I WANT TO SAY HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOU BEEN WORKING WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS- THIS BILL
BANS MERCURY CONTAINING COMPACT
THE LINEAR FLUORESCENT BULBS- SO
PLEASE PRESENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AT THE END
MEMBER. I'D LIKE TO. I LIKE I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN YOU
STOP FOR THEIR WORK AND GUIDANCE
ON THIS BILL AB TWENTY TO AWAIT
WOULD PHASE OUT THE SALE AND
DISTRIBUTION AS A NEW MENU FAST
FACTOR PRODUCT OF COMPACT
FLUORESCENT LAMPS AND LINEAR
FLUORESCENT LAMPS STARTING ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE RESPECTIVELY. HOWEVER
OTHERS BILL WOULD EXEMPT CERTAIN
SPECIALTY FLUORESCENT LAMPS
INCLUDING THOSE USED IN IMAGE
CAPTURE IMAGE PROJECTION AND
DISINFECTION. WHILE THE REST OF
MY AUNTS WERE ORIGINALLY
INTENDED AS A BETTER ALTERNATIVE
TO INCANDESCENT LAMPS THERE ARE
TWO KEY REASONS WHY THERE ARE
THERE ARE NO LONGER THE BEST
OPTION CALIFORNIA. FIRST OFF
FLUORESCENT LAMPS CONTAIN
MERCURY A POTENT TOXIN THAT CAN
CAUSE PERMANENT DAMAGE THE
CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEM IT'S A
FACTOR ESPECIALLY PRONOUNCED IN
CHILDREN. WITH FOREST LANDS ARE
BROKEN THEY RELEASED AMERICA BE
CONTAMINATING ONE ANYTHING IN
THE VICINITY. WHILE THE STATE
CATEGORIZE PRESS OF BOB'S AS
HAZARDOUS WASTE MOST RESIDENTS
ARE STILL DRAWN AWAY IN THE
REGULAR TRASH WITH THE OFTEN
BREAKING EXPOSES WORKERS. TO
DANGEROUS LEVELS OF MERCURY.
SECOND FLORESCENT ONES ARE NO
LONGER THE MOST ENERGY EFFICIENT
BULBS ON THE MARKET MOKRI FREE
LEDS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
EFFICIENT THE FLUORESCENCE ONLY
REQUIRING ABOUT HALF ELECTRICITY
WHILE LASTING TWO TO THREE TIMES
LONGER. FURTHERMORE THE PRICE
ABILITIES IS DROPPING DISDAIN
EXPECTED TO BE COMPARABLE TO THE
COST OF PRESENTS. BY THE TIME
THE BILL TAKES EFFECT.
ADDITIONALLY THE MOVEMENT
TOWARDS- TOWARDS BANNING
FLUORESCENCE IS NOTHING NEW THE
STATE OF VERMONT CURRENTLY
PROHIBITS THE SALE COMPACT
FLUORESCENT LAMPS IN THE E. U.
IS PLAIN TO PAYS AT ALL GENERAL
PURPOSE. FLUORESCENT LAMPS NEXT
YEAR. AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT
WILL ELEVATE CALIFORNIA THE
LEVEL OF OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERS HAVE ALREADY STARTED TO
REMOVE TOXIC INEFFICIENT
FLUORESCENT BULBS FROM THEIR
LIGHT FIXTURES. BY USHERING UP
RUSSELL LANCE THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW BETTER ALTERNATIVES TO
LIGHT THE WAY TO A SAFER MORE
ENERGY EFFICIENT FUTURE. WOULD
BE PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
ARE JORDAN WELLS DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCACY AND COMMUNICATIONS AT
THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL. ADVERTORIAL ROME
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. AT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. OR THIS ME GEORGE WELL
ON THE PHONE LINE I BELIEVE YOU
CAN JUST START TALKING. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. OKAY WONDERFUL
THANK YOU MEMBER KALRA CHAIR
NUMBERS I AM JORDAN WELLS AT THE
NATIONAL STORAGE OF ACTION
COUNCIL A NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES PARTICULAR AN
EQUITABLE ECONOMY AND THE FUNDS
ARE EIGHTY TWO TWO ZERO EIGHT
ALL PRESENT LAND CONTAINER CURE
A POTENT NEUROTOXIN LISTED BY
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANISATION AT
THE TOP TEN CHEMICAL A MAJOR.
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA DOZENS OF WATERWAYS
ARE ALREADY CAN SO CONTAMINATED
WITH MERCURY THAT THE STATE
WARNS CONSUMERS TO LIMIT THEIR
CONSUMPTION OF FISH CAUGHT FROM
THESE LAKES STREAMS AND
RESERVOIRS. THE MERCURY IN
FLUORESCENT LAMP IS CONTAINED
ONLY BY FRAGILE GLASS THAT CAN
AND DOES BREAK RESULTING IN
MERCURY EXPOSURE AND THERE IS NO
SAFE LEVEL OF EXPOSURE TO
MERCURY. BREAKAGE CAN OCCUR AT
ANY POINT IN A PRESS THAT LANCE
LIFECYCLE DURING MANUFACTURING
INSTALLATION COLLECTION
TRANSPORT PROCESSING OR
RECYCLING IRWIN IS LANDFILLED
INCINERATED OR LEGALLY DOT. IF
THIS MEASURE PASSES CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE FOLLOWING THE TWENTY
SEVEN COUNTRIES OF THE EU THAT
UNDER. ENERGY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATION HAVE ALREADY BANNED
YES L. IN SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE AND- LFL WILL BE
BANNED IN AUGUST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE. BERMAN HAS ALSO
ALSO HAS A BAN ON THE COMPACT
FLUORESCENT LAMPS THAT BEGINS IN
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE AND LAST MONTH DURING THAT
MINIMIZE THE CONVENTION ON
MERCURY IN BALI. ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN GOVERNMENTS
INCLUDING THE UNITED STATES
ADOPTED AMENDMENTS TO PHASE OUT
THE CONTACT FOR COMMAND GLOBALLY
BY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE. AND
HERE AT HOME CALIFORNIA SIXTY
NUMBER STATEWIDE RECYCLING
COMMISSION WHICH REPRESENTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RETAILERS
NONPROFIT AND UNIONS. VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO APPROVE A POLICY
RECOMMENDATION STATING SOME
PRODUCTS ARE JUST TALK SICK AND
UNNECESSARY AND HAVE CHEAPER
CHEAPER ALTERNATIVES MAKING
THEIR- SALE UNNECESSARY AND
COSTLY. FLUORESCENT LAMPS THAT
THE CATEGORY AND WE RECOMMEND
THAT CALIFORNIA BANNER FAILED TO
STOP ADDING COSTLY DANGEROUS AND
UNNECESSARY MERCURY IN THE HOMES
AND THE ENVIRONMENT. THE TIME IS
NOW FOR CALIFORNIA TO SAY
FAREWELL TO TOXIC FOR. I LIKE TO
THINK IT'S AN MEMBER. FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP RESPECTFUL ASK FOR
YOU TO FIGURE AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
TWO ZERO EIGHT THANK YOU. SO MS
BROWN PLEASE HAVE BEEN ALREADY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
VICTORIA ROME WITH ENERGY C.
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL NICE TO SEE YOU ALL- AS
STATED MERCURY'S A CHEMICAL OF
SERIOUS CONCERN. AND IT'S YOU
SHOULD BE LIMITED WHENEVER AND
WHEREVER POSSIBLE. IN THE PAST
DESPITE THEIR MERCURY CONTENT
FLUORESCENT LAMPS WERE TOLERATED
EVEN PROMOTED BECAUSE THEY WERE
THE MOST ENERGY EFFICIENT OPTION
AT THE TIME ESPECIALLY COME WHEN
COMPARED TO INCANDESCENT BULBS.
BUT A LOT HAS CHANGED AND LEDS
NOW USE ABOUT HALF THE
ELECTRICITY IS FLUORESCENCE TO
PRODUCE THE SAME AMOUNT OF LIGHT
AND LAST TWO TO THREE TIMES
LONGER. THEY'RE ALSO WIDELY
AVAILABLE AND BECOMING MORE SO
ALL THE TIME. UNLIKE FLUORESCENT
LAMPS THEY DO NOT CONTAIN
MERCURY OR RELEASE TOXIC VAPORS
WHEN THEY BREAK. MAKING THE
SWITCH TO LEDS IS BETTER FOR OUR
HEALTH ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMY
ALSO HELPS WITH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND SAVES CONSUMERS
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION EACH
YEAR IF WE ARE TO MAKE THE FULL
SWITCH- SAY SO AB TWENTY TWO OH
EIGHT WILL REDUCE THE BURDEN ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHICH ARE LEFT
WITH THE CHALLENGING AND COSTLY
TASK OF COLLECTING IMPROPERLY
DISPOSING OF MERCURY CONTAINING
FLUORESCENT LAMPS THE BILL WILL
ALSO BOOST SALES FOR THE MORE
THAN FIFTY MANUFACTURERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS OF LED LIGHTING
THAT ARE OPERATING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NOW IS
THE TIME TO PHASE OUT THE SALE
OF FLUORESCENT LAMPS THANK YOU
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR
AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY VERY
GOOD THANK YOU- DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. NO I'M
SORRY I SHOULD ASK FOR-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- EIGHT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND- ASSERTION.
AFTERNOON PERSECUTE US ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING CLIENTS ALAMEDA
STOP WASTE SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA
LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE WESTERN
PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS
ARE SHIPPED COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LOCAL KOREAN WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT. ANDREA VENTURE WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD- QUESTIONS SARAH
MISTER MATHIS. VICE CHAIR VICE
CHAIR YES THEY DO HAVE ONE FOR
THE FLUORESCENT LIGHTS TO
CERTAIN ADAPTION TO TAKE INPUT
FOR LED LIGHTS OR THE WHOLE
SYSTEM'S GOING TO BE REPLACED NO
IT'S A IT'S A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
MECHANISM ALTOGETHER AND THERE
ARE AND BY THE WAY THERE ARE
EXEMPTIONS THAT WE ARE INCLUDING
IN HERE. OFFERED THERE BECAUSE
THERE STILL ARE SOME USES THAT
CANNOT BE REPLACED BY LED- IT
INCLUDES CERTAIN MEDICAL YOU
ALSO POWER CERTAIN GERMS ARTICLE
USES DISAFFECTION FLY TRAPPING
SUN TANNING THERE'S CERTAIN
THINGS I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
WHAT. CANNOT BE REPLACED QUITE
YET SO OKAY. THIS WAS ONE- GOOD
- YES IN TEN SALON. THAT'S BIG
ONE. OF BUT SEE AT NOW ALONG TO
I DID ASK SO ANY IN THE ROOM.
NOW FROM EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR-
PLEASE- ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION NAME- OUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND POSITION. GIVE HER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. WE WILL
BOTTOM LINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BYE NINE ONE SIXTY
HI MISTER CHAIRED MEMBERS JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
SUN TANNING ASSOCIATION-
SPEAKING TO THE COMMENTS BY THE
CHAD BY THE CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR
ABOUT CERTAIN COMMERCIAL UP
APPLICATIONS THERE THAT YOU THE
LIGHT GIVEN THE AMENDMENTS WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
THANKS THE OFFER FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ALKALINE ONE OF
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE BACK FROM
BEHALF OF RETHINK WAIT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
EMPLOYEE ON BEHALF OF CARE CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE ONE FIFTY
THREE. NINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN MEMBERS MICHAEL THAT UP
WITH THE PRAYER IN THE KEIGHLEY
ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE HOURLY-
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS MICHAEL STOLEN FROM
CLASS AND THE CLEAN LIGHTING
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT THE NINE ONE SIX
THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI THIS IS LISA COLBERT
FROM THE RESPONSIBLE PURCHASING
NETWORK IN A RENTED CALIFORNIA
VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THAT. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS GEORGE
BENNETT ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
TRUNK AFTER COVERED IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NINE ONE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JIM LINDBERG
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
. VERY I'M GONNA FIRST OUR CALL
FOR A QUORUM SO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM CORK BY CORK
HOME COURT HERE. SUBMIT SMITH
HERE PRESENT ARAMBULA KALRA CARS
HERE BENNETT AND IT'S HERE
CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA GARCIA
IS HERE MATHIS. MATHIS HERE
MORETZ WHO G. WALDRON WE HAVE A
QUORUM. I GOOD- FIRST I WANT TO
THANK MISTER BENNETT FOR BEING-
PINCH HITTER TODAY AS WELL AS
MISTER CALDERON. AND SO FOR THE
QUESTIONS FOR MR POWER. THERE
BEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU KNOW JUST USE MY CLOTHES
ACTUALLY FURTHER SPECIFY MY
ANSWER BECAUSE I THINK- MY
UNDERSTOOD LESSEN YOUR QUESTION
WAS ACTUALLY THE ELEMENT IS
DIFFERENT BUT- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BALLASTS SO
100% OF CFL BALLASTS CAN ACCEPT.
LEDS 93% OF THE NEAR BALLOTS
GONNA SET LEDS THAT BEING SAID
WE DON'T HAVE TO NECESSARILY
REPLACE THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE LIGHTING JUST SIMPLY
REPLACEABLE. THAT BEING SAID THE
ARISTOCATS RIGHT BUT- SECOND.
OUR SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND NO MORE QUESTIONS- YOU'VE
DEALT WITH THAT YOU'RE CLOSE WHY
NOT ALL RIGHT- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL REASON
BEING I USED. SHARE ON WEEK DAYS
WAS ALWAYS A PAIN SO I DON'T
THINK VERY MANY OF THE
FLUORESCENCE ACTUALLY WERE
DISPOSED OF PROPERLY. SO THIS IS
A REAL ADVANCE. ALL RIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY TWO
OH EIGHT KALRA THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE FLOOR CORK BY CORK
ICE SMITH. SMITH NO ARAMBULA
KALRA THANK KALRA HIGH BENNETT
BENNETT I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I MATHIS. MATHIS
KNOW WHAT A TO G. WALDRON. WELL
WITH THE- ABOUT OPEN YEAH SO
IT'S FOR VOTES AND WE NEED ONE
MORE- YES LET'S DO CONSENT AND
THEN WILL ALSO GO THROUGH THE
STONES BUILT. THANK YEAH WILL BE
PRESENTED AND ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IT'S COMPRISED OF ITEM NINE AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT BLOOM
AND ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT O'DONNELL BOTH
WITH THE MOTION DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CONSENT. CORK BY
CORK HI SMITH. SMITH I ARAMBULA
KALRA KALRA AYE BENNETT BENNETT
I CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I MATHIS MATHIS I WOULD
LIKE TO CHANGE. WALDRON. WE HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES TO PASS THE
CALENDAR VERIFIED SO THAT IS
FANTASTIC NOW WE HAVE A B.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR STONE. SO
ALL RIGHT AND THIS IS ABOUT
STATE OWNED WASHING MACHINES-
WITHOUT MICROFIBER FILTRATION
I'M RECOMMENDING AND I FELT.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR STONE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORK BY CORK I
SMITH. SMITH NO ARAMBULA. KALRA
KALRA AYE BENNETT BENNETT I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I MATHIS. MATHIS NO MODE
SWITCHING WALDRON SO WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN AS WELL AS FOR TARA-
SO WE HAVE A NO AUTHORS IN THE
AUDIENCE SO. MISS GARCIA PLEASE
BRING YOUR BILL FORWARD. RIGHT
YOU KNOW. THROWING THE BUTTONS
IN THE HOME. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. WHAT. THANK YOU- THE
SEARCH MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR
FOURTEEN I'M HERE PERCENT AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTH FOURTEEN.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO FOLLOW CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS BEFORE APPROVING
AND BUILDING A NEW SCHOOL.
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO MEET
THE SAME REQUIREMENTS AS PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BEFORE BUILDING A NEW
SCHOOL. AS A RESULT THERE ARE
CASES IN CALIFORNIA OVER SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN BUILT AND POTENTIALLY
UNSAFE LOCATION NEAR SOURCES OF
HAZARDOUS EMISSIONS SUBSTANCES
OR WASTE FOR EXAMPLE IN FREMONT
A PRIVATE SCHOOL WAS BUILT RIGHT
NEXT DOOR TO A CEMENT PLANT
EXPOSING THE CHILDREN AND STAFF
TO HARMFUL. AIR TOXICS IN MY OWN
BACKYARD AND CUT A HEY THERE
WERE PLANS TO BUILD A NEW
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL ON LAND THAT
CONTAINS TOXIC SUBSTANCES
INCLUDING LEAD AND ARSENIC. AB
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN ENSURES THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA BY REQUIRING PRIVATE.
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS TO IDENTIFY
NEARBY SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION
CONSULT WITH A LOCAL OR DISTRICT
DETERMINE THAT A PROPERTY IS NOT
HAZARDOUS IT'S NOT A HAVE TO
STATE. OR STATE THAT CAN
POTENTIALLY RELEASE HAZARDOUS
EMISSIONS UP SENSORS OR WAIT
THIS BILL SIMPLY CREATES PARITY-
AND ENSURES THAT OUR EARTH
STUDENTS THE MATTER OF THEIR AT
A PUBLIC PRIVATE OR CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE SAFE. FROM HAZARDOUS
WASTE. SINCE ESPECIALLY AT I'VE
- WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A AB.
WITH THE BAY AREA- QUALITY.
DISTRICT TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. AND ON THE PHONE I HAVE
AT LEAST CLOSE RIGHT DALY THE
LAWYER FOR THE CUTTING ALLIANCE
FOR JUSTICE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR CORK AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M ALLEN ABS
LEGISLATIVE OFFICER WITH THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT AND SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN. WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TO PROTECT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH. IN CURRENT
LAW PRIOR TO CONSTRUCTING A NEW
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR PUBLICLY FUNDED
CHARTER SCHOOL. SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM SEVERAL ACTS OF DUE
DILIGENCE TO BETTER ENSURE THE
HEALTH OF THEIR FUTURE STUDENTS
SCHOOL STAFF. THEY DETERMINE
THAT THE PROPERTY TO BE BUILT
UPON IS NOT A CURRENT OR FORMER
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE OR
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES RELEASE
SITE. AND THEY CONSULT WITH
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES AND
MAKE A FINDING THAT THE HEALTH
RISKS OR OTHER POLLUTION
SOURCES. DO NOT AND WILL NOT
CONSTITUTE AN ACTUAL OR
POTENTIAL ENDANGERMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO PERSONS WHO WOULD
ATTEND OR BE EMPLOYED AT THE
SCHOOL. THIS INCLUDES WORKING
WITH THE LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT OR AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. BY BY BO
PERMITTED AND NON PERMITTED
FACILITY WITHIN THAT DISTRICTS
AUTHORITY. INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO FREEWAYS ANOTHER BUSY
TRAFFIC CORRIDORS LARGE
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS.
RAILYARDS ALL WITH IT AND- MY
PROPOSED SITE THAT MIGHT
REASONABLY ANTICIPATED BE
ANTICIPATED TO EMIT HAZARDOUS
AIR EMISSION. THIS IS BERMAN.
YOU DEPRIVE. US IN ORDER. AND
WHILE WE ARE NOT CLAIMING THAT A
LARGE NUMBER OF SCHOOL ARE
POORLY SET. INCREASING USE
DENSITY IN RE PURPOSING INFILL
THREE THE- THAT WITHOUT SIMILAR
DUE DILIGENCE FUTURE SCHOOLS MAY
BE CONSTRUCTED IN THE VICINITY
OF POLLUTION SOURCES.
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSE CHILDREN IN
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AND CREATE AN
UNHEALTHY WORK ENVIRONMENT. AB
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN REQUIRES THE
SCHOOL AUTHORITIES TO ASSESS THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE IN AIR POLLUTION
CONDITIONS ON IN IN THE VICINITY
OF THE POST SCHOOL. TOOK
KNOWLEDGE OF THIS INFORMATION
AND IF NECESSARY TO USE IT IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS
AND CAN. THEIR ON BEHALF THEIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT AT THE DATE
AND THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BROUGHT THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU- VERY GOOD ND
WE HAVE ONE OTHER. WITNESS A
LEASE PERCENT DAILY- ATTORNEY
FOR THE CUT HE ALLIANCE FOR
JUSTICE ON THE PHONE LINE POLICE
IF YOU CAN JUST START SPEAKING
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU. THANK
YOU HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBER.
MY NAME IS COOPER DALY AND I'M
WITH. A LOT. AFTER ALL RIGHT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND DISCRIMINATION
LAW FIRM. WELL CURRENT HELLO LAW
BY THE REQUIREMENTS THE CLEANUP
OF HAZARDOUS THREE ON PUBLIC BY
. AND GIVEN THE WAY I'M HOW
AGENCIES THAT RICHARD OF THE BUT
THERE'S BEEN YOU BRING ME
READING BACK TO IT. NOT SO. WHAT
CHARTER SCHOOL. MOST IMPORTANTLY
BOB DEPARTMENT OF PROCTER. ALL
HAVE BEEN FORWARDED TO THE
REQUIRED NOT PUBLIC. IT IS NOT
HAVE THE STATEMENT OR DEMOCRATS
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC. I
CONSEQUENTLY. OKAY YEAH.
GLUED TO THE FALL IN THE LOCK MY
CLIENT HAD WOULD BE THE CITY
DOING SURE IMPROVE APPROPRIATE
ENVIRONMENTAL OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROPOSED. WELL WE PREVAILED ARE
LOCKED YOU BY THAT. AND UNMANNED
AND- I'M NOT VERY BY AND A
FIGHTING THE ISSUE BROWN. THE
CURRENT RECENTLY UNFAIRLY THE
BURDEN OF IMPORT AND OVER I'M
PRIVATE THEM AND BUILD. IMPACT
INCOME COMMUNITIES. HOW ARE.
LARGE OF BLACK INDIGENOUS AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR OFTEN HAVEN'T
BEEN COMPENSATION CHEN AND TALK
IN. HI PAY FOR EXAMPLE- MAKING
THE NINE SEVENTH BUT YOU NEED
NOT IMPACT BY IN. THOUGH THE GET
ONLY POINT WHERE MY- THIRTY
AFRICAN THANK. AND I'M THE FIRE
. EIGHT YOU WERE BUILT ON TOP
THE AGING PROCESS THANK 95% OF
THE POPULATION HOW TO CREATE A
BLACK.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF AND
WITHOUT MY FIRM PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED BUT ALL
RIGHT THEY NEVER MET THE
CHALLENGE. ALONG ZERO VIDAK
PEOPLE ALL REMEMBER FOR IN OF
ENSURING CORP I'M PRIVATE AND
GRAPHICS HM IT WILL REQUIRE
PRIOR AND CHARTER SCHOOLS RIGHT
DOWN NEARBY AND LOOK. YEAH MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHAT YEAH YEAH JERK
THANK BROWN THE- AND CLEAN UP OF
HAZARDOUS LOOKS LIKE. HAD TWENTY
TWO FOURTEEN A DOCTOR W. ACCOUNT
MY CLIENT BUT NOW HAVE HAD OUR
LAWSUIT AFTER. AND. THE REASON I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR
SUPPORT I HOPE FOR A. TWENTY
FOUR.
A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WE
BELIEVE THAT THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE ON THE PHONE LINE
- SO FIRST OF ALL- VERY GRACIOUS
HOOLAHAN IF YOU SPEAK UP WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU.
ON BEHALF OF PTSD AND SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN. PTSD IS A NONPROFIT
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR TO
ADDRESS THE SINGLE GREATEST
HURDLE THAT FACE URBAN CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND THAT SECURING
ADEQUATE FACILITIES. MY THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE TO THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LAND
DEVELOPMENT AS A CIVIL ENGINEER
LAND SURVEYOR FORMER PUBLIC
WORKS DIRECTOR IN THE CURRENT
PLANNING COMMISSIONER. PROVIDE
ME A SECOND SIGNIFICANT
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LOCAL
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS AND AGENCIES
DOCKING IMPACTS RESULTING FROM
BURDENSOME PROCESSING
REQUIREMENTS PRIVATE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE SUBJECT TO RIGOROUS
LOCAL AGENCY REQUIREMENTS FOR
ENTITLEMENT AND PERMITTING THAT
INCLUDES EQUAL AND REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE. PUBLIC REVIEW AND
COMMENT THE PROCESS RESULTS IN
FAVORITE COMPLIANT PROJECTS THAT
ADDRESS LOCAL COMMUNITY CONCERNS
AB TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN CHANGES
TO THIS PROCESS CONFLICT WITH
LOCAL MUNICIPAL CODES AND THAT
DUPLICATED STATE LEVEL PROJECT.
REVIEW SENATE REQUIREMENTS
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE PROJECT AND
TIME. MAKING IN OUR DIFFICULT
PROCESS CHILD AND OVER. LOCAL
AND AGENTS STAFF. IF ENACTED
THIS BILL WILL HAVE A VERY REAL
IMPACT FROM CURRENT P. CST
PROJECTS FOR EXAMPLE ARE BE
TECHNICAL HIGH SCHOOL. WHICH HAS
INITIATED AN ENTITLEMENT PROCESS
TO DEVELOP A PERMANENT HOME FOR
IT SCHOOL. SCHOOLS MOVED
LOCATIONS MORE THAN SEVEN TIMES
IN TWENTY ONE YEARS. THE STUDENT
POPULATION IS MORE THAN 89%
MINORITY UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY
AND THEIR GRADUATION RATE IS ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. THE PROJECT
ENTITLEMENT INCLUDE SEQUIN VERY
MENTAL SUBSTANTIVE AND
SUCCESSFUL REDEVELOPMENT WILL
BRING THIS FACILITY BACK TO LIFE
BENEFITING THE COMMUNITY AS WELL
AS THE STUDENTS. AB TWENTY TWO
FOURTEENTH NEW REQUIREMENTS
EFFECTIVE JANUARY ONE WILL CAUSE
DELAY INCREASED COSTS MAKE THIS
PROJECT NEAR IMPOSSIBLE. I THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU- NOW WE HAVE JOHN LANGER.
THEIR DEMANDS NAME PENTAGON INTO
TOWN. THANKS CHAIR MEMBERS- JOHN
LINGER I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION I THINK MITCHELL
AND- HIGHLIGHTED A LOT OF THE
EXISTING PROCESSES THAT WE GO
THROUGH ON THE ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL BUT WOULD LIKE TO JUST
MAKE. TWO QUICK POINTS- ON THE
BILL FIRST THERE CONTINUES TO BE
AN ASSERTION THAT THIS BILLS
SIMPLY BRINGS PARITY BETWEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS BY- UP APPLYING THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS STATE REQUIREMENTS
TO THEM WHEN IT COMES TO SCHOOL
CITING I WOULD SAY THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT MISLEADING
CONSIDERING THE LOCAL RIGOROUS
LOCAL REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE
TO GO THROUGH. PLACING
ADDITIONAL STATE REQUIREMENTS ON
TOP OF THAT ACTUALLY CREATES
FURTHER INEQUITY- AND NOT PARITY
BETWEEN THE TWO- TYPES OF
SYSTEMS- ED THEY LOCAL OR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE ALSO YOU KNOW
EXEMPTS FROM ALL THOSE LOCAL-
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE ARE-
SUBJECT ALSO MAKE THAT POINT.
I'M AND THEN FINALLY- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE ALSO GIVEN
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR FACILITIES-
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO LOCAL AND
STATE FOR- BOND FUNDING CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE VERY VERY RARELY
EVER GIVEN THOSE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES AND WE PRIMARILY
HAVE TO FUND ARE PROJECTS OUT
OF- GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS ARE
UP OUR GENERAL OPERATING BUDGET
SORRY- AND SO ANYTHING THAT WE
HAVE TO SPEND. OUT OF OUR
GENERAL PRETTY BUDGET GETS TAKEN
OUT OF THE CLASSROOM AND SO I
THINK WE CONVERSATIONS GOING ON
FOR A COUPLE YEARS WE'VE BEEN
VERY CONSISTENT IN OUR POSITION
ON THIS IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE
STATE REQUIREMENTS ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS FOR OUR FACILITIES THEN
THERE NEEDS TO BE A OVERSIGHT.
FLEXIBILITY IT IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS GET
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR THOSE PROJECTS OR
ELSE WE'RE JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CHARTER
SCHOOLS- FACE EXTREME
DIFFICULTIES IN DEVELOPING THAT
THEIR PROPERTIES AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE- THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN A
POSITION- NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION YEAH YOU CAN SIT THERE
IN CASE OUR QUESTION A PROBLEM.
THERE BEING NO ONE IN THE ROOM
WELL NOW ASK COULD BE EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR. TO ASK THOSE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN. TO GIVE US
THEIR NAME OUR ORGANIZATION IF
ANY AND THEIR POSITION ON AB.
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN- EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FOURTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
AB. TWENTY FOUR FOURTEEN. AND
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST. WHEN
THEY WILL GO LINE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN CORRECT. NINE
ONE EIGHTY SIX. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS A BACK ON FROM
BOSTON LINK AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ITSELF. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS GEORGE
BRED THEM A PROPERTY OWNER IN
THE CITY OF CUTTING HAY AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TO. FOUR.
THANK YOU. AGAIN THAT IS AND-
OPPOSITION. S. ONE AND THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN
KIEL. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. ARM
LET'S SEE OUR QUESTIONS MISTER
MAHER CG THANK YOU I- APOLOGIZE
FOR. GETTING HERE A LATE AND SO
I MAY HAVE MISSED SOME TESTIMONY
BUT- THE QUESTION FOR THE BAY
AREA HEY KIM D. IF YOU HAVEN'T
ALREADY COVERED THIS ARM COULD
COULD YOU OF- GIVE EXAMPLES OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT- THAT HAVE
FOR A- HAVE THIS PROBLEM OF
DEALING WITH A HAZARDOUS WASTE
SITE TAKE I KNOW THAT THERE'S
ONE IN THE- SUMMER GARCIA'S
DISTRICT CUTTING A TO-
SPECIFICALLY IN. THE BAY AREA
VACANTE IS. BUT YES ASSEMBLY
MARTUCCI- SO OUR OUR ORIGINAL-
WHAT. WHAT BROUGHT ABOUT THIS-
THIS BILL PROPOSAL IN THE BAY
AREA WHAT WASN'T A CHARTER
SCHOOL WAS RESULT OF A PRIVATE
SCHOOL CITING AND IN THE STREETS
VERSION OF THIS IS A PRIVATE
SCHOOL- COMPANY WANTED TO EXPAND
THEIR PRIVATE SCHOOL NETWORK THE
PURCHASE TO INDUSTRIAL LAND.
FROM INDUSTRIAL FACILITY THAT
HAD A MET WITH THE AIR DISTRICT
IT HAD A- A CEMENT PLANT IT HAD-
ROB AND GRAVEL- OUTFIT IT HAD
DEL A LANDSCAPING BUSINESS- THIS
INDUSTRIAL FACILITY SOLD- LANDS
TO THE PRIVATE SCHOOL COMPANY-
THE- THE CITY. OF PLANNING TO.
THE CITY OF. I IN IN OUR
OPINION- ALLOWED THE THIS THE
SCHOOL SITE TO BE BUILT WITHOUT
WHAT WITHOUT REQUIRING ANY
CONTACT WITH THE AIR DISTRICT OR
D. T. S. C. THE SCHOOL WAS BUILT
AND PARENTS WERE THEN. ON THE
FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL WHEN THEY
WERE CHILDREN AND SAW THE OF THE
SMOKESTACK FROM THE CEMENT PLANT
AND INDUSTRIAL OPERATIONS THAT
WERE GOING ON BACKSTORY IN BRING
RIPS UP. YOUR THE PUBLIC STARTED
SHOWING UP AT THEIR TO MEETINGS
IN DOING RESEARCH BUT WE JUST.
TO OTHERS FIREMEN FOR FIRST
PUBLIC SCHOOL WHICH DO NOT A FOR
PRICE SCHOOL AND- CHOI SCHOOL.
RELATED TO AN OF BEING ATTEMPT
HE HAS THIS VISION YOUR RISK
GOING TO BE BUILT INSIDE. SO
THIS WILL COVER THAT THAT THAT
IF THIS. LAW THAT. HAPPENED YES
WE WOULD NEVER END AND THE
QUESTION FOR THE CHARTIST-
REPRESENTATIVE OF. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE ZONING WAIVER
AUTHORITY WHEREAS- COURSE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DO NOT. HOW DOES
THAT- DOES THAT IN ANY WAY
AFFECT. CHARTERS NOPE
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
REQUIREMENT TO COMPLY WITH
SYKORA- REQUIREMENTS. I DON'T
THINK IT MATTERS IN A MINUTE
I'LL GO AHEAD MADE ME HAPPY GOOD
. I'M SORRY AGREED TO HAND SO-
WHEN A CHARTER SCHOOL GOES FOR
ENTITLEMENT YOU MUST GO THROUGH
AN ENTITLEMENT PROCESS WE DON'T
HAVE THE EXEMPTIONS THAT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS HAVE WHEN YOU GO TO THAT
ENTITLEMENT PROSTITUTES USUALLY
CONDITION USED HER OR SOMETHING
OF THAT IT MUST COMPLY WITH
EQUAL- WE- HAVE. MANY SIDE KERR
GOING THROUGH IT AND TO IT VERY
ROBUST PROCESS. IN IN ADDITION
TO. THAT PROCESS YOU ALSO GET
THE- A REQUIREMENT TO DEAL WITH
THE CONCERNS OF THE LOCAL AREA
WHICH HONESTLY PUBLIC SCHOOLS DO
NOT COMPLY WITH THAT- YEAH I
HAVE BEEN A FORMER PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR AND BEEN INVOLVED IN
MANY MANY MANY. PROJECTS FROM
THAT SITE AND READ OF FROM THE
PUBLIC WORKS CAMPUS OF THIS
DOCUMENTS AND- IT'S ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE WHEN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS COME IN BECAUSE YOU DO.
GREAT EARLY YOU KNOW WHERE TO
LOOK AGENCY IN ENTIRETY ALMOST-
WHERE IS THE CHARTER SCHOOL IN
THE PRIVATE DON'T THAT YOU
ACTUALLY MUST COMPLY WITH ALL
THE ISSUES FOUND. AND IT'S
ERODING IS TO SAY THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
CLUB BECAUSE THEY DO. BUT I'M
GOING TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL
REPRESENTATIVE I MEAN THIS BILL
IS PROPOSING THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH THE STATE
REQUIREMENTS- I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ABOUT HOW. CHARTER
SCHOOLS CAN GO OUT FOR BONDS BUT
IN TERMS OF ENSURING. THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE LOCATED IN
SAFE LOCATIONS THE CHILDREN OF
EMPLOYEES ARE LOCATED IN SAFE
LOCATIONS I. RIGHT I'M HAVING A
HARD TIME SEEING WHY CHARTER
SCHOOLS WOULD NOT TO OR SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
SIXTEEN SAME STATE REQUIREMENTS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE IN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SAFE. SIDES YEAH
I THINK IT'S JUST AN ISSUE OF-
ADDITIONAL PROCESSES TO GO
THROUGH- IF WE DIDN'T HAVE. THE
LOCAL PROCESSES THAT WE HAD TO
GO THROUGH SIMILAR TO THE WAY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO AND WE JUST
HAD A STATE. LEVEL REQUIREMENT
SIMILAR TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAN
IT BE A MUCH DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION BUT PLACING A STATE
REQUIREMENT IN A STATE PROCESS
ON TOP OF IN ADDITION A EXISTING
LOCAL PROCESS THAT TAKES QUITE A
LONG TIME AS WELL. JUST CREATES
FURTHER DELAYS AND- MORE TIME
AND MORE MORE MONEY AND SO WE
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT STATE.
REQUIREMENT THEN IT SHOULD BE-
IN PARITY WITH WITH THE WAY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE TREATED. IN
THIS LOW. VETERANS PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SO HOW TO COMPLY WITH
THE- LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
REQUIREMENTS. ALL THE ALL THE
FOR TO MARRY- GRACE BUT I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT IS ACCURATE I THINK
THERE HAVE WHERE B- IT'S A REAL
CHALLENGE I'LL BE HONEST WITH
YOU- SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
REGULARLY STATE THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE TO SUBMIT TO OR COMPLY.
WITH LOCAL AGENCY AND THEY WILL.
NOT SUBMIT TO THE LOCAL AGENCY
FOR THE- AND THEY WILL IGNORE-
THE LIST PROCESS HE- IT HAPPENS
IT HAPPENS CONSTANTLY- THE
CHARTERS IN THE PRIVATE. IT'S
INTERESTING TO ME THAT THERE'S
THIS IDEA THAT YOU DON'T COMPLY
WITH THE STATE REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE YOU DO- BOTH. PROJECTS
AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT IS THERE
A STATE- AT SCHOOL OR PRIVATE
CHARTER SCHOOL THEY START WITH
PREPARING TO FACE ONE AND THAT
GETS REVIEWED ENOUGH CAN
IDENTIFY YOUR FIRST INITIAL
ISSUES. AND THEN YOU GO ON IF
THE IF THERE ARE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED IN THAT PHASE ONE
WHICH IS CONSULTANT FOR PAIRED
ON BOTH SIDES. WHETHER IT'S
GOING TO DGSE OR WHETHER IT'S
GOING TO THE LOCAL AGENCY THE
BENEFIT IS IF IT'S GOING TO A
LOCAL AGENCY IT'S USUALLY HAS A
SCOPE OF WORK FOR THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANT. THAT
WAS REVIEWED AND APPROVED BY THE
LOCAL AGENCY AND ALTHOUGH THE
DEVELOPER WOULD PAY FOR IT THE
DEVELOPERS NOT OVERSEEN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT- THE
CONTROL OF THAT CONSULTANT BY
THE LOCAL AGENCY. LITTLE
DIFFERENT. WITH DTS- EIGHT.
PREPPER OF THAT DOC IS GONNA BE
BY. THE QUOTE UNQUOTE DEVELOPER
OR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEN
COMMITTED TO DGSE. BOTH WILL
REVIEW THAT CASE ONE IF THERE
ARE ISSUES THAT ARISE AND IT
GOES TO THE NEXT UP. IN THE
LOCAL AGENCY IF IT STARTS GOING
TO STEPS IN IDENTIFYING. OF
POLLUTANTS THAT ARE OVERSEEN BY
THE- COUNTY ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
IN MANY H. AREAS. BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN HOSTILITY. BY. PORTABLE BTC
OR IT WILL GO D. T. WE CHARTERS
. THAT HOUSING WERE PROCESS
THROUGH THE LOCAL. I ITEMS CAME
UP AND THEY WERE REFERRED OVER
TO DGSE AND DTC OVERSAW THE
CLEANUP OF THE VERY S. THAT
PROCESS IS IN PLACE- SO IT'S
INTERESTING. THAT SOMEONE IS
IMPLYING THAT IT'S NOT OKAY SO
IN IT BOTTOM LINE ARE YOU SAYING
THAT. TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
HAVE TO COMPLY. HADN'T HAVE TO
COME WITH THE STATE REQUIREMENTS
BUT NOT WITH LOCAL REQUIREMENTS
WERE AS CHARTER SCHOOLS COMPLY
WITH LOCAL REQUIREMENTS. AS
CHARTER SCHOOL SHOULD GO IN MAY
DAY HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
CHOIR WHICH IS STATE
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH REGIONAL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD WHICH IS STATE
REQUIREMENTS. THEY HAVE TO ROUTE
COMPLY WITH ALL THE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS IN ADDITION THEY
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE LOCAL
AGENCY REQUIREMENTS AS WELL YOU
ALSO GET THE BENEFIT OF WHEN
THEY PROCESS THROUGH LOCAL
AGENCY. LOCAL AGENCY STAFF IS
AWARE OF THE ISSUES THAT COME
ABOUT LOCAL AGENCY DEALS WITH
HOUSING PROJECTS AND WHAT HAVE
YOU AND FISCALLY. THEY'RE
DEALING WITH WITH THINGS READ
MORE SENSITIVE- BECAUSE YOU'RE
DEALING WITH TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
TO SILLY- SO. WHEN YOU GO
THROUGH A LOCAL AGENCY. HUMAX
HAVE. A MORE THOROUGH AND
ROBUST- REVIEW AND UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN
THAT COMMUNITY IN AND AROUND
THAT SITE OKAY THANK YOU WHEN
YOU BUY PAST THAT YOU'D KNOW IT.
I JUST WANTED IF I MAY LET ME
ASSURE HANNAH. GAS THE BAY AREA
AN AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT TO A- RESPONDED IN
CONTENTION THAT. SOMEHOW
CHARTERS AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS
ALREADY HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
RIGOROUS LOCAL REVIEW. I THINK-
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT THERE'S-
WHEN YOU LOOK AT PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND IN THE REQUIREMENTS AND SEE
WHAT THERE'S- THERE'S ONE THING
THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT FROM
TRADITIONAL SEQUEL WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN.
SO NORMALLY WHEN YOU DO SEE WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE EFFECTS OF
THE PROJECT ON THE ENVIRONMENT
BUT IN IN WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PUBLIC SCHOOLS THERE IS
ALSO A- REQUIREMENT TO LOOK
OUTWARD. THE EFFECTS OF LOCAL
ENVIRONMENT ON THE PROPOSED
SCHOOL SITE INTO MY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WHEN THEY GO THROUGH THE
SITING THEY HAVE TO LOOK AT.
WHERE TO. FIRST QUARTER THEY
HAVE TO LOOK AT- IN FOR ARE FOR
THAT EMIT TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS
YOU KNOW TO ASK THE TSC IF
THERE'S HAZARDOUS MATERIALS OR
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITES NEARBY AND
THOSE REQUIREMENTS DON'T EXIST
IN A TRADITIONAL SEQUEL PROJECT
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE BUILDING A-
AN APARTMENT COMPLEX OR OR AT
THE NEW FACILITY OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY THE HEART OF WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO IS TO GET
THOSE CHARTER SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS TO TAKE THAT
OUTWARD LOOK JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
WITHIN A QUARTER MILE FOUR
THOUSAND FEET OR WHATEVER IT IS.
THAT YOU CAN IDENTIFY THOSE. HI
WE- IS A HAZARDOUS MATERIAL
SITES HAZARDOUS WASTE SITES- ERR
YOU KNOW TOXIC- EMISSION SITES
IN USE THAT IN YOUR DECISION
MAKING AND AT LEAST. YOU KNOW
GIVE GIVE YOURSELVES AND THE
PUBLIC THE- THE KNOWLEDGE OF
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING INTO WHEN
YOU BUILD THAT SO THAT SITE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
MISTER VICE CHAIR REJECTED.
COMMENTS I GUESS NOT TOO MANY
QUESTIONS BUT WHEN YOU. TAKE A
SCHOOL SITE FOR THE STATE I GOT
TO GO THROUGH ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SOLVE ISSUES. AND
CHARTER SCHOOL OR PUBLIC SCHOOL
THEY GOT TO DO THE STATE ISSUES
AND IT'S BEEN MISSION AND THE
LOCAL ISSUES THE GIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT TIME TO GO THROUGH
THERE. IT I DON'T SEE IT APPLES
FOR APPLES I SEE IT AS A MORSE
RESTRAINTS ON CHARTER SCHOOLS.
SO THEY DO NOT BUILD. OR EXPAND.
AND I THINK THAT'S AN HINDRANCE
TO THE PUBLIC THAT NEEDS
FILLING. UP MISTER TO. THANK I'M
WELL WHAT YOU ARE THAT YOU'RE
CLOSE- I'M GOING MAKE COM FOR OF
ALL WE HAVE IS OF SCHOOLS RIGHT
NOW AND THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
REQUIRED TO FIND FACILITIES SO
YOU KNOW THERE AREN'T THAT MANY
CHARTER SCHOOLS BEING BUILT
MOSTLY THEY'RE GOING INTO OLDER-
FACILITIES- SECOND. YOU KNOW I
DO SEE SOME DIFFICULTY WITH
HAVING BOTH THE STATE AND THE
LOCAL I ALSO SEE THAT DESPITE
WHAT THE WITNESSES SAID THAT
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN MISTAKES
ARE MADE BY LOCAL. I THE LOCALS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
NOW- SO I SEE SOME I SEE SOME
JUSTICE IN YOUR ARGUMENT AND I'D
SUGGEST PERHAPS THE AUTHOR COULD
FIND A WAY OF TO HAVE ONE OR THE
OTHER AGENCIES BE THE PRIMARY
AND MAKE SURE THAT. THESE
QUESTIONS OF THE EFFECT OF THE
END ALL OF THE ENVIRONMENT ON
THE SCHOOL GET LOOKED AT I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER THAT'S POSSIBLE.
AND IT'S UP TO YOU AND YOU CAN
ADD TO THAT OR NOT IN YOUR
CLOSE. BUT- I'M FINE WITH THE
BILL AS IT IS. IF THERE'S A WAY
YOU CAN MAKE IT LESS BURDENSOME
THAT'S FINE BUT- YOU KNOW WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE MISTAKES
LIKE WERE MADE WITH THE PRIVATE
SCHOOL IN THE BAY AREA OR THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AT CARNEGIE. JUST
CAN'T AFFORD TO DO THAT OUR KIDS
ARE TOO PRECIOUS SO AGAIN. I'M
QUITE HAPPY WITH THE BILL AS IT
IS BUT IF WE CAN. LIGHTEN THE
BURDEN SOMEWHAT I'M HAPPY WITH
THAT TOO. LONG AS WE GET THAT
PROTECTION SO- PLEASE MAKE CLOSE
YES I WOULD SAY THAT THAT THE
SECOND BILL THAT SOMEONE ELSE
COULD WORK ON SINCE THIS IS MY
LAST YEAR HERE. OKAY IN SESSION
AND I DON'T WANNA. CONVOLUTED
THINGS I WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS
NOT A NEW IDEA ARE YOU BILL IT'S
BEEN CHAMPIONED BY MR LEE WHOSE
MY AGE I'M NOT A DOCTOR THIS
YEAR. AND THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
HAVE CONTINUE TO MOVE- THE BOOK
THOUGH THE FIELD GOAL ON US OR
WHAT THEY WANT AND I WILL SAY
BEFORE THEY WANTED TO. TURN
INSIGHTS TO BE GRANDFATHERED IN
THIS BILL DOES THAT AND NOW
THEY'VE CHANGED TO A DIFFERENT
ARGUMENT. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
WAIVE ALL OF THE LOCAL I.
REQUIREMENTS CUT HAY DID EXACTLY
THAT. AND THE CHARTER SCHOOL
KNEW THAT THAT THAT HAD LED AN
ARSENIC AND GETTING CARE AND WE
TALK ABOUT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WHICH IS
WHAT CUT A HATE A 100% IS THOSE
KIDS DESERVE TO BE SAFE NO
MATTER WHAT IF IT'S BURDENSOME
IT'S PART OF SOME FOR A REASON
AND THEY DESERVE TO BE SAFE. OUT
THERE. I WILL SAY WE HAVE A NEW
SCHOOL IN MAY WOULD NEIGHBORING
CITY- THAT WAS BUILT ON A- SITE
THAT WAS COMPLETE. THE EIGHT
EIGHT AND IT'S ONE OF THE ONLY
NON TOXIC EFFECTS IN THE WHOLE
CITY NOW. OUT THERE ARE AND SO
THEY ARE COMPLYING AND WE'RE
EXCITED FOR THAT SCHOOL AND SO
WE WELCOME YOU SCHOOLS TO JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE OUR STUDENTS.
OUR STATE AND THE IDEA THAT
THERE'S LACK OF FUNDING OR ITS
CUMBERSOME TO ME IS IN FULL TEEN
ACTUALLY GETS IN THE DAY BECAUSE
WE SHOULD ALL HAVE THE SAME
GOAL. TO ENSURE KIDS ARE SAVE
THESE TOXICS NOT ONLY MAKE IT
SICK BUT ALSO AFFECT OUR
ABILITY. GET TO THE OUT THERE
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT
AND I'M RECOMMENDING AND LIFE OF. PARDON THE MOVE BILL ALL RIGHT
MOVED IN SECOND. OF MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHT
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN CRISTINA
GARCIA THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK. I WORK ICE
SMITH. SMITH NO ARAMBULA KALRA
KALRA AYE BENNETT BENNETT I
CRISTINA GARCIA HI CRISTINA
GARCIA I'D MATHIS MATHIS NO
MURATSUCHI WHAT A TO G. I
WALDRON. THE FACT WE HAVE FIVE
VOTES FOR THEMSELVES FIVE TWO.
THANK YOU. FOR RIGHT. I SEE
RIGHT YEAH ALL RIGHT THE NEXT
STEP IS BROUGHT I KNOW MISS
BLOOM IS BEING FOR A WHILE YOU
MIND WAITING WHILE LONGER. OKAY
MISTER BRYANT. THE BILL. WHICH.
THIS IS A AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
AND PRIOR MENTAL. FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS IN
JOB ACT JUST AS FORTY OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE. BACK IN. WE'VE BEEN
SECONDED ALL RIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD MR BRYANT GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
FIRST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR ON
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK WORKING WITH MY TEAM
ON THE ONGOING DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS BILL LANGUAGE WE ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL WORK AYE THAT'S GONE
INTO THE PROCESS THUS FAR I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN THE CALIFORNIA JUSTICE
FORTY ACT. THIS IS A BILL IN AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
LEAD THE NATION. AN INDUSTRY
INNOVATION IN EQUITY. AS WE
BUILD A SHARED FUTURE. THE
JUSTICE FORTY ACT ESTABLISHES AN
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE WITHIN THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
COMPOSED OF STAKEHOLDERS FROM
IMPACTED FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
LABOR. TRIBAL COMMUNITIES AND
OTHERS TO RECOMMEND PROJECTS.
AND KEEP CONSISTENCY WITH THE
FEDERAL JUSTICE FORTY EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND TRACK THE EXPENDITURES
OF FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT IN
JOBS THAT. THE FRAMEWORK WE SAID
IS THAT 40% OF THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS GO TO PROJECTS SERVING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WITH
AN ADDITIONAL TEN PERCENT.
SPECIFICALLY EARMARKED FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WE'VE
OPERATIONALIZED DISADVANTAGED
USING THE CALAVERAS SCREEN AND I
KNOW THE CHALLENGE WITH THAT IS
THAT OFTEN THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE EXTREMELY POOR THAT.
HAVE GOOD AIR QUALITY. IN GET
LEFT OUT OF THAT ANALYSIS AND TO
BE MINDFUL AND THOUGHTFUL OF
THAT AND TO INCORPORATE THAT
INTO OUR A HOLISTIC
CONCEPTUALIZATION OF
DISADVANTAGED WE'VE ADDED AN
EARMARKED SPECIFICALLY FOR JUST
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. IT'S
TIME TO MAKE A COMMITMENT TO THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT
OF THE PROCESS IN HARM BY
DECADES OF BAD CHOICES. ENDED
NEWS USE NEW RESOURCES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO STEP UP
AND HELP. THE RESULT OF THE LACK
OF INVESTMENTS IN CLEAN AND
SHARP CLEAR. THE COMMITTEES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE LIVING WITH
THE LEGACIES OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HARM. FROM CHOICES FROM DECADES
AGO. AND EVEN MORE RECENT
CHOICES. PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE
U. S. ARE EXPOSED 238% HIGHER
LEVELS OF NITROGEN DIOXIDE. THAT
OUR WHITE NEIGHBORS IN L. A.
COUNTY ONE IN TEN CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH ASTHMA. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN WEST ADAMS A
PART OF MY DISTRICT NEARLY 30%
OF PEOPLE REPORTED BEING UNABLE
TO DO ACTIVITIES DUE TO SITE
OWNERS. FIFTEEN POINT 5%
REPORTED WEEKLY ASTHMA SYMPTOMS
AND THERE WAS A 25% RATE OF
PEOPLE WITH ASTHMA RELATED ER
VISITS. IN WEST OAKLAND. THE
BLACK AS PART OF OAKLAND. IS THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF AIR POLLUTION.
IT'S LONG PAST TIME TO MOVE
FORWARD. AND MOVE FORWARD
TOGETHER WITH GOOD JOBS AND
CAREERS. IN AN ENERGY EFFICIENT
CALIFORNIA WITH NEW
OPPORTUNITIES. THAT ARE ALREADY
OPENING FOR CARPENTERS
MACHINISTS WELDERS ELECTRONIC
EQUIPMENT ASSEMBLERS
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTISTS
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANTS
ACCOUNTANTS. TRUCK DRIVERS
ROOFTOP ROOFERS AGRICULTURAL
LABOURS. INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL PRODUCE.
BELOW JOBS FOR EVERYONE.AND WE
KNOW THAT WHEN COMMUNITY VOICES
COME TO THE TABLE THE RESULTS
ARE ALSO BETTER AGAIN. FOR
EVERYONE. BUT THIS ISN'T GONNA
HAPPEN UNLESS WE ARE CLEAR ABOUT
OUR GOALS. AND WHAT THIS TASK
FORCE IS LOOKING TO DO IS AGAIN
REVIEW AND RECOMMEND PROJECTS.
MARK 440% OF THE FEDERAL CLIMATE
DOLLARS COMING IN FOR CLEAN
ENERGY AND INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
THOSE FUNDS TO GO TOWARDS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
AN ADDITIONAL 10% DIRECTLY FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND
HOUSEHOLD WHILE UPHOLDING
SKILLED AND TRAINED LABOR
STANDARDS TO GIVE TESTIMONY WITH
ME TODAY. I'M JOINED BY MELISSA
ROMANO FROM ENVIRO LOADERS. AND
SCHOENING LEGAL FROM POLICY LEAD
ON THE PHONE. OR IN PERSON. OKAY
GO AHEAD MELISSA ROMERO THANK
YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
BERMAN TO VOTERS IN THE YEARS
AHEAD CALIFORNIA HAS A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE MASSIVE
INVESTMENTS IN THE CLIMATE
RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE
KNOW WE NEED TO COMBAT THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WHAT WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE MADE EQUITABLY PRIORITY IS
IN COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED FROM
THE MOST OF THE LEGACY OF TOXIC
POLLUTION AND DISINVESTMENT. THE
FEDERAL JUSTICE FORTY INITIATIVE
IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
JUSTICE FORTY OF THE FEDERAL
COMMITMENT TO DIRECT 40% OF
CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WELL THIS IS A
STRONG FEDERAL GOAL THAT WE
SUPPORT STATES WILL ULTIMATELY
DETERMINE MUCH OF THE DETAILS OF
HOW THIS IS CARRIED OUT AB
TWENTY FOURTEEN IS A CRUCIAL AND
NECESSARY BILL TO ENSURE THE
EQUITABLE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
JUSTICE FORTY INITIATIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND TO ADVANCE THE
DECADES LONG FIGHT TO DISMANTLE
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM AND ENSURE
THAT ALL COMMUNITIES CAN THRIVE
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN WILL
COMMIT TO JUSTICE FORTY BY
REQUIRING 40% OF FEDERAL CLIMATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDS TO BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH
AN ADDITIONAL 10% INCOME IT IF
UNTIL AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN
WILL BE A MODEL FOR THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY OF HOW STATES
DELIVER THE PROMISE OF JUST
FORTY. AND TO ENSURE THAT THESE
LONG OVERDUE INVESTMENTS THAT
ADVANCE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC USTICE FOR THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
SEEN THROUGH THE FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR EITHER THANK YOU. THANKYOU
VERY MUCH- NEXT ON THE PHONE
LINE. ACCIONES LEGAL- PLEASE
JUST SPEAK UP AND WILL BE ABLE
TO HEAR YOU. AFTERNOON CHAIR
CORKING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JEREMY PLEASE GO ON I'M
A MANAGING DIRECTOR POLICY
LINCOLN NATIONAL RESEARCH AND
ACTION INSTITUTE BASED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA HOW WE INVEST
IN INFRASTRUCTURE THE PROJECTS
WE FIND THE PLACES THAT STAND.
ON THE JOB PATHWAYS WE CREATE IS
A REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AND
PRIORITIES OF THE SOCIETY FOR
TOO LONG THE CHOICES WE'VE MADE
HAVE CREATED AND REINFORCED
SPEAK RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
DIVIDES MEETING MANY L<c.cyan>G COMING</c>
TO ME AND OF COLOR COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT THE MOST BASIC FEATURES
OF A HEALTHY AND SUSTAINABLE
NEIGHBORHOOD. TODAY THEY'RE AN
ESTIMATED ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS BY WATER SYSTEMS
THAT DON'T MEET SAFETY STANDARDS
AND MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
LIVING COMMUNITIES FOR LAND USE
PLANNING INDUSTRIAL CITING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE DECISIONS OVER
GENERATIONS OF CONCENTRATED
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION
CONTRIBUTING TO HIGHER RATES OF
ASTHMA HEART DISEASE AND OTHER
HEALTH BURDENS. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSIDERS HOW TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE CRUMBLING ROADS AGING
WATER SYSTEMS UPDATED UTILITY
SYSTEMS AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISMANTLE THE STRUCTURES OF
RACISM THAT HAVE DIVIDED US AND
BUILD A MORE JUST AND INCLUSIVE
SOCIETY THAT ALLOWS EVERYONE TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL. THE
POLICY LIKE WE HAVE A MODEL
EQUITY IS THE SUPERIOR GROWTH
MODEL THIS MEANS THE EQUITY
DRIVEN INVESTMENTS WILL CREATE
NEW JOBS AND BOLSTER LONG TERM
COMPETITIVENESS FALL AT THE SAME
TIME ENSURING THAT EVERYONE
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BENEFIT FROM IT
. CLOSE IT TWENTY FOUR NINETY
DELIVERS ON THAT BY EMBEDDING
EQUITY INTO OUR INVESTING IN
HARD FUND CHECK COMING THAT
GREATEST NEED THIS IS SOME AND
BUT IT'S ALSO A BETTER TYPE
ABOUT ECONOMIC GROWTH BENEFITS
EVERY FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY DO WE HAVE MANY
MEMBERS IN THE HEARING ROOM WE
WANT TO- TESTIFIED SUPPORT WITH
NAME POSITION AND- ORGANIZATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON KYLE JONES WITH
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MMHM. REBECCA
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT GREAT. I'M NOW WE
HAVE MISTER ADAM QUINONEZ IN
HERE IN PERSON TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ADAM. ARE YOU STILL
HERE IT ACTUALLY ARE THERE YOU
ARE ON THE- LINE. YEAH THE MUCH-
AARON MEMBERS ADDING KIANA SOME
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES I
RESPECTFULLY WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL. APPLE REPRESENTS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY PUBLIC NONPROFIT
WATER AGENCIES MANY OF THEM-
CERTIFIED BANDS COMMUNITIES. WE
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN WE HAVE
ADVOCATED IN THE PAST FOR
FUNDING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. INCLUDING SB TWO
HUNDRED FROM TWENTY NINETEEN
WHICH ESTABLISHED THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER BOND.
ABOUT FUND PROVIDES A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET
WATER QUALITY STANDARDS. OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN WITH AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETEEN IS THE DEFINITION
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY WHICH
THE AUTHOR TOUCHED ON. IT IT'S A
VERY NARROW DEFINITION AND
LEAVES OUT MANY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I'M INCLUDING SOME OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IDENTIFIED AT
DISADVANTAGE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER BOND. I'M ALMOST NO CAN NO
OF SAC WE BE I DO. AS THE CITY.
DESPITE THE FACT SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE THE POOREST IN
THE STATE. SO THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT WOULD NO LONGER BE
CONSIDERED DISADVANTAGED WOULD
HAVE TO COMPETE FOR MORE LIMITED
RESOURCES- AT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IDENTIFIED THE 10% OF
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE IDENTIFIED
BECAUSE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL THAT
USES COUNT BY RESTRAINT
DEFINITION OF DISADVANTAGED
WHICH FAILED TO IDENTIFY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
TO MEET WATER QUALITY STANDARDS.
CALAVERAS BEING WOULD DEVELOP TO
IDENTIFY AIR QUALITY ISSUES AND
IT'S REALLY NOT THE RIGHT TOOL
TO IDENTIFY WATER QUALITY-
CHALLENGES. THE WATER RESOURCES
AND STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD USE THAT PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE DEFINITION OF
DISADVANTAGED. WHICH ALLOWED
THEM TO DIRECT FUNDING THAT
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE WATER
QUALITY ISSUES. IN ADDITION
WHILE THIS BILL SEEKS TO BUILD
ON PRESIDENT BIDEN'S JUSTICE
FORTY IN ADDITION TO. THE
FEDERAL EFFORT IS THE GOAL ONLY
AND THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A
MANDATE THAT 40% OF FEDERAL
FUNDING BE ALLOCATED. TO A MORE
NARROW GROUP OF COMMUNITIES. NOW
WILD 40% THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER
FOR SOME TYPES OF FUNDING IT MAY
NOT BE FOR OTHERS- IN THE
FEDERAL AGENCIES ARE STILL
IDENTIFYING HOW THIS GOAL WILL
BE IMPLEMENTED. AND TO FURTHER
COMPLICATE MATTERS THEY HAVE YET
EIGHT DIFFERENT GET DEFINITION
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. SO
IF THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD- YOU
KNOW YOU COULD HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE CALIFORNIA DIRECTING
FUNDING TO COMMUNITIES. THAT MAY
NOT EVEN PASSED BY THE FEDERAL
GOAL. AS WE GET THE HEAD OF THAT
PROCESS. SO WE WOULD HOPE THAT
THIS BILL ONLINE WITH THE
FEDERAL PROCESS WHICH IS ONGOING
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
OFFICE OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS. TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL DOES NOT BE
ABOUT SOMEBODY STRUGGLING
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO IS SO MUCH
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION. THERE
BEING NONE OF WILL THEN ASK FOR
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN BRIAN.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE THAT- OUR
PEOPLE ON THE PHONES- GIVE US
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION FOR OR AGAINST AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN PLEASE
PROCEED AT&T OPERATOR. THANK YOU
FOR AND SUPPORTER OPPOITION OF
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AMBER HIGHLY
TRAINED CREDIT CONSULTING ON
BEHALF OF THE- LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL EIGHT TEN VOCAL LEARN
NEXT GEN WATER FOUNDATION AND
CLIMATE CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF TWO OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY TWO
OH FIVE YOU TOOK YOURSELF OUT.
YOU HAVE TO RE PROMPTS NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OF FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON NATALIE BACK ON BEHALF
OF. AN ACCURATE BIRTH DEFENSE
COUNSEL ACTION FUND AND SUPPORT
. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE AT ONE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HOW ON THE- RIGHT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HER NAME IS
LAURA ROSENBERGER HAIDER AND
MEMBER OF THE C. E. J. C. AND I
. REPORTER VOTE YES ON ON THE
STILL HAVE. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO STANDING AROUND HER
POLICY ADVOCATE FOR FINAL PLAN
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOT FOR THE LINE TO
TENURE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON STATING HERE WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT WE DO
HAVE STRONG CONCERNS THAT WE
RELATE TO THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
AND E'RE IN LINE WITH AQUA ON
YOUTH AND CALAVERAS SCREEN TOOL
TO IDENTIFY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN MEETING OUT A LOT
OF OUR POOR RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO
SEE IF WE CAN COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OVERLAND ONE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXAVAR LINE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
KATHY SHAPER ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ERIN WILLIAM BEHALF OF A
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
BYE TO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON JESSICA FONG ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
REPORT. NINE ONE SIX THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRY LEAR ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY SOUTH PLAN LEGISLATIVE
ALLIANCE AND THREE FIFTY SOUTH
BAY LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WON ALL THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- DECAGONAL BEHALF OF
THE ABOUT THE POP AND POPCORN
YEAH AND I STRONGLY. FOR EIGHTY
TWENTY FOUR NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME AND MODEL CUT
COULD COUNTLESS PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BENNIFER
COUNTY AND I'M A CONSTITUENT OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND SUPPORTERS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN. THANK YOU ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EXACTLY
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA GREEN NEW
DEAL COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT ONLINE TO
ALL FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
IN. FIFTY FOUR EIGHTY TWENTY
FOUR. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON I
WOULD THINK OF THAT I WITH
STRATEGIC CONCEPT IN ORGANIZING
AND QUALITY EDUCATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE TWO OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS THERESA COOPER I'M A
RESIDENT OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
TO ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
T. R. ARIANNA WITH DRINKING AND
BENNIFER OPPORTUNITY AND I'M
CALLING WITH OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWENTY FOUR NINETY.
THANK YOU NEXT TO FIND ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS BELLA GHANI CALLING
ON BEHALF OF DREAM CAR GREEN
PEARL IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT AVAILABLE LINE ONE
FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
ONE FORTY TWO. YES JENNIFER
HANNER ON BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREETING AND A STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME- THANK YOU
OPERATOR. OUR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MISTER VICE CHAIR OR
JUST MATHIS MISTER VOTER HISTORY
DID A COMMENT PRETTY MUCH FOR
THIS BUT CALIFORNIA ALREADY A
PRIORITY AT THAT PRIORITIZES
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
CURRENTLY 10% OF ALL CAP AND
TRADE AUCTION REVENUES. MUST BE
SPENT ON PROJECTS LOCATED IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. 25%
ON PROJECT THE BENEFIT THOSE
COMMUNITIES. MANY GRANTS ALSO
PRIORITIZE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THIS REGARD
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY WAY AHEAD
OF THE REST OF THE COUNTRY. SO
AT THIS TIME I THINK THIS BILL
IS UNNECESSARY. BOB GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU- MISTER
BRYANT FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON ON
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES- JUST
SOME QUESTIONS- TO CLARIFY MY
UNDERSTANDING SO THAT THE POINT
WAS MADE THAT. THAT IF THE-
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PASSES OR
DEFINES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IT IS THAT GOING TO
PRE EMPT- HOW YOUR BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO A THAT IDEA
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. NO
IT'S NOT- IT'LL BE IN
COLLABORATION IN CONCERT ONE
ANOTHER BUT THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES OR AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND LEAVE A LOT OF DISCRETION AN
OPPORTUNITY UP TO THE STATES
OKAY IN FACT I THINK OUR
LEADERSHIP COULD HAVE AN IMPACT
ON HOW THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
THINKS ABOUT WOULD DISADVANTAGE
COMMITTEE. OKAY SO- I AM I'M
SURE IT YOU YOU EVER A KNOWLEDGE
TO THE- YOU'RE YOU'RE DESIRE TO-
TO ADDRESS SOME OF AQUA'S
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW- THE
CALAVERAS GREEN LEAVES OUT A LOT
OF LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. THAT
OTHERWISE HAVE. I GUESS BETTER
AIR QUALITY- I AM SURE IT'S NOT
YOUR INTENT TO EXCLUDE THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHY WHY NOT JUST TO.
WHY NOT JUST TAKE OUT HELP
CALLIN BY OR OR OR TAKE OUT
CALAVERAS SCREEN OR SUPPLEMENT
IT WITH WHAT. YOU KNOW THE WATER
YOU KNOW HOW THEY'RE DIRECTING
TO. FUNDS SUIT TO ADDRESS- GO
ALONG COMPANIES WITH UNSAFE
DRINKING WATER ABSOLUTELY
BECAUSE THE CALAVERAS SCREEN
DOESN'T JUST USE AIR QUALITY
RIGHT IT'S A CONSTELLATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL FAILURES OVER A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME THAT A LOT
OF THESE INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS-
OR TO GO TO REMEDY. AND TO
MITIGATE RIGHT I WOULD
OPERATIONALIZE DISADVANTAGE COP
IN A HOLISTIC WAY OF TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS- YOU COULD YOU
COULD DEFINE IT BY OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH THE MOST
LIQUOR STORES FOR HER
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SCHOOLS EVERYBODY HAS
AN INTEREST ON HOW THEY CAN FIND
ITS ADVANTAGE POOR AIR QUALITY
AND POOR WATER. QUALITY OVERLAP
MATURE THIS WAYTHE WAY THAT
THEY DON'T IT'S OFTEN- MOST. OF
THIS PROXY COVERED BY LOW INCOME
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE DONE
HERE WHAT WE'VE USED 40% FOR
DISADVANTAGED OPERATIONAL. IN
THE CALAVERAS CLINTON SPENT FOR
STRICTLY LOW INCOME THOSE IT IS
THAT DON'T FIT UNDER THAT LEAVES
FIFTH PERCENT THE SIMPLEST
DOLLAR THAT COULD GO EITHER OR
BOTH. AND ALL. OUR OUR OUR- ARE
YOU ONE AQUA DISAGREEING ON WHAT
CAN BE SHOULD QUALIFY FOR THESE
I DON'T THAT WE ARE. I THINK
WE'RE HAVING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW TO DIVIDE PIE. WITHOUT
APPRECIATING THE FACT THAT IT'S
A NEW PART IN THERE ARE A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO CAN AND SHOULD BE
HELPED AND- WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO
MAKE SURE THAT COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY. NOT TO
BELABOR THE REFERENCE BUT HAVE
NOT HAD. GET A PIECE OF THIS ONE
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT ON AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THE
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE WE DO THIS
RIGHT. NOW BUT WE KNOW THE
HISTORIC CHALLENGES OR PUSH BACK
TO USING KALAN VIRAL SCREEN AS A
MEASURE ALBEIT IT'S A VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND WELL CRAFTED
MEASURE IT DOES LEAVE OUT
EXTREMELY POOR. COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE SOME OF THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS AND THOSE
EXTREMELY POOR COMMUNITIES. ARE
THOUGHT OF INCLUDED AND HAVE
BEEN IN THIS BILL FROM ITS
INCEPTION. FIVE FINALLY- YOU YOU
AND I AND OTHERS IN THIS
COMMUNITY- THAT- YOU THERE'S
THERE BEEN ONGOING ISSUES IN
TERMS OF- A LOT OF THE- THE
WORST ENVIRONMENTAL HARM COMING
FROM- REFINERIES AND OIL
DRILLING AND THAT- LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- DO YOU
FORESEE THESE DOLLARS. TO
SOMEHOW REMEDIATE- THE DALLAS
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS FROM THE
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF
REFINERIES AND OIL DRILLING
TAKING PLACE ALONG CAN
COMMITTEES A COLOR. I THINK IF
THAT'S WHAT THE JUSTICE ORTY
TASK FORCE RECOMMENDS- WITH
THEIR PROPOSALS I DON'T WANNA
JUMP AHEAD OF THE TASK FORCE'S
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT I THINK
THAT IS. ONE OF THE VISION THE
KEY OBLIGATIONS TO FIND OUT WHAT
KIND OF ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS
COULD BE REMEDIED. A REPAIRED
AND PART OF THE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE THAT WE'RE ALL BUILDING-
USING THESE DOLLARS OKAY I
SUSPECT IT'LL BE PART OF THE
CASE WITH YOU AND WITH YOUR-
PERMISSION I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR TO THIS
BILL. BE HABITAT THANK YOU. YES
BOB MISS GARCIA I THINK FIRST
AND THEN- THAT. THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT
THE- PURPOSE OF THE CALAVERAS
SCREENING AND IF COMMUNITIES ARE
LEFT BEHIND AT THIS I MEAN THAT
THE CALAVERAS SCREENING THIS
FAILING- OUT THERE IT'S MEANT TO
LOOK AT A NUMBER OF ISSUES
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION AND
HOW THAT AFFECTS OUR HEALTH. OUT
TALKING ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SIDE OF IT ALL THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT AND THAT'S
WHAT SHOULD BE MEASURED OUT
THERE IT DOESN'T MEAN
COMMUNITIES ARE LONG CONCERNED
SERVE RESOURCES A DISPLAY OF CAR
THAT THAT 10% GUARANTEED AND
THEY'RE STILL 50% OF THE PIE.
LEFT OUT THERE AND SO AS WE ARE
ARE YOU KNOW RIGHT NEW PLAN HOW
TO CUT IT UP I THINK IT'S FAIR
FOR GROUPS ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELF
ON SPEAK UP AND TRY TO GET AS
MUCH AS THEY CAN THAT'S OUR JOB
I AND I APPLAUD THAT BUT IT
SHOULD BE AT THE EXPENSE OR-
MISREPRESENTING A- TOOL THAT WE
HAVE HERE AND IN THE CAPITAL AND
CAL. SHOULD BE. OKAY. AND OTHER
PLACES OTHER SO. I A YEAR AFTER
YEAR TO. THIS IT'S- ON THE
CALAVERAS SCREENING AND IT'S
FASTER- THE COW. WE TO SELL YOUR
- YOU. TRUE IT. WILL MORE TOXIC
AND FOR THE CALIFORNIA NINE
CALIFORNIA TURNS OUT TO BE THE
CASE. THANK YOU. YEAH YEAH AT I
- I JUST GO ON RECORD AS WITH A
ELSE MY STEP AS REACHED OUT TO
YOUR STAFF ABOUT THIS CONCERN
AND- WE JUST REALLY APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN YOUR
ABILITY TO GET THIS RIGHT- AND
THAT'S PART OF WHY WE WERE I WAS
HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOTION FOR
YOUR BILL. THANK THANK YOU.
THAT'S RIGHT YOU MADE THE MOTION
FOR LEAVE ARE HAVE A MOTION.
YEAH OKAY. FROM SO MY TURN I
GUESS OKAY- HOW MUCH OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS. TO WHAT
EXTENT SO THE ACT WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT GETTING THEIR SHARE FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES I DON'T KNOW
THAT MUCH ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL CERTAINLY
THAT'S ONE OF ITEM BUT IT'S ONE
AMONG MANY IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT YEAH SO- LOOK- TO ACWA-
MISTER BRIAN HAS AN OPEN DOOR
POLICY UP I SUGGEST YOU CONTINUE
TO TALK WITH THEM I AM NOT GOING
TO TRY AND THE JUDICATA THIS
MISTER BRIAN SPENDING A LOT MORE
TIME THAN I AM- I'M HAPPY WITH
THE DIRECTION YOU'RE GOING AND
I'M HAPPY WITH YOU IS THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL AND I TRUST YOU.
CAN I DON'T THINK WE CAN. GIVE
TOO MUCH ARM TO ENVIRONMENTALLY
CHALLENGED AND- INCOME CHALLENGE
COMMUNITIES I COME FROM A
RELATIVELY PROSPEROUS COMMUNITY
. AND YOU KNOW I THINK SHOULD GO
TO THE COMMUNITIES AND- YOU KNOW
WILL WILL HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO I TRUST WILL MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION AND I'M SURE THEY'LL BE
WATER PROJECTS AND OF COURSE
THERE'S 50% THAT YOU HAVEN'T
SPOKEN TO AT ALL. AND THAT CAN
CERTAINLY GO TO WATER PROJECTS
AS WELL SO I WILL LEAVE THIS IN
YOUR HANDS. AND RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE AND- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS ITEM FIVE
AB. TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN.
MACKLOWE AFTER I'VE GOT A CLOSE
CLOSE PLEASE. THAT THE I MEAN I
APPRECIATE THE URGENCY I THINK
THERE IS URGENCY- WHAT WHAT I
HAVE BROUGHT TO THIS COMMITTEE
IS A BILL THAT BRINGS LABOR TO
THE TABLE A BILL THAT BRINGS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS TO THE TABLE.
A BILL THAT TAKES NEW FEDERAL
RESOURCES AND CREATES A- POLICY
FRAMEWORK FOR MOVING THOSE
RESOURCES TO COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY HARMED.
BY BAD INVESTMENTS AND HARMFUL
INVESTMENTS WITHOUT LEAVING OUT-
THE POOREST OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR STATES I DON'T THINK
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PASS THIS BILL I THINK WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY. TO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. VERY GOOD NOW YOU CAN CALL
THE ROLL THANK YOU FOR CATCHING
ME ON THAT IS PICTURE. WITH CITY
OF WITH THE APPROVAL OF THE
AUTHOR OF THE A CO AUTHOR.
THANKS GREAT. I ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN BRIAN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK HI CORK I
BET SMITH ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I.
KALRA CHOLERA HIGH BENNETT
BENNETT I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING WHAT I TO G.
MODES TO CHEAT I WALDRON. THREE
FIVE SIX TWO WE HAVE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SO MR RENDON LAST FOR
COMMITTEES AT ONE SEVENTY IS.
HE'S GOT TO GO SO NOW WE'LL HEAR
FROM MR BLOOM THANK YOU FOR
WAITING SO LONG THIS IS I LOVE
THIS. IT'S HER FLORAL ALKYL AND
POLY FLORAL ALKYL SUBSTANCES P.
FAST AND P. FAST PRODUCTS. AND
PRODUCT COMPONENTS PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE REPORTING PLATFORM.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT. BUT I
GET THAT MUCH LOVE FOR MY BILLS
- BUT- OBVIOUSLY MUCH
APPRECIATED- AND- GOOD AFTERNOON
TO ALL OF YOU- AND I'LL BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND TO THIS
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR- THEY'RE
VERY DILIGENT WORK WITH MY STAFF
AND ME ON THIS LEGISLATION
CONCERNS ARE MOUNTING THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD ABOUT THE TOXICITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PERSISTENCE OF
FOSS CHEMICALS THE EUROPEAN
UNION THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CALIFORNIA THE OTHER STATES HAVE
BEEN WORK TO CURB. PEOPLE US
POLLUTION BY SETTING
CONTAMINATION LIMITS AND
RESTRICTING THE USE OF PEACE
PROCESS AND PRODUCTS. BUT THESE
SUBSTANCES ARE EVERYWHERE IN OUR
DRINKING WATER WASTEWATER AND
EVEN RAIN WATER SEN OUR BODIES
AND THE BODIES OF WATER AND FISH
. LATERS ARE NOW TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW PEOPLE AS A
SPREADING THROUGH THE THROUGHOUT
THE ECOSYSTEM. AND THEY'RE
ASKING- FOUNDATIONAL QUESTION
WHERE IS IT ALL COMING FROM. AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE A MANUFACTURER OF P.
FOSS OR A MANUFACTURER OF A
PRODUCT OR PRODUCT COMPONENT
CONTAINING THE FILES THAT IS
SOLD OFFERED FOR SALE
DISTRIBUTOR OFF. FOR PROMOTION
PURPOSE. INNER BOARD IN EIGHT
REPORT THOSE PRODUCTS AND THE
AMOUNT OF P. FONTS THAT CONTAIN
TO A PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE
DATABASE ANNUALLY. THE BILL
FURTHER INSTRUCTS THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL TO
WORK WITH THE INTERSTATE
CHEMICALS CLEARING HOUSE TO
CREATE AND MAINTAIN THAT
DATABASE PLATFORM. P. FIVE OUR
CLASS OF APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
THOUSAND TOXIC MAN MADE
CHEMICALS THAT CAN BE FOUND IN
MANY PRODUCTS PRODUCTS SUCH AS
NONSTICK COOKWARE WATER
REPELLENT CLOSE. THE CHURCH.
HOUSE PRODUCTS PAUL MERRY OUT OF
INDUSTRIAL MATERIALS EXPOSURE TO
P. FIVE SUSPEND WITH A WIDE
RANGE OF HEALTH CONCERNS THE-
ANSWER READ THE- HI. AND REDUCED
IMMUNE RESPONSE AND VACCINE
EFFECTIVENESS. VIRTUALLY ALL
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE
P. FONTS IN THEIR BODIES AND
BABIES ARE BEING BORN WITH THEM
. WE KNOW THAT PETE FOSSE'S IN
MANY PRODUCTS AND EVEN AN
INDUSTRIAL SUBSTANCES BUT
BECAUSE P. FOSS HAS SO MANY USES
AND IS ONLY MET. FOR ALL. COULD
A FOR ANY SECTOR INDUSTRY. WE
THAT THE P. FOSS USES WE HAVE
ONLY STARTED TO REGULATE- SUCH
AS- USES IN FOOD PACKAGING
CARPETS TEXTILES COSMETICS AND
FIREFIGHTING FOAM ARE ONLY THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG. IN ORDER FOR
READERS THAT CAN MAKERS TO
UNDERSTAND BUT A MATCH THIS P.
FAST POLLUTION WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW INTEREST BUYER.
EIGHTEEN COMES FROM. EIGHT TWO
FORTY SO WILL BE US THIS PER BY
REQUIRING MANUFACTURERS TO
REPORT TO THE INTERSTATE
CHEMICAL CLEARING HOUSE WHICH IS
A NATIONAL DATA COLLECTION
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA IS
ALREADY A MEMBER OF. IMPORT
ATTAINING PEAK BOSS THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT ONLY NEEDED
BY WASTE WATER REGULATORS WHO
ARE HERE WITH ME TODAY BUT ALSO
DECISION MAKERS AT EVERY LEVEL
OF GOVERNMENT. I'D LIKE TO BE
CLEAR.
FOUNDATIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW AND HOW MUCH PEOPLE OWE US
IS ENTERING OUR STATE WE CAN'T
TAKE FURTHER ACTION UNTIL WE
HAVE THAT BASIC INFORMATION. AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN WILL HELP
US ACCURATELY IDENTIFY HOW MUCH
BOXES COMING TO THE STATE.
GIVING THE STATE THE AUTHORITY
THE STATE WILL ENABLE US TO
EXPLORE HOW BEST TO MITIGATE ITS
HARMFUL IMPACTS WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION WE CAN'T TAKE ANY
MEANINGFUL STEP TOWARDS
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF CASH
POIGNANCY AND ARE ARMED. LONG
TERM HERE WITH ME TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL R. ANDREW
VENTURA OF CLEAN WATER ACTION
AND JESSICA GALLAGHER OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
SANITATION AGENCIES. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GO FIRST I BELIEVE I
WILL OKAY. MANRICO I WON THAT I
WON THE LOTTERY- THANK YOU CHAIR
QUIRK AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S AN HONOR HERE
BEFORE YOU AGAIN AND- ALWAYS
SITTING NEXT TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM- CLEAN ACTION ALONG WITH
THE ENVIRONMENT CAN GROUP AND
THE CALIFORNIA. SANITATION
AGENCIES- CIRCLE ANSWERING THIS
BILL WILL REPEAT THE HEALTH
IMPACTS YOU'VE HEARD THEM BEFORE
. TURN AGAIN BUT I DO WANT TO
REMIND YOU THAT REGARD OF THE SO
CALLED TYPE OF P. FAST ALL OF
THESE CHEMICALS PERSIST TRAVEL
BROADLY IN. AND THEIR- CAN NO
LONGER. OF THIS. IF YOU GET
PROGRESS IRAQ IN SOME OF THEM
WERE AND UNDERSTOOD USE A P.
FAST- OVER THE YEAR BUT AS YOU
JUST HEARD ARE WE JUST THE CHIP
ICEBERG BECAUSE WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ARE OR HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
ON THAT BECAUSE HE IS A
PROFESSOR HAVE BEEN WELL PUBLIC
BUYS. THE BY IN IT NO. BE JUST
MAKER SUCH AS- ARE. PUBLIC
AGENCIES OR EVEN BUSINESSES HAVE
A GOOD SENSE OF HOW THESE
CHEMICALS ARE BEING USED
THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA MARKET
. I'M YOU CAN HAVE THIS BILL
ACTUALLY CAME ABOUT IN THE
COURSE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AN
UNUSUAL COALITION CAME TOGETHER
UP FOLKS FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
AND HEALTH- COMMUNITIES- AS WELL
AS THE WASTE WATER COMMUNITY WE
DECIDED THAT WE WERE GOING TO
TRUST EACH OTHER AT A FRANK
CONVERSATION ABOUT P. FAST AND
TRY TO FIND SOME COMMON GROUND
AND SOLUTIONS AND THE COURSE OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS IT WAS
UNANIMOUSLY AGREED THAT GIVEN
THAT WE DO NOT MAKE PEACE US IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
BIGGEST BARRIER TO FUTURE
SOLUTIONS. IS ABOUT HOW AND IN
WHAT FORM CHEMICALS ENTER OUR
STATE AND THIS BILL ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BELIEVES
LEADERSHIP IS THE RESULT OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. SO AND IT
WOULD JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION FOR
CALIFORNIA IS. HOW DO WE WANT TO
RESTRICT MAX. HOW DO WE DECIDE
WHAT'S AN ESSENTIAL. FACT THAT
WE NEED TO KEEP BUT THINGS WE
DON'T NEED HOW TO TAKE ACTION TO
MANAGE THAT WAVE SURE I DON'T
KNOW ALRIGHT ARE MEANT. TO WE
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIRST
LEADERSHIP WE ARE. THE FOR THE
AND WE WILL MAKE DECISIONS BASED
THE DATA AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HE PRETTY IN THIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
. CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SAN
THE WE ARE HERE TODAY AT THE
PRESS COSTA OF AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY. AS YOU KNOW FOSS HAS
BECOME A VERY SIGNIFICANT TOPIC
IN WATER AND WASTEWATER IN THE
UBIQUITY OF THESE CHEMICALS
COUPLED WITH THE URGENCY FOR
FINDING SOLUTIONS FOR MANAGING
THEM. HAS COME. IN K. ACTIVE
MANAGE OPTIONS WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE WATER BOARDS TO
IDENTIFY THE LEVELS OF P. FAST
IN OUR SYSTEM THROUGH A
STATEWIDE MONITORING AND
REPORTING ORDER- PRELIMINARY
RESULTS FROM THE FIRST PHASE OF
THIS EFFORT INDICATE THAT WE'RE
SEEING CONSISTENT LEVELS OF P.
FUSSING WASTE WATER FROM BOTH
RESIDENTIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
CHARGES IT'S COMING IN FROM
SOURCES OUTSIDE OF THOSE THAT WE
CAN CURRENT REGULATE THROUGH-
THE INDUSTRIAL PERMITS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO THAT INDICATES IT
IS BEING USED IN PRADA. PEOPLE
AND BUSINESSES. WE SEE
CONSISTENTLY THAT ARE MORE P.
FIVE COMPOUNDS IN EFFLUENTS
COMPARED TO THE INFLUENCE.
INDICATING THAT SOME OF THESE
CHEMICALS HAVE A TENDENCY TO
TRANSFORM INTO MORE HARMFUL
COMPOUNDS DURING THE CONTROLLED
TREATMENT PROCESS. AND THIS
TENDENCY IS REPRESENTATIVE OF
HOW THESE PERSISTENT COMPOUNDS
REACT IN THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. AS AGENCIES TASKED
WITH THE PROTECTION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT THIS
IS A VERY DAUNTING PROCESS TO BE
FACE. THERE'S NO CABLE
DESTRUCTION TECHNOLOGY SO TREAT.
A SIGNIFICANT RATEPAYER EXPENSE
WOULD ONLY DISPLACE THE CHEMICAL
RESIDUALS TO A DIFFERENT WEIGHT
DREAM. SO THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE AND MEANINGFUL
APPROACH TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
AS SOURCE CONTROL SOURCE
REDUCTION AND POLLUTION
PREVENTION. RIGHT NOW WE ARE
LIMITED BY THE LACK OF
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THESE
CHEMICALS ARE USED IN COMMERCE
AND UNTIL WE KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
COMING FROM WE CAN'T IMPLEMENT
MEANINGFUL SOURCE REDUCTION
POLICIES. AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN WOULD GIVE US THE DATA WE
NEED TO SUPPORT STATE AND LOCAL
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS AND FOR US
TO BETTER IDENTIFY TO THE PEOPLE
OFTEN OUR WATERSHEDS. WE WOULD
USE THIS INFORMATION TO WORK
WITH OUR CUSTOMERS ON POLLUTION
PREVENTION POLICIES TO LIMIT THE
INTRODUCTION OF THESE CHEMICALS
INTO THE ENVIRONMENT. AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN WILL GIVE US THE
AND- REPORT THAT. I WANT. NUMBER
YOUR I. SO ARE THERE ARE IN ROOM
INTO. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS THERE DAHLE FIELD
HAPPILY CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON UNDER AVERAGE OUT WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON KYLE JOHNSON
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN
SUPPORT. MELISSA ROMERO
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
AND SUPPORT. PROSECUTORS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
HELLO SUSAN LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL
OBVIOUSLY IN SUPPORT ALSO TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT OF CALPERS
SURFRIDER PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY SAN FRANCISCO.
INDIVISIBLE ALTER PASADENA
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH U. S.
CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY CENTER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
RETHINK DISPOSABLE THANK YOU
MMHM. SUTTER CORTES AT KELLER-
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT GREAT
THANK YOU. WE'VE GOT QUITE A
LIST TO SUPPORTERS- TAMPINES
COME FORWARD. SO TOO I'M SURE
STEP IS WITH THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL AND HE'S HERE
TO SPEAK FOR THEIR POSITION ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU DR COURT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
INVESTIGATE FOR THE WITH THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY I DO WANT TO FIRST
START OFF BY SAYING THAT WE GOT
A COUPLE OF MEETINGS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPENNESS AND- OPEN DIALOGUE- WE
DO UNDERSTAND APPRECIATE
INTENDED THE BILL BUT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED A FEW CONCERNS. AND
AS OF TODAY MUST RESPECT TAKEN
IN OPPOSE POSITION. AS YOU'VE
HEARD THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
NEW DATABASE TO HOUSE
INFORMATION SUBMITTED BY
MANUFACTURERS. ARE INDUSTRY
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE REASONABLE
PRODUCTION USE AND MANAGEMENT OF
THESE FLORIDA SUBSTANCES. BUT
WITH RESPECT TO TWENTY TO FORTY
SEVEN WE HAVE RAISED A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS- THIS BILL COMES AT A
TIME WHEN U. S. EPA IS. EXPECTED
TO FINALIZE A COMPREHENSIVE
REPORTING RULE ON THIS VERY SAME
ISSUE LATER THIS YEAR-
MANUFACTURES A P. FOSS AND
PEOPLE TALK. CONTAINING
ARTICLES- MUST REPORT IN. ELEVEN
OF DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF
INFORMATION PROPOSED A USES FOR
EACH SUBSTANCE OR MIXTURE
DESCRIPTIONS OF BY PRODUCTS
RESULTING FROM MANUFACTURING
PROCESSING USE AND DISPOSAL-
INFORMATION RELATIVE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL- AND HEALTH
EFFECTS AS WELL AS WORKER
EXPOSURE TO NAME A FEW. EPA HAS
STATED THAT THIS RULE IS TO HELP
THEM BETTER UNDERSTAND SOURCES
AND QUANTITIES OF P. FAST
MANUFACTURING IN THE US SUPPORT
ON GOING RESEARCH MONITORING AND
REGULATORY EFFORTS. WE THINK
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEVERAGE THIS
INFORMATION BETTER UNDERSTAND A
POTENTIAL SOURCES OF EXPOSURE
AND ALLOW DGSE OR ANOTHER
APPROPRIATE STATE AGENCY TO
PRIORITIZE A POTENTIAL FUTURE
REGULATORY ACTIONS- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT DGSE DOES HAVE SOME
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO COMPEL
MANUFACTURE ASK MANUFACTURERS
FOR. FOR INFORMATION- AND IT'S A
COMMITTEE MAY KNOW THE- CENTER
ALLEN'S SB FIVE OH TWO IS MOVING
TO A LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD
COMPEL MANUFACTURERS AT THE TNCS
DIRECTION TO PROVIDE A HOST OF
INFORMATION ABOUT CHEMICAL
INGREDIENTS CONCENTRATION
FUNCTIONAL USE. INFORMATION IS
RELATIVE TO THE USE OF PRODUCTS.
IT WHEN ANOTHER. RELATIONS ARE
SO AGAIN WE DO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT IN THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER HOW WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO UTILIZE SOME OF
OUR EXISTING TOOLS ONGOING TOOLS
AT EPA- TO HELP BETTER
UNDERSTAND- INSTILL SOME OF THE
DATA GAPS THAT CALIFORNIA MAY
IDENTIFY AS A PRIORITY JUST A
COUPLE OF OTHER ISSUES REAL
QUICKLY RIGHT NOW THE BILL DOES
NOT CONTAIN AN ARGUE A TO
MINIMUS LEVEL THAT WOULD TRIGGER
REPORTING OBLIGATIONS SO SUPPLY
CHAINS ARE PRETTY COMPLEX SMALL
MEDIUM AND LARGE COMPANIES ALL
PER COMPONENT PARTS THAT COULD
IS IN A SINGLE PROP- OF A STATE
SPECIFIC REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
COULD BE. TREMENDOUSLY
COMPLICATED- AND AGAIN AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN DOT. A THIRD.
EITHER OUR STATE CHEMICALS-
HOUSE TO CREATE AND MANAGE THIS
INFORMATION. WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AT LEAST SOME GUIDELINES OR
REQUIREMENTS THAT ENSURE THE
INFORMATION COLLECTED- IT'S
PRESENTED TO THE PUBLIC IN A IN
A SCIENTIFICALLY SOUND MANNER.
BEING SKINNY PER PRESENTING SUCH
TECHNICAL AND YOU WANT
INFORMATION. IS IMPORTANT FOR
MANUFACTURERS TO BE INVOLVED IN
THAT PROCESS IN OUR VIEW AND
THERE SHOULD BE A FORMAL PROCESS
FOR MANUFACTURERS DOING H. WITH-
THE INTERSTATE CHEMICAL CLEARING
HOUSE IF THERE IS AN ISSUE IN
TERMS OF HOW THAT INFORMATION.
IS PRESENTED AND IT FINALLY
GIVEN THE SCOPE OF THE BILL AND
REPORTING OBLIGATIONS THAT WOULD
FIT FALL ON POTENTIALLY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF MANUFACTURERS
AND SUPPLIERS. OF A JULY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR COMPLIANCE. IN ARE
NOT NECESSARILY BE ACHIEVABLE SO
I WITH THESE UP THE KEY CONCERNS
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE BUT
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
DIALOGUE WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR AND- IS IT SHOULD THE
BILL MOVE FORWARD WE WOULD BE
CONSTRUCTING ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION SO APPRECIATE THE
TIME TODAY. GOOD. EXCELLENT FROM
NOW ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WANTS
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DON
KHAKI MCCUE CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES
ON BEHALF AIR CONDITIONING
HEATING REFRIGERATION INSTITUTE
ALSO OPPOSED AS WELL AS THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER STEPHANIE
MOORE ON BEHALF OF THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
AND THE CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON NICOLE COMMUNITIES ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. IN MANY WEON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LEARNED ABLE AND SEE A
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
COATINGS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
ADAMANTLY UP HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONES- AND
WE WANT PEOPLE BOTH IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE JUST GIVE US
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION BOB. AT&T OPERATOR
PLEASE PROCEED. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO LOCAL STORE LINE OF
THE I. TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ROSENBERGER MOTOR ONE
MEMBER OF THE H. G. E. J. C. AND
I. AFTER THE SURPRISE LOOK YES
SIR. THE A. B. CHANGE SEVEN
THANK. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JENNIFER
WILLIAMS BUT THE EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. SO. EIGHTEEN MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRTH DEATH A LOSS SO
ON BEHALF OF WATER REUSE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. TWO TWENTY. THANK YOU THE
MEMBERS THANKS FOR YOUR REYES ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL ACTION
CAMP BONTA ON SUPPORT THANK YOU
. NINE TO. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
WOULD YOU SHARE MEMBERS ASKING
US ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT. NINE ONE ONE. ON BEHALF
OF THE BREAST ANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS THAT ACCURATE EXAMPLE
ACTUALLY FUND IN SUPPORT. NINE
TWO TWO ONE. EMILY PAPPAS ON
BEHALF OF ANIMAL HEALTH
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION I WHAT
THE MEANT THAT THANK YOU. FIND
TO NINETEEN. BOB SPIEGEL
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALTHOUGH
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN FOR THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY THE CAMERI-
ROSEVILLE AND THOUSAND OAKS
ALONG WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
MICHAEL BATH WITH THE PREY AND
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS THAT THE SHARON
GREEN BUT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT AND STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE THIRTY. WE SHOULD
OWN CAN WITH ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ERIC TURNER ON BEHALF OF
THE EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. TO GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS ALICIA CULVER ON BUT ON
BEHALF OF THE RESPONSIBLE
PURCHASING NETWORK AND GREEN
SCIENCE POLICY INSTITUTE WHO
FOUNDED THE CHEMICALS AND
EVERYTHING FROM AYE
CLASSIFICATION THE FORMAT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- THANK YOU
. TWO TWO EIGHT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN IS LOBBYING COALITION
AND HE'LL TODAY IN SUPPORT. NINE
ONE FOUR TWO. THE BRIDGE NUMBER
WILL CALIFORNIA GREENSTEIN AND
PRECOURT. AND TWO TWO NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBER ERICA
ANDREA TO BE OR COUNTY
SANITATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
KNOW ONE OF THREE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. VERY GOOD ARM. NEXT
WE HAVE QUESTIONS. WELL YES
GARCIA THANK YOU THIS BRIDGES
REGISTRY ARE WE GONNA
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
INTENTIONAL AND UNINTENTIONAL.
YOU CAN RESPOND TO OKAY AT THIS
POINT IN THE BILL- THE BILL DOES
INCLUDE BOTH- INTENTIONAL AND
UNINTENTIONAL WE DO YOU-
UNDERSTAND FROM WHAT MR TRUST
SAID THAT THERE WOULD BE IT
WOULD BE USEFUL TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF THREAT OLD ARE
CONCERNED. IS THE CASE AN UP HIS
WE ARE DEALING DIFFERENT KINDS
OF PRODUCTS AND SO THERE IS.
CATEGORY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE- ONLY IT WORKS THE END
INDUSTRY UP SECTORS TO SEE HOW
WE CAN BEST IDENTIFY
UNINTENTIONAL P. FAST. WITHOUT
CHASING EVERY MOLECULE IN THE
WORLD THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE BUT WE
DON'T AT THIS POINT WANT TO LOSE
THE INFORMATION OF WHAT MAY BE
COMING IN STATE IN FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS DUE TO
CONTAMINATION SO WE ARE WILLING.
DO TO COPY THE RECESSION ON THAT
FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY FORWARD
ON HOW TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
YEAH I DON'T I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER OF HOW TO BEST. ADDRESS
THAT BUT WE O TALK A LOT ABOUT
THAT AND THIS COMMITTEE AND JUST
TRYING TO BE FAIR AND- FOR
PUTTING THEM FORMATION OUT THERE
YOU KNOW- ABSOLUTELY. AND THEN
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO EXCEPTIONS
FOR. VETERINARY OR HUMAN
MEDICINE OR IF THE MEDICAL
DEVICES- CAN COMMENT ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT. AND YEAH I WILL TAKE
THAT WHEN I. NO THAT. BEING USED
TO MAKE THIS DEVICE THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT INFORMATION TO
US TO US THAT THE LOCAL LEVEL-
SO YOU KNOW THIS IS JUST A
DISCLOSURE ELEMENT THERE'S NO-
PROHIBITIONS ON USE OF THE
COMPOUNDS AND THOSE TYPES OF
APPLICATIONS- BUT YOU KNOW
ABSENT KNOWING THAT THEY ARE-
BEING USED IN THAT WAY WE NEED
THAT INFORMATION TO MAKE MANAGE
DECISION SO WE KNOW IF WE AT.
WELL THE FACT THAT PRODUCT IN
SERVICE AREA THAT WE- ON THE
WASTE SIDE LEAST NOTE CONTACT
THEM AND WORK THROUGH- THEIR
DISCHARGE REQUIREMENTS WITH THEM. ALL RIGHT- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
NOT ADDRESSED IN JUST A
COMMENTED AT TACTIC RIGHT NOW
WE'RE FLYING BLIND AND I JUST IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT WE GET
THAT INFORMATION AND WHEN WE'VE
DONE SOME ACQUIRES ABOUT HAVE
BEEN SOME PEOPLE GO. FOUR WEEKS
WE CAN'T GIVE YOU THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW WHETHER WE USE IT OR NOT
IT'S LIKE WELL THAT'S THAT'S THE
WHOLE PROBLEM THANK YOU. YEAH
ANYONE ELSE. I'LL JUST MAKE A
COMMENT. AND I DON'T WANT YOU TO
GO THROUGH ALL OF THIS TODAY BUT
AFTER YOUR TESTIMONY. YOU LISTED
A BUNCH OF THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING BUT I COULDN'T TELL
EXACTLY. WHY YOU WERE LISTING
THEM AND WHY THEY WERE CONCERNED
. THAT'S BUT I'M SURE YOU COULD
MAKE THAT CLEAR TO MR BLOOM- AND
THE REASON TO DO THAT IS THEN HE
CAN WORK WITH YOU SALVATERRA
PROBLEMS CAN BE MELIORATE IT OUT
WHAT YOU DID SAY IS THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT REPORTING GOING
ON DTS SHE HASN'T ALREADY. I
WASN'T QUITE SURE HOW THE ALL OF
THAT RELATED TO YOUR OPPOSITION
MAYBE IJUST DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
YOU BUT I THINK YOU NEED TO. BE
SPECIFIC ABOUT SO MISTER BLOOM
CAN ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS BUT I
DO WANT TO GET INTO THE NOW
BECAUSE WE HAVE OTHER THINGS TO
DO TO. ALL RIGHT- MISTER BLUE.
THANK YOU MOTHER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING- A DIALOGUE WITH THE
OPPOSITION THIS IS A-
COMPLICATED BILL- BUT IT HAS- A
GREAT DEAL OF IMPORTANCE I THINK
TO THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ANSAR ASK YOUR I'VE
- ALL RIGHT WE NEED A MOTION.
THE BALLOT IN MAY MOVE THE BILL
WOULD. SO FROM HERE SPECS IN THE
SECOND OKAY. RICHARD HAS A
SECOND THEY'LL- SO OF THIS
CONTENT CAN AFFECT FLIGHTS. ALL
RIGHT- LET'S. MR OF MR
BLOOMINGTON THE OTHER PEOPLE ON
THE OTHER WORDS ON SO IF YOU
WANT STAY THAT YOUR BILL IS UP
TO YOU UP HE WANTS TO GO THERE.
I THINK OR- SO. FINE LET'S.
LET'S GET ON WITH BUSINESS. I'M
ALL FOR THAT AFTER WE CAN MADAMS
. THIS IS ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN BLOOM THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CORK
BY CORK I SMITH SMITH NO
ARAMBULA. OKAY SURE I'M KALRA.
KALRA FIVE BENNETT BENNETT I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I MATHIS MATHIS NO MORE THAT'S
WHAT SHE WOULD HAVE TO G. I
WALDRON. WE HAVE FIVE VOTES SO
DOES YOUR OUT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- MISTER I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY JUST TOO TIGHT AND I
SHOULD I START I AM NOW DOING
EVERYTHING AND THANK WE HAVE
LOTS OF OTHER AUTHORS HERE-
LET'S SEE. THE ONLY NON MEMBER
COMMITTEE. FOR WHOM WE NEED TO
HEAR FROM IS EDUARDO GARCIA. SO
IF THE SERGEANTS COULD ASK MR
GARCIA TO COME UP. IN TIME MR
MATHIS I HAVE A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL. WHY DON'T
WE BRING THAT OUT NOW. SECOND
WITH ALL RIGHT TO LIVE DID
SECOND DID AND WE LOVE YOUR BILL
- MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL I'LL BE BRIEF- A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE DE
CALIFORNIA WITH REGIONAL QUALITY
WATER CONTROL BOARDS AND FOUND
IN FOR THOSE COMPLAINTS- BILL.
IS DESERVE VERY AIMED AT GIVING
OUR FOLKS BACK HOME THE
OPPORTUNITY SAY OKAY WHAT WHAT
IS TOO MUCH AND WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE AND MR CORKER. I THINK
ELFIN COMMITTEE STAFFER WITH MY
TEAM- THAT I'M ALWAYS COMMITTED
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO WORK
THROUGH THESE ISSUES IN TO COME
UP WITH THE BEST POLICY AS
POSSIBLE. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS COMMITTEE AND IN DOING THAT
I CAN'T NECESSARILY SAY THAT BUT
OTHER COMMITTEES I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT HERE. ARMS WITH
THAT WITH THE MOTION IN A
SECOND- I WILL GO AHEAD AND- IF
WE HAVE OUR LEAD WITNESS- MISTER
FERNANDO RIVAS ONLINE FROM SAID
PISTACHIOS AT TERRA BELLA- I'LL
GO AHEAD AND HANDED OVER TO HIM.
BURKE VERY GOOD- FERNANDO RIOS-
YOU CAN JUST SPEAK TO YOUR ON
THE PHONE AND PLEASE SPEAK UP
AND WILL HEAR YOU. VERY GOOD YEP. OKAY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS FERNANDO
RIOS MIGHT WORK FOR SENATE
PASSED YOU I DON'T CARE ABOUT
THAT AN IDEA WITH A GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AND REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE. MY ORGANIZATION. AND
I ALSO WILL BE BRIEF- FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE BEEN BIG
FANS- UNFOUNDED. AND FRIVOLOUS
COMPLAINTS UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
NO RECOURSE ON THE RESPONDING
PARTY WHO ARE CALLING IN THESE
UNFOUNDED AFFAIRS THANK. WATER
BOARD STAFF AN HOUR A HALF TWO
HOURS. INVESTIGATE TURNED BACK
BECAUSE THE COMPLAINTS WERE
UNFOUNDED THIS REPEAT THE NEXT
DAY THE NEXT DAY AND THE NEXT
OFTEN FOUND IT. WATERWORKS
CAPTAIN. EACH COMPLAINT. RELY ON
AGENCIES TO INVESTIGATE ON THEIR
BEHALF. UNFOUNDED IMPRIMER I
COMPLAIN IS THE WAY TO THE TOP
IN A WAY REACH. ONE PARTY CAN
CALL IN. AND FOUND IT WITH ZERO.
AND KNOCKING OUT ACCOUNT FOR
CALL IN RIGHT FIFTY CONTINUE
THERE IS THERE NEED TO BE A
MECHANISM OR WAR. OUR PREPARE
THESE UNFOUNDED EVERY SERVICE
TEMPLATES TO. WITH WHY WE STRIVE
SAID EIGHT. EIGHTY NINE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MR MAT WHAT
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YES SIR THE
POINT HERE IS THAT THE WOULD
WITH THE REGIONAL WATER CONTROL
BOARD. TO DECIDE- WHEN THEY NEED
TO INVESTIGATE WHEN THEY DON'T
AS WELL AS- HOW THEY MIGHT DEAL
WITH THE- I DON'T. A SERIES OF
FRIVOLOUS COMPLAINTS THAT THAT
WOULD BE A POLICY THEY COULD SET
CORRECT AND SO THAT WAS YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN THE
AUDIENCE. AND IS THERE ANYONE
WHO IS SUPPOSED. IN THE AUDIENCE
ENSINANDO WE CAN GO ON THE PHONE
LINES. AND THIS IS ON AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE MATHIS-
OPERATOR PLEASE GO AHEAD TO GET
THOSE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
HERE ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE HAVE QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME.
VERY GOOD DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT. I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
GET THIS BILL PASSED- WE HAVE
MOTION AND A SECOND I THINK WE
CAN JUST SHOWED YOU WANNA CLOSE
ABSOLUTELY MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
MEMBERS IT YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO KIND OF
CALL TIME OUT ON THIS CLAIMS
DEVELOP A PROCESS THAT WORKS
BEST- SO WE'RE NOT BURNING
RESOURCES IN THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY LOOK INTO A RELATIVE
CLAIM. HIS US I'M ON ONCE DATE
DAVE DINO NECESSARY OKAY. OF
THAT CERTAINLY- TRUST- POSITION-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS ITEM TEN AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE MATHIS THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORK BY CORK I
SMITH. SMITH HI ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I KALRA. KALRA I BET IT
CRISTINA GARCIA MATHIS MATHIS I
WANTED TO CHECK. WHAT I TO XII
WALDRON CONGRATULATIONS TODAY
THAT'S THAT'S- FLUORIDE
SERGEANTS DO WE HAVE ANY WORD
FROM MR GARCIA. HE'S COMING UP
THE ELEVATOR THEN LET'S HOLD ON
ON THE OTHER- PRESENTATIONS
UNTIL WE HEAR FROM YOUR GARCIA.
WE DON'T. WE YOU FOR YOUR BILL.
WITH A SEVEN POINT. FIVE FIVE
CORRECT IF YOU WANT TO STOP.
SO I WILL WAIT FOR HIM TO GET
OFF THE ELEVATOR. FROM THAT
POINT. FOR MISTER. FOR THE FOR
THE LOOK AT THE VIDEO BETTER.
COMBO WHERE YOU CAN RUN THROUGH
THE FRONT DOOR WHICH OF THE-
OKAY CAN I CALL. HER TO GET HER
ON THE PHONE. YEAH YEAH OKAY SO
I'M- ADDING ON THE CONSENT CAL
CALENDAR- THE VOTE. CURRENTLY
SITTING AT SIX ZERO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I. MURATSUCHI WITH A
TWO GI WALDRON. THAT BRINGS IT
TO EIGHT ZERO. CHRISTOPHER THIS
IS ITEM ONE WELL IT IS AT FOUR
TWO. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I WOULD
HAVE TO CHANGE. THIS IS I'M
SORRY ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR STONE WHAT
A TO G. I. WALDRON BRINGS THE
VOTE. SIX TWO. THE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT-
THE VOTE TWENTY TWO OH EIGHT
CALL KALRA THE VOTE SETS AT FOUR
TWO ARAMBULA ADAM HEY WHAT TO
CHECK WITH A TO G. WALDRON. SIX
TWO. ITEM FOUR IS AB TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN CREEK CRISTINA GARCIA
VOTE SET FIVE TWO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I. WALDRON. SIX TWO.
AND ITEM EIGHT OUR AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN BLUE VOTES FIVE TWO
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I WALDRON.
SIX VERY GOOD SO MR GARCIA DO
YOU WANT TO START WITH AB TWENTY
FORTY ONE- CALIFORNIA SAFE WATER
SAFE DRINKING WATER ACT. PRIMARY
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS YES
SERVICE CHAIRED COLLEAGUES AND
I'LL JUST JUMP RIGHT IN THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE
BOARD TO TAKE CERTAIN ACTIONS.
WHEN A PRIMARY DRINKING WATER
STANDARD IS ADOPTED. AND THAT
REALLY LOOKING AT HOW WE GET
INTO COMPLIANCE I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE AS IT
RELATES TO CONTAMINANTS IN OUR
WATER. BUT THERE A LOT OF IN
NEED TO HAPPEN IN TERMS OF
ABILITY ACCESSIBILITY TO
TECHNOLOGIES AND- ULTIMATELY
WHICH SYSTEM STOCKS THAT
CALIFORNIA ARE GONNA BE ABLE TO
COMPLY- WHEN ADOPTED AND IF NOT
WHO ARE THEY WHERE ARE THEY AND
WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO GET THEM.
TO COMPLIANCE SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT- ARE A
WITNESS TODAY'S AMOUNT OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY
JAILS. THANK YOU BUTTERMILK VICE
CHAIR SMITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AND I DON'T
THEY GOT FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS
I HAVE SERVED AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES WITH R. FOUR HUNDRED
MEMBERS WERE CONSIDERED. THE
VOICE A SMALL SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA. I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
FOR BEING A CITY SUPPORTER OF
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AS
WELL AS THE PASSWORD THE
CHAIRMAN DID ON PRIMACY AGENCIES
AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE AGENCIES IT SERVES. MS ARE
PROPERLY FUNDED. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER
THERE EXCELLENT SUGGESTIONS AND
CONSTRUCTIVE AMENDMENTS. ABOUT
AB TWENTY FORTY ONE. WE FEEL
THAT THE SIX AREAS IDENTIFIED
FOR CONTINUING WORK ON THIS BILL
ARE ACHIEVABLE BECAUSE THE
CLARIFICATIONS ARE BASED ON THE
CURRENT PRACTICES AND RESOURCES.
OF THE STATE WATER BOARD IN THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER IN
THE PROCESS OF CREATING NEW SAFE
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS FOR
TARGETED CHEMICALS. AS WELL AS
IN THE BOARD'S CURRENT WORK TO
HELP WATER SYSTEMS AT RISK OF
FAILURE UNDER THE SAFER PROGRAM.
UNDER CURRENT PRACTICES IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF SAFE DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS COMPLIANCE BY
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IS
PRETTY MUCH. THE CHATS. BUT THE
BILL BLOCK- TO ADDRESS THIS
DISPARITY WERE LARGER SYSTEMS
CAN AFFORD TO COMPLY BUT MANY
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS CAN. WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT THE BOARD IS
ALLOWING FOR A MULTI YEAR
COMPLIANCE PERIOD FOR EXAMPLE.
PROCESS TO SET A NEW STANDARD
FOR CHROMIUM SIX. AS THE
ANALYSIS NOTED. THE PREVIOUS FOR
CHROMIUM SIX SAID BEEN IN THE
DAY. TWENTY SEVEN. HUNDRED IT
RISK COMPLIANCE WITH PRIMARY
DRINKING WATER IN CAL. AB TWENTY
FORTY ONE TAKES THE CHANCE OUT
OF COMPLIANCE BY ESTABLISHING
LOGICAL STEPS AT THE END OF THE
REGULATORY APPROVAL PROCESS TO
ACCOUNT FOR THOSE SMALLER AND
POOR WATER SYSTEMS THAT CANNOT
AFFORD TO COMPLY THE FINAL STEP
IS A FINANCIAL PLAN TO HELP THEM
COMPLY AB TWENTY FORTY ONE WILL
ALSO HELP THE DIVISION OF
DRINKING WATER AGAINST FUTURE
LEGAL ATTEMPTS TO INVALIDATE
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS BECAUSE
IT BAKES AND ECONOMIC FEASIBLE.
REQUIRING A FINANCE FOR WHAT
SINCE COMPLY WITH SAFE DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS WE ASK FOR YOUR
YES VOTE AND THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN FOR CONSIDERING THIS BILL
. VERY GOOD. ALL IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE AUDIENCE IN SUPPORT. THIS
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF RESCUE AND
SALAS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
COACHELLA DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY IN EASTERN COACHELLA
VALLEY THAT WAS FACING A ONE
HUNDRED AD 20% INCREASE IN ITS
WATERY ONE VALIDATED MCL FOR
CHROMIUM WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE ENERGY TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
DO YOU WANT TO MAKE AN EXTENDED
STATEMENT TOUR I'M I JUST WANNA
SAY WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY HERE IN
OPPOSITION- EVERY VENTURE WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
ON THIS BILL WE THINK THEY BRING
UP SOME IMPORTANT POINTS THAT WE
DO WANT TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
WE'RE NOT SEEN THAT IN THE BILL
AT THIS POINT WE DO HAVE SOME
PROBLEMS BUT WE ARE WILLING TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS
MOVING FORWARD YES. VERY GOOD
ENCOURAGES THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER JUST ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH ANDREA THANKS ALL
RIGHT SO THE BILL IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND YOU'RE WORKING ON
IT AND I TRUST YOU SO THAT'S
GOOD- I KNOW YOU TRUST ME TO-
LET'S SEE ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION WE CAN GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. OF THIS WILL BE ON
A B. TWENTY FORTY ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA- AND ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT PLEASE GIVE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
OPERATOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
LOCAL TWO TO THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS GET THIRTY MILLION ON
BEHALF COMMISSION WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
ZERO TWO. EVERY TIME HE HAD
PEOPLE AND MARINO WEST REPRESENT
BIG ONES THAT WOULD BE WATER
AGENCY ANTON MEDINA COUNTY AND I
VOICE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
FORTY ONE. ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS OUR MONDO THAT UP US
REPRESENTING RUBIO CAN THAT IN
WATER AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO
FOUR ONE THANK YOU. BY TWO
THIRTY THREE. SENATOR MEMBERS
CIRCLE DONALD THE COMPANY
PROBABLY CONCERNS ON BEHALF OF
YOUR BOARD THE WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY TWO. ONE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY
THREE. HI THIS IS JOHN LANGAN ON
BEHALF OF SUNNYSLOPE WATER
COMPANY LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY FORTY
ONE AND URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
THANK YOU. ONE EIGHT SEVEN. THIS
IS JADE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
MUTUAL WATER COMPANY IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY- WE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FORTY ONE AND WE URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES. ONE EIGHTEEN. HI
THIS IS DOUG NOT ONLY A
REPRESENT THE OIL THEIR MUTUAL
WATER COMPANY IN THE NORTH OF
THE RIVER MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AND WE STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. TWO THREE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE ISSUE SO FAR AND I
REPRESENT- VALLEY WATER COMPANY
MAY WITH MUTUAL WATER COMPANY
NUMBER TWO AND TRI CITY MUTUAL
COMPANY FROM L. A. COUNTY I ALSO
REPRESENT MY ALL MY DIDN'T WATER
COMPANY RIVERSIDE COUNTY-
PONDEROSA BASED MUTUAL WATER
COMPANY UPON- MONEY COSTA
COUNTY. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
VOICE STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY FORTY ONE THANK YOU. ONE
THREE ZERO. ONE SEVENTY SIX. ONE
SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR
REPRESENTING MIDWAY CITY MUTUAL
WATER COMPANY AND EAST SIDE
WATER SOLICITATION WE WOULD LIKE
TO VOICE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY ONE WE ORDERED YOU TO VOTE
YES. ONE ONE ONE. YES THREE I
REPRESENTED A CANYON MEADOWS
MUTUAL WATER COMPANY KERN COUNTY
WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO APPLY TO
VOICE OUR SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FORTY ONE. I KEEP. ONE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS COREY GLENDALE I
REPRESENT BLANCA HATES WATER
COMPANY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT OF
AB TWO ZERO FOUR ONE AND WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES. ONE SEVEN FIVE.
MY NAME IS DAVID ARMSTRONG I
REPRESENTS MAY SOME MUTUAL WATER
COMPANY IN THE COUNTIES OF
RIVERSIDE AND SAMBAR DINO COUNTY
THAT ABOUT LIKE TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWO ZERO FOUR
ONE. ONE ONE ZERO. WHEN DAVID
STATEWIDE WITH BELLFLOWER
SOMERSET RECALL WATER COMPANY
AND L. A. COUNTY AND WE SUPPORT
EIGHTY TWO ZERO FOUR ONE. ONE
TWO SEVEN. THOMAS FLOW AND
JOSHUA BASIN WATER DISTRICTS AND
GUARDINO COUNTY WE SUPPORT AB
TWO ZERO FOUR ONE AND URGE THEM
HI FOLKS THANK YOU. ONE NINE
SIX. YES MY NAME IS DAVE CHALCO
I REPRESENT PLAN CHALLENGE WATER
COMPANY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND A CHARTER MEMBER OF COUNTY
CHILLS AND WE'D LIKE TO FOR SURE
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY TWO ZERO FOUR
ONE CAN WE HEAR YOU TO VOTE YES
AS WELL. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
THREE. MY NAME IS ONE OF THE
LARA REPRESENT ONE OF VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND WE SUPPORT AB TWO
ZERO FOUR ONE THANK YOU. ONE
NINE TWO. ONE NINE TWO. HELLO I
HAD. MY NAME IS GEORGE BRED MY
REPRESENT TRACK ONE EIGHTY WATER
COMPANY IN THE CITY OF CUTTING
HAY IN ALLEN COUNTY AND WOULD
LIKE TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWO ZERO FOUR ONE. AND WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES. ONE NINE ZERO.
ONE NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS MATT TRACK I REPRESENT
THE TWENTY NINE PALMS WATER
DISTRICT IN SAN BENITO COUNTY WE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FORTY ONE
INTERVIEW TO VOTE YES. ONE SEVEN
TWO. ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THIRTY. WE SHOULD AND
CAN WITH ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. TEN THIRTY EIGHT. YES MY
NAME IS NICHOLAS SNYDER AND AS A
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS ALLIANCE THE MOJAVE
WATER AGENCY IS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO ZERO FOUR ONE THANK YOU.
AND ONE SEVEN. ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVEN SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
. VERY GOOD THANK YOU. BOB WE
CAN NOW GO TO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS MR MATHESON AND MR VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- MARCH MORE OF A
COMMENT MR GARCIA I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING-
WITH THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND WOULD LOVE TO A CO AUTHOR
JOIN IF YOU HAD ME AT THAT
LEVEL- THIS IS VERY MUCH NEEDED.
AND IT'S ABOUT TIME WE PUT. THE
SOME STUFF WHEN INSTALLING WITH
CLEAN WATER. MISTER VICE CHAIR
SAID THINK THANK YOU- EDUARDO
GARCIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- BUT NEEDS
TO BE DONE I'M HOPING THAT WITH
THE APPROPRIATIONS FOR GOVERNOR
GET SOME MONEY INTO THIS SO WE
DON'T JUST START CONSOLIDATING
WATER DESTRUCTION WILL LEAD THE
SMALL. BE ABLE TO SURVIVE ON
BECAUSE THEY DO A VERY GOOD PART
IN THIS AND I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR. HI GOOD. OF THIS
GARCIA MISTER CALDERON. NO
QUESTIONS VERY GOOD- I'LL JUST
MAKE A COMMENT- THAT YOU CAN
ENTER YOUR CLOTHES SO WHAT WHAT
THE WATERBOARDING CLEAN WATER
ACTION WILL BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
IS HELLO UNDERSTAND YOUR
FINANCIAL SITUATION I MEAN I GET
MY WATER FROM OUR WATER AGENCY
THAT HAS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS. AND IT CAN PRETTY
MUCH TAKE CARE OF ANYTHING. BUT
THERE CLEARLY ARE AGENCIES THAT
CAN'T AND WHAT THEY'LL WANT IN
YOUR BILL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT EVENTUALLY- WE DO GET THE-
ARE. WE DO GET THE COMPLIANCE.
AND I KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WORK
. I THINK BEYOND THIS YEAR ON
THIS- TO GET THAT MONEY THAT'S
GOING TO BE NEEDED- I THINK
THEY'RE STILL WILL BE
CONSOLIDATIONS OF SYSTEMS ARE
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT ALL WORKS OUT
BUT- THERE'S NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT THAN CLEAN WATER AND
AT THE SAME TIME YOU DON'T WANT
TO HAVE A PRICE. THAT PEOPLE
CAN'T PAY AND I CAN'T THINK OF
ANYTHING MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THAT WHICH IS WHILE BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL. YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU I THINK YOU YOU
STATED IT WELL RIGHT THERE ARE
TWO THINGS THAT WERE NOT
COMPROMISING HERE. ONE IS THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO YOU KNOW CLEAN
SKIN AND AFFORDABLE WATER. AND
THE OTHER IS COMPLIANCE RIGHT
THOSE ARE TO THE FUNDAMENTAL
THINGS THAT WE ARE ALL IN
AGREEMENT WITH. WHAT WE'RE
ASKING TO BE DONE HERE IS IF
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO COMPLIANCE
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
WILL BE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS. THAT
WILL HAVE A BIGGER CHALLENGES TO
GET TO COMPLAINTS IDENTIFYING
THEM AS IT'S CRITICAL. AND WHAT
THE PATH TO COMPLIANCE LOOKS
LIKE IS THAT MUCH MORE. THE
ESSENCE OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SHARE WITH THIS LEGISLATION- WE
CANNOT HAVE. A SITUATION WHERE.
WE'RE PUTTING- THE FINANCIAL
CONSTRAINTS. ON THE CONVERSATION
OF PROTECTING PEOPLE- WITH THAT
PROVIDING CLEAN DRINKING WATER
RIGHT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PERCENT. WATER INCREASED TO GET
INTO COMPLIANCE- WHERE REALLY-
HURTING PEOPLE AT THAT POINT IF
FIVE IF NOT THROUGH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ASPECT. TO THE FINANCIAL
RIGHT AND- THAT'S JUST NOT.
ACCEPTABLE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO DO. IS
MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL. PLANTS IN
THAT EVERY ONE AT SAFELY
DRINKING WATER THAT'S AFFORDABLE
SPECTACLE. WELL GREAT BILL. CAN
WE HAVE A MOTION. MISTER MATHIS
AND- RESENTMENTS GARCIA YES ALL
RIGHT- WHEN YOU'RE READY MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS%
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FORTY ONE
EDUARDO GARCIA THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CORK
BY CORK I'D SMITH. SMITH I
ARAMBULA. KALRA KALRA HIGH
BENNETT CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI MATHIS MATHIS
AYE MURATSUCHI. WALDRON WE HAVE
FIVE VOTES. IT'S PAST ALL RIGHT-
MUCH TO HEAR YOUR NEXT BILL
FRAZIER THANK YOU RICHARD VERY
IMPORTANT BILL THIS IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER- WITH
REGARD TO THE TRIBES WITH THE
MOTION A SECOND I'LL BE BRIEF
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS EQUITY AS IT
RELATES TO PARTICIPATION AMONGST
OUR TRIBAL NATIONS AND THAT THEY
ARE NOT BEING ASKED TO
COMPROMISE WHAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO THEM AND
FUNDAMENTAL THE TRIBE
SOVEREIGNTY THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
GOVERN THEMSELVES AND SO-
INSURING THAT DOLLARS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE SAFER PROGRAM
WERE TRIBES- IS REALLY THE
OBJECTIVE A- SPELL RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. VERY GOOD- AND DOES
SCOTT GOVERNOR AND GOVERNMENTAL
ASSOCIATES IS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I THINK HE'S HERE IN
OUR AREA. WELL IT'S A GOOD BILL.
I DON'T I DON'T THINK FOR A LOT
. HE COMES IN LATER WE CAN HEAR
FROM AND ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT. MAN YOU COULD SAY A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF ONE GOOD
AFTERNOON KYLE JONES OF
COMMUNITY WATER SAID I REALLY DO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING AMENDMENTS THAT REALLY
GET AT THAT THE CRUX OF THE
ISSUE AND I HOPE WE CAN. ENSURE
THAT THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND IS ABLE TO
MEET TRAVEL NEEDS AS WELL. THANK
FORGET. ANDREA VENTURE WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION IN SUPPORT
AND WHAT HE SAID GOOD. ALL RIGHT
AND YET. THERE IS THERE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION OR LOSE. CONCERNED. BUT I GUESS NOT IN THE ROOM
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONES ARE ON AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SEVEN SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
TRIBES- SO THAT'S ONE ZERO. OKAY
TWO FOUR THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS SCOTT
GOVERNOR BEHALF OF THE MORONGO
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS I
APOLOGIZE THEM OVER IN THE SWING
STATES RIGHT NOW BUT WE DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TRIBE HAPPEN
L. WILL PRESS BE TWO HUNDRED
MONEY IN THE PAST HOWEVER THE
PROCESS WITH THE STATE BOARD.
HAS WORKED WELL AND BY AND LARGE
TRIBE UNABLE TO ACCESS THIS
MONEY WE BELIEVE THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO ENABLE
TRIED TO ACTUALLY USE. THE
FUNDING. FOR THANK YOU. ONE TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS LAURA ROSENBERGER HAIDAR
ASSURANCE NOW I SUPPORT THAT
BILL. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. VERY GOOD- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. I
CAN'T OVERSTATE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL AND ENSURING THAT
OUR TRIBES- ARE GETTING THEIR
FAIR SHARE ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO OUR TRAVEL
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE- ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO WATER. AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE
THIS BIRD AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO
CO AUTHOR AND HELP ANY WAY I CAN
WITH THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD- I'LL JUST
MAKE A COMMENT HERE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLES HAS BEEN THE
WATER BOARD INSISTING THAT THEY
TRIED TO GIVE UP ON THEIR
SOVEREIGNTY. I DON'T SEE A
NECESSITY FOR THAT. AND I HOPE
THAT THIS BILL WILL CONVINCE THE
WATER BOARD TO TAKE OTHER
ACTIONS THAT. CAN ASSURE- THAT
THEY'RE GETTING THEIR- THEY ARE
PROJECTS THAT THEIR FUNDING AND
AT THE SAME TIME LET TRIBES
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH DIGNITY
THAT THEY DESERVE. SO GIVEN THAT
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU RICHARD
YOU KNOW THE TRIBES- ARE
STRUGGLING WITH- THE ISSUE OF
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY WAY READING
FOR A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER STATE-
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AND I HOPE
THAT THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF. A
SAID BEING ABLE TO THIS IS A
FRAMEWORK AND APPLY IT TO OTHER
CODES IN STATE LAW THAT WILL
ALLOW THEM TO ALSO INTEGRATE YOU
KNOW THEIR EFFORTS WETHERBY
TRANSPORTATION- BROADBAND IN
THIS CASE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CLEAN WATER AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SO. THIS WHAT WILL REALLY KIND
OF LEAD TO OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
AS WELL SO EXPECT GAS FREE I'VE
ALL CURRENT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. MADAM SECRETARY COULD
YOU CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORK BY CORK HI
BETH. SMITH I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
I KALRA. CALLER I BENNETT.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I MATHIS MATHIS SIDE WHAT TO
CHANGE WALDRON. IF SIX SO THAT'S
OUT REGULATIONS VERY GOOD. BOB
ALL RIGHT. WOOD MISTER BENNETT
COMES BACK WE CAN HE'S GOING TO
PRESENT FOR MISS REAVIS ON THE
PLAY YOU KNOW I COULD PRESENT
THIS BILL. WHATYOUR ABILITY TO
PUT. RIGHT OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I
GUESS I'LL WAIT- ORDINARILY I
TURN THIS OFF IF THE VICE CHAIR
BUT I KNOW HE HAS TO LEAVE IT
FOR ANOTHER. SURE ADD ON FOR W.
ARAMBULA. I HAVE ONLY HAS THREE
OTHER COMMITTEES AT THIS TIME SO
. IDM SIX AB TWENTY FORTY ONE
EDUARDO GARCIA THE VOTE IS AT
FIVE ZERO. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
BENNETT WHAT A TO G. WALDRON FIX
IT TO SIX ZERO. ALL RIGHT PEOPLE
. YOU CAN SHOW IT AGAIN. I GOT
TO LEAVE IN THE WEALTHY KERR-
WHY DON'T I JUST START WITH
SOMEONE ELSE AND YOU'RE GONNA
LEAVE IN ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
THESE ARE GOING TO BE LONGER
BILLS AND I CAN GET WHOEVER IT
IS. SHARE ITEM TEN AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY NINE MATHIS. THE VOTE
SETS AT SIX ZERO BENNETT.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I WALDRON. BECAUSE THE SEVEN
ZERO. YEAH ARE YOU DON'T NEED TO
. FORGET YEAH FIVE ALL RIGHT-
ALRIGHT MY AGE WILL BE HERE
SHORTLY I'M GOING TO TAKE THE
MICROPLASTICS BILL FIRST THAT'S
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
MISTER COURT. GO AHEAD WHEN
YOU'RE READY FOR IT EVEY TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN REGARDING
MICROPLASTICS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
TEMPORARY CHAIR. AND AND MY
FELLOW MEMBERS- AS THE AS WITH
ALL BILLS WILL WE START BY
SAYING HOW HOW IMPORTANT-
COMMITTEE STAFF IS. THAT THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO CAN. GET THIS ON
THE RIGHT TRACK THEY WORK ON
THESE ISSUES THEY CAN TALK TO
THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DEPARTMENT. AND
THEY CAN THE- KEEP US ON TRACK
RIGHT A GOOD ANALYSIS. OF REALLY
GOING TO GET US TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND OUR BILLS. AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD BAN THE
SALE AND DISTRIBUTION OF
COSMETICS. THE CHURCH AND
CERTAIN CLEANING PRODUCTS THAT
CONTAIN INTENTIONALLY ADDED
MICROPLASTICS. NOW MICROPLASTICS
ARE AS PERSISTENT AS YOU COULD
GET IN THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
THERE ARE A PERVASIVE PROBLEM
YOU JUST HEARD THAT FROM- THAT
P. FAST- YOU HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM WITH PLASTICS. ARE THERE
EVERYWHERE AND OF COURSE YOU
ALSO HEARD THAT FROM- OUR BAIL
ON- WASHING MACHINE FILTERS. SO
THE IN PARTICULAR THERE S A
GREAT STUDY DONE BY THE ESTUARY
INSTITUTE SHOWING HOW THEIR
FIBERS EVERYWHERE ARE
PARTICULARLY- IT GETS INTO THE
BAY THROUGH STORMWATER. A LAKE
TAHOE ALSO HAS MY AGE WHAT IS A
PURE PLACE THE TAHOE.
MICROPLASTICS EVERYWHERE
STEADIES YOU SHOWN THAT
MICROPLASTICS ARE HARMFUL TO
MARINE LIFE. AND EXPERTS HAVE
RAISED CONCERN ABOUT THE IMPACTS
TO OTHER WILDLIFE AND HUMAN
HEALTH. ANDIN FACT YOU CAN FIND
IT IN PEOPLE'S LUNGS. ONCE
MICROPLASTICS A RELEASE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT OF COURSE THEY DON'T
BREAK DOWN THEY- CAN COULD
BECOME SMALLER AND SMALLER TO
THE POINT WHERE YOU CAN'T SEE
THEM. BUT THE SMALLER THEY GET
TO A CERTAIN SIZE THEY CAN BE
VERY HARMFUL. OF REPORTS BY THE
OCEANSIDE AND TRUSTS AND OTHERS
RECOMMEND USING A PREVENTIVE
APPROACH TO CONTROL SOURCES OF
MICROPLASTIC POLLUTION.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO CURB
MICROPLASTIC POLLUTION.
COLLUDING AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM WHICH
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
FIFTEEN IT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
BILLS I CHAIRED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WE SHOULD BAN THE SALE OF RENTS
OF PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THAT
CONTAIN MICROBEADS WHICH ARE
MICROPLASTICS THAT ARE USED TO
SCRUBBING AGENTS. EVER
MICROPLASTICS ARE STILL WIDELY
USED IN MANY OTHER CONSUMER
GOODS INCLUDING COSMETICS.
LAUNDRY DETERGENTS AND CLEANING
PRODUCTS CONTINUED NONESSENTIAL
USES OF MICROPLASTIC. IN THESE
PRODUCTS MIGHT REPORT RELEASED
CALIFORNIA'S WATER AIR AND SOIL. FEBRUARY THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL RECOMMEND THAT
CALIFORNIA RESTRICT THE USE OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED
MICROPLASTICS IN CONSUMER
PRODUCTS LIKE MAD. S. AS PART OF
A STATE WIDE MICROPLASTICS
STRATEGY. THIS BILL DIRECTLY
ACTS ON THAT RECOMMENDATION TO
PROHIBIT THE SALE OF COSMETICS
DETERGENTS. AND CERTAIN CLEANING
PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN
INTENTIONALLY ADDED
MICROPLASTICS TO PREVENT FURTHER
MICROPLASTIC POLLUTION.
DITERPENE UNION HAS PROPOSED
REGULATIONS TO PROHIBIT THE USE
OF MICRO PLASTICS IN THESE
PRODUCTS. I INTEND TO HAVE A
BILL THAT THE INDUSTRY CAN
COMPLY WITH MY HOPE IS TO ALIGN
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH YOU AGAIN
LATER. THIS HAS TO BE DONE IN A
MANNER THAT IS APPROPRIATE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT I BELIEVE WE CAN DO
THIS. WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH
TECHNICAL EXPERTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS. PRECIADO TACKLE
PREVENTED IT WORK WITH US. AS
WELL AS ACADEMIA AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
E. REGULATION. THE MEN COULD FOR
. I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
MY STAFF OF HAD WITH
STAKEHOLDERS UP TO THIS POINT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM FURTHER- ANY HELP THEY CAN
THIS IS. A LIVE. PHYLLIS IS.
KIRBY MICHAEL POLLUTION THAT IS
ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE. WITH ME
TODAY IS PROFESSOR SUSANNE
BRANDER FROM THE OREGON STATE
UNIVERSITY AND CODY PHILLIPS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA. POST
KEEPERS A LOT. PHONE MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE PLACE DR
SUSAN BRENNAN ON THE CALL. GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IT SHOULD BE
OPEN. TO SEND YOU SPEAK WILL BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU.
THE TYPE OF. THE CRITICALLY FOR
. TELL YOU WHAT SHE'S HAVING
TROUBLE GETTING ACCESS OR CODY
COULD YOU SPEAK FIRST. YEAH NO
PROBLEM- HI EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
CODY PHILLIPS ON THE POLICY
ANALYST FOR CALIFORNIA KEEPER
ALLIANCE I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN- RIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
SEVEN EXPAND ON THE MICROPHONE
BAG FROM AB. EIGHT EIGHT TWENTY
THREE. SIX ADDED TO MEDICS. AND
WHAT POLISHES. NOW THAT YOU'RE
VERY MUCH AWARE OF THE HARM OF
MY AND HOW UBIQUITOUS THEY ON
THE ENVIRONMENT SURROUNDING THE
DETAILS- JUST- YOU WANT TO POINT
OUT IS THAT HOW IT ALL FLOW INTO
OUR WATER THE PLASTIC WHAT. THE
HELL AND WATER. MICROSCOPIC THE
DEATH THEY'RE SO SMALL THAT THEY
CAN WORK THEIR WAY THROUGH
MOSTLY MARC WASTEWATER TREATMENT
FACILITIES CONTAMINATING OUR
DOWNSTREAM SUPPLY. FOR THE
TREATMENT FACILITIES THAT
CANCELS OUT THESE MICROPLASTICS
THOUGH TO PUT IN JUST KEEP AT
FIVE. I THERE. ENVIRONMENT TO
THE SIDE AND- AFTER THAT THE BY
THE BATHROOM FOR CONTROLLING
THEM IS MANAGING AT THE SOURCE.
SO THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES- AND FOR THAT REASON THE
REASON OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
STRATEGIC REPORT ON. SIX
REMANDED RECOMMENDED EXPANDING A
P. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. THE PEACE
PROCESS. SIGN THIS WOULD A GREAT
SOURCE CAN MICHAEL AND FOR THESE
REASONS I YOUR AYE THOUGH ON B.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. YOU FOR POTTERY OF. BRAND
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WONDERFUL I'M SO TO FOLLOW UP ON
WHAT OTHERS HAVE SAID
MICROPLASTICS ARE OF. AND DUE TO
THE TEMPERATURE SENSORS AND
THEIR PROPENSITY TO DEGRADE INTO
SMALLER AND SMALLER SMALLER
PIECES OF VOLUNTARY LACK OF
BIODEGRADE ABILITIES EARLY EVERY
. COULD YOU. I'LL EXISTENCE FROM
ONE FAVORITE DOWN INTO MY CRIB
UNDER ABOUT TEN MICRONS IN SIZE
CAN TRANSLOCATE AND THE BODY AND
THAT AND APOSS TEXTS WHICH
WINDOW- EXISTENCE ONE DAY BANK
THAT THEY CAN'T BE. BUT CAN I-
AND YOURSELF SHE AND WHERE
PEOPLE GET DIRECTLY IN WATER-
AND OF COURSE THE CAN OFFSET A
FACTOR CRITICAL THANK FROM THE
CHEMICAL THE TALK TODAY. I ALBUM
- CAN ARE YOU. THEIR PLASTIC
MANY THEM ARE AND- COME.
INTERFERE WITH FORMER FUNCTION
SH- SO MANY OBJECTIVE-
EVERYTHING RECENTLY COMPLETED
STATEWIDE MICROPLASTICS STRATEGY
WHICH I WAS- ALL TO CHECK.
SENATE BILL SIX THREE ISRAEL THE
COMPLETION ATTENTION BY CO AND
AFTER IT FROM STRICTER SENSE
NEITHER MICROPLASTICS IN
ANAPLASTIC CAN BE EASILY REMOVED
WHEN THEY ANSWER THE ENVIRONMENT
OR ONE INSURE THANKS REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF MAN PLASTIC ENTERING
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANT AND
THEN AND OUR CHANGE ON AN X. HIM
SO I WOULD SUPPORT. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SEVEN IT'LL LEAD TO
THE VERGE REDUCTION PRIMARY
CLASSIC ENQUIRING. AN EXCELLENT
AND IT IS RIGHT ACT ON THE OCEAN
COUNCIL RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THERE. ISSUED IN. HERE IT MUCH.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD LET
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT. HI JESSICA
GEIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI ANDRE AVERAGE JOE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT YOU.
LOCAL KOREAN WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO VOICES POOR
OF HEAL THE BAY AND THE CLINTONS
LOBBYING COALITION THANK YOU.
CLEAN WATER ACTION ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE ALSO HAVE
TWO PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY IN PERSON THE COLD
KIMONOS AND MANDY LEAVE PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO TESTIFY. RIGHT I
COULD SEE TO ZURCHER MEMBERS
MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL-
HERE IN REGRETFUL OPPOSITION-
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN A BILL THAT-
PUT RIGHT MICHAEL PLUS CONSUMER
PRODUCTS. AFTER WOULD HAVE. BEEN
BECAUSE MEDIC AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS
TODAY LET ME START OFF BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT MICROPLASTIC
POLLUTION IS A PROBLEM THAT WILL
REQUIRE CREATE STILL. A STRONG
TWELVE SEVENTY SEVEN OVER THE
BROAD FAILS TO CONSIDER MANY OF
THE RECENTLY DEVELOP INNOVATION
THEN ARE A THREE. TO ADDRESS THE
1% THE PROBLEM THROUGH X. EARLY
MATT. THE TWENTY. POST BY
MICHAEL STRATEGIES IDENTIFIED
MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO
MICROPLASTICS- THOSE CATEGORIES
INCLUDED VEHICLE TIRES TEXTILES
SINGLE USE FOOD WHERE AND
PACKAGING AGRICULTURE AND
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE
ADDITIONALLY AN E.U.
MICROPLASTICS DAYS FOUND THAT
EXTRAVERTED SEVEN EIGHTY AN
AIMLESS X. DIFFERENCE AND HIS.
THEN PERCENT MORE SPECIFIC POINT
NINE PER CENT TO MARK PROBLEM
GLOBALLY. NOT ONLY IS IT
PERPLEXING THAT AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WHAT THE MINIMUS
CONTRIBUTOR SIX BUT DEPENDING ON
HOW THE TERM MICROPLASTICS IS
ULTIMATELY DEFINED THE BILL
COULD DECIMATE AN ENTIRE. TRIP A
BANNING ANY OF THE PRODUCTS THAT
CONSUMERS FIND ESSENTIAL TODAY.
ALMOST NO ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT.
AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE THAT
MICROPLASTICS HAVE BEEN FOUND IN
OCEANS THIS BILL FAILS TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM BECAUSE IT
FOCUSES ON AND DOUBLE SORTS
RATHER THEM AMERISOURCEBERGEN OF
ABOUT. REMEMBER THE SIX R.
PALMER NOT ALL POLYMERS PLASTICS
MANY OF THE POLYMERS THAT OUR
INDUSTRY USES AIR LIQUIDE IN WAX
FORM NOT SOLID PARTICLE SECTOR
TO PLASTIC IN LETTER. AND IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THESE POLYMER
WHAT. SHERD IN UNDER THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL IF THEY ARE THEN
THIS BILL WOULD REPRESENT A
DEFECTIVE BAND BECAUSE IT IS NOT
THAT IS NOT A VIABLE SUBSTITUTE
FOR ME OF NON STICK POTS THAT WE
USED TO. BE GREAT PRODUCT PROOF
ONE STATE ETCETERA AND MANY OF
THE ATTRIBUTES THAT CONSUMERS
FIND USEFUL AND BANNING THESE
POLYMERS WOOD NESSUS THAT WOULD
NECESSARILY REQUIRE US. TO
REFORMULATE THE END PRODUCT
WHICH- WILL TAKE SEVERAL DECADES
TO DO. THE OF THE MATTER IS THAT
THE IT WAS STILL WORKING ON
THEIR DRAFT REGULATIONS WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY THE EQUIVALENT OF A
COMMITTEE REPORT IS WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TOLD BY THE U. COUNTERPART
. FOR IT SHOWS WELCOME EXIST
ISSUE ISN'T THE TIME IF YOU HAS
TAKEN- THAT TAKE. NUMBER OF YEAR
ASSEMBLY PLUS ELATION THERE'S A
DONE IT AS POOR LONG TOGETHER
RIGHT. HOWEVER THERE ARE THINGS
IN THE DRY. WE DO THIS- THAT WE
CAN SUPPORT AND WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ENGAGING IN
CONVERSATIONS AND HIS COMMITMENT
TO. ALIGNING- AS MUCH AS WE CAN
WITH THE E. U. IMAGINE IT'S TO
ALIGN IN THAT IS. THE YEAH. A
CALL A COLD. WHAT BUT I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT ONE THING AND- THE
U. CURRENTLY. AND THAT IS- OKAY
. SO WE BELIEVE THAT AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN SHOULD
EXAMPLE ON COSMETICS- WHICH ARE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT INTENDED
TO BE WASHED DOWN THE DRAIN.
THINK OF YOUR MASK YOUR LIPSTICK
HERE QUESTION THESE PRODUCTS- IN
MANY CASES REQUIRE THE CONSUMER
TO WIPE THEM OFF WITH THAT.
BACKED WE CONSUME AND THAT SHE
OVERNIGHT PERCENT SIMMERS
UTILIZE MAKE WIPES- TO REMOVE
THESE TYPES OF MAKEUP AND
THEY'RE SOLID WASTED RATHER THAN
BEING FLUSHED DOWN THE- AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUES. CONCERNS BUT- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THIS BILL
ONLINE WITH THE E. U. AND- UNTIL
THEN WE RESPECTFULLY REMAIN
OPPOSED MOST AMENDED. I THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER-
NICKEL CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE FRAGRANCE CREATORS
ASSOCIATION THE LEADING TRADE
ASSOCIATION. I'M MEMBERS
COMPRISING BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
FRAGRANCE PLAY CHAIN AS WELL AS
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATE. WHO'S NOT IN
CONSUMER PRODUCTS THERE'S A
PROPER IMPACT BY THIS BILL
INCLUDING DETERGENTS WAXES AND
POLISHES. WE WANT TO BE. THERE
AND AFTER. WILLINGNESS TO ALIGN
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WITH THE EUROPEAN UNION AND IT
ALSO- LIKE TO ADD- THE COMMON
SIDE PROVIDED BY MANDY LEE- IN
ADDITION AND ALL TALK ABOUT
FRAGRANCE AND CAP LET'S. ANY
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS SEEKING TO
ALIGN WITH THE EUROPEAN UNION
FIRST FRAGRANCE ENCAPSULATION IS
A LEADING SENT DELIVERY
TECHNOLOGIES USED BY THE FAKE
AND INDUSTRY AND CONSUMER
PRODUCT COMPANIES. FURTHER
FRAGRANCE THE SHIP AND- PERCENT
. 8004% I'VE BEEN ONLY ADDED
MICROPLASTICS. ENCAPSULATION IS
THE MOST RESOURCE EFFICIENT WAY
OF DELIVERING FRAGRANCE REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF PERFUME USED BY
ROUGHLY 33% WHILE ALLOWING THE
SENATE TO LAST LONGER. WHEN USED
IN DETERGENT THIS CAN ACTUALLY
LEAD TO SOME ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS- CONSUMER XIN TEXTILE
UP OFTEN. DO WATER USE LESS
CONSUMPTION BUT ALSO MICROFIBRES
GOING DOWN THE DRAIN WHICH HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE A MUCH LARGER
CONTRIBUTED. PASTA BY. FOR DISK
. DUE IN LARGE PART TO THE
SYSTEM BILLETE BENEFITS OF ALL
INCAPSULA TECHNOLOGY THE YOU
BUILT INTO THEIR MICROPLASTICS
REGULATION A BIO DEGRADATION
STANDARD BASED ON
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNISED WE C.
D. AND I. S. O. TESTING
STANDARDS SO THAT TRULY BY. THE
IS AS THE VIABLE PATHWAY
AVAILABLE TO INNOVATE AND
CONTINUE TO REALIZE THE BENEFITS
OF FRAGRANCE ENCAPSULATION A
BIODEGRADABLE STANDARD TO ALLOW
MORE SUSTAINABLE BIODEGRADABLE
POLYMERS IS AN ABSOLUTE
NECESSITY TO HAPPEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. OUT ALSO
LOOKING I'M L. ADD TO HAVE A DE
MINIMIS THRESHOLD IN THE
DEFINITION OF MICROPLASTIC TO
AVOID UNNECESSARY ENFORCEMENT OR
LITIGATION FROM- YOU KNOW DE
MINIMUS AMOUNTS ADDITIONALLY-
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AN EXEMPTION
FOR INORGANIC POLYMERS- WITHOUT.
THEM XIN INGREDIENTS LIKE FUSED
SILICA KIPLING CLAISEN BY US
WOULD BE BANNED FOR SO MANY EX
THERE HELLO ALL THIS END OF
CALIFORNIA BEYOND THE E. ANTI.
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THAT'S INTERESTING
MR COUNCIL FOR THE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU THANK. SEEN
OTHERS CIVIL TO GET TO THE PHONE
MODERATOR FOR WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER WILL YOU
BE STAYING AT THE POINT COUNTY
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT. FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU DON'T ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR. TWO HUNDRED. ZERO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THREE
NINE. ERIN WILLIAM BEHALF OF
FEAR OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
TWO SIXTEEN. MATT BROWN ON THE
BANK NAB. COMPOSTABLE. ALL AND
YET. CHIU FORTY EIGHT. HI THIS
IS WILL BE OVER ON BEHALF OF THE
PARTY THANK THAT WORK. AND IN
SUPPORT OF FELT. FOR SOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JEFFREY AND OF THE CLEANING AND
- POSE ENOUGH FROM REASON STATE
THANK YOU. ONE THREE. KAREN
GREEN WALKED INTO ACCOUNT AND TO
AND SUPPORT. TWO FIVE TWO. NEW
CHAIR MEMBERS IN SAUDI
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE MUCH. THANKS
SO MUCH THE GREAT WHAT IF IT.
AND TO FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. TWO FIVE FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
HI KATHY SHAPER FOR THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL ARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL TEND TO
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU AT PREPARE FOR THE SHEER
COMMITMENT TO ALIGN THIS WITH
THE EITHER NAY YOU'VE YOU'VE
STATED IT MANY TEETH IN THE
RECORD- THAT THE- FOR THAT.
PURPOSE WHAT. I MIND OR- THINK-
THE EASTERN TO BE. COMPLETED R.
LET ME CHECK ON THAT OKAY-
INSIDE ON THE WE HAVE A DEADLINE
HERE AND- FOR. THE BILL. AS THAT
SO BUT I WOULD LIKE TO BE A WORK
. HOW THAT AN ITEM. WITH OUR
TIME LINES ON THE ROAD- YEAH I'M
IT'S PROBABLY THE THIRD QUARTER
OF THIS. WE WILL WILL BE DONE
WITH AMERICA THANK THE SWELLED
THIRTY IS SEPTEMBER OCT BUT TO
THE FOURTH QUARTER IS. HOWEVER
THE MEMBER DECEMBER SO WE WILL
BE IN SESSION I FIFTH YOU KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO APPROVE IT BY
THEN FELT A VERY GOOD TRACK. MY
AND- IT SHOULD BE OKAY- AREA.
AND I'LL WORK THE STAKEHOLDER TO
MAKE THAT WE HAVE THAT. AND- WE
HAVE TESTIMONY ABOUT CAN HELP
YOU GOTTA BE CAREFUL THAT YOU
DON'T PAN SANDER CLAY HI I AGREE
WITH THAT I DON'T WANT TO
BANDSTAND OR PLAN. UP WE'RE
GOING TO. FIVE MY HOPE WOULD BE
THAT WITH YOUR WERE. IN OUR WORK
THAT COME TO CONSENSUS THAT WE
HAVE A BILL THAT WILL ALLOW
WHATEVER SOLD IN THE U. TO BE
SOLD HERE THAT'S MY OBJECTIVE
PURE AND SIMPLE. THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE- AND SO I AM I'M PREPARED
TO. SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY AND
I'M PROBABLY GONNA SUPPORT ON
THE PHARMACIST WITH WE DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER BY THEM BUT AFTER
RETURN TAKE THE HOPE THAT WE
SURE THAT. IS WITH WITH THE
STAND. FOR THE UP. AND MAKE A
VERY WELCOME MONTHS. OF
POSITIONAL GUARANTEE AND THERE
BUT MISTER. HAS BEEN AMANDA HIS
WORD FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS SO-
I LIVE FORWARD TO HOLD. A
VACATION. IN THE FUTURE. ABOUT
THAT OKAY NOW THAT. WHAT WE ALL
WANT TO THE SAME STANDARD. ANY
OTHER IN THE COMMITTEE. ALRIGHT
ALL MISTER CORK I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR ONGOING WORK. WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS AND- AS MISS
GARCIA SAID YOUR COMMITMENT TO
HAVE THIS NO SOCIALLY SO IT
MATCHES THE E. U. STANDARD- THE
EIGHT AND IS A GOOD STEP- IN
YOUR WORD AS MISS GARCIA SAID
OVER THE PAST DECADE WORKING
WITH USE UP IN SOLID IN YOUR CAR
IT'S- TODAY- SECRETARY SEE NO
OTHER COMMENTS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOTIONS NOW MOTION IT.
SECOND HAND I'LL JUST CLOSE OFF
SERVICE FOR. UP WITH REGARD TO
THE LEAVE ON COSMETICS OF WE
SHOULD HAVE A DISCUSSION ON THAT
OUR INFORMATION FROM THE E. U.
SAID IT'S ABOUT 50% DOES GO DOWN
THE IN THIS BILL TO WASH THEIR
FOR ISN'T. I DON'T I DIDN'T
HEAR. THAT'S RIGHT NOW THAT'S
GONNA BE REMAINING IN THE BELL
AND- THE OTHER QUESTION WAS IT
TAKES A LONG TIME TO DO THIS
THAT'S WHY WE'RE NOT TO READ.
BOB IF YOU WERE TO TRY TO DO
THIS IN CALIFORNIA I DON'T THINK
WE COULD EVEN AFFORD. THEY HAVE
SOME OF THE BEST SCIENTISTS IN
THE WORLD. WORKING WITH YOUR
COUNTERPARTS WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. AND THERE
ARE. WHEN ADDED I WAS TALKING
WITH THE PEOPLE FROM PROCTER AND
GAMBLE'S THE OTHER DAY. AND WE
DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH THAT
AGAIN. WE THE CALIFORNIA ADOPTED
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS. THAT
THAT CAN THEN SPREAD THROUGH THE
US AND YOU ONLY HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT MAKING ONE PRODUCT FOR THE
WORLD AND THAT WOULD BE MY HOPE
. WITH THAT PLEASE GO AHEAD. IDM
TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN CORK THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CORK
BY CORK ICE SMITH ARAMBULA.
KALRA BENNETT HI BENNETT I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I MATHIS MATHIS I WANTED TO
CHEAT WALDRON WE HAVE FOUR VOTES
SO FAR THANK YOU- WHY DON'T I
TAKE A BREAK A MISTER VAN IT CAN
PRODUCE PRODUCE CANNED- GIVE MR
MISS REAVIS IS BELL. BUT. MISTER
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO WITH THIS
THREE OF US IS A NINE THIRTY ONE
GO AHEAD. HELLO PASSED THE GAVEL
OPEN BACK TO THIS REPORT. OKAY.
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR CHAIR- YOU HAVE A FEW MORE
NAY CHECK AND NOW HE'S THE CHAIR
BACK OF THE- BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AT SHEERAN MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB NINETEEN THIRTY
ONE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY. LUIS
RIVAS SHE HAS WRITTEN THESE
COMMENTS IN THE FIRST PERSON I'M
GOING TO READ THEM IN THE FIRST
PERSON WHEN I SAY I AM REALLY
READING ON BEHALF OF- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY THE SMOOTHEST WAY FOR
US IN THIS- AND- I WANT TO START
BY THANKING JOSH FOR HIS
ANALYSIS- ON THIS. BILL AB
NINETEEN THIRTY ONCE A CRITICAL
BILL THAT PROTECTS ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER WHILE
ENSURING LEAD SERVICE LINE
REPLACEMENTS ARE DONE WITH
INDUSTRY STANDARD HEALTH
PROTECTIONS SPECIFICALLY AB
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE THE ACT IN A
PARTIAL LINE REPLACEMENTS THE
BILL ADDITIONALLY AS IMPORTANT
AND NECESSARY HEALTH PROTECTIONS
TO AVOID LEAD EXPOSURE THE BILL
REQUIRES. SYSTEM WELL BEFORE
CONSTRUCTION BEGINS IT ALSO
RECALL. WATER WATER FILTERS TO
BE PROVIDED AND FINALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES PRE AND POST WATER
TESTING TO ENSURE THERE ARE NO
LEVELS OF LEAD IN RESIDENTIAL
WATER. THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE CAN ALL AGREE THERE'S
NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD EVER. LET
IS ESPECIALLY DAMAGING TO
CHILDREN EVEN SMALL LEVELS CAN
CAUSE IRREVERSIBLE AND LONG TERM
NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEADS US LINES
DELIVER DRINKING WATER TO
MILLIONS OF HOMES IN THE STATE.
HAVE CORRODED OVER A MINUTE
RELEASE LEAD INTO DRINKING
WATER. UTILITIES ARE. FORMER
SEES REPLACEMENTS ARE OCCURRING
IS EXTREMELY CONCERNING AB
NINETEEN THIRTY ONCE NEEDED TO
ENSURE PARTIAL REPLACEMENTS
WHICH HAVE BECAUSE LEAD SPIKES
ARE BANDS THAT'S PARTIAL
REPLACEMENTS ARE BANNED TO
REQUIRED PORT INDUSTRY STANDARD
HEALTH PROTECTIONS. I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF THE REPLACEMENTS
UNDERWAY BUT AGAIN WE MUST
ENSURE THESE REPLACEMENTS ARE
DONE IN A SAFE HEALTH PROTECTING
MATTER OTHERWISE HE'S EFFORT TO
BE COUNTERINTUITIVE. MEMBER GET
WHAT THEY ARE DROUGHT WHAT IS A
PRECIOUS RESOURCE CENTERS.
CANNOT ALLOW THIS LIMITED. WE
CAN HAVE WITH LEAD AND THEN
EXPECT HOUSEHOLDS TO CONSUME. I
HAD WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY.
VIA TELE. IN ONE AND YOUR HAVE
COREY ALL OF THE NRDC.
WORKING GROUP IS HERE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS- AND
WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO- OUR TESTIMONY SPEAKERS ARE
RETURNED BACK TO THE CHAIR FOR
HIM TO CALL MY CUSTOMER RIGHT
SO- COREY THAT. SHOULDBE ON THE
LOT. AND JUST SPEAK UP AND WILL
HEAR YOU. ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR
ME YEP. GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
COREY BELL AN ATTORNEY WITH NRDC
A CO SPONSOR OF AB NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP AND CAL PARTNER ALSO COULD
. PARTIAL REPLACEMENT OF. FIND
HAVE BEEN HAPPENING THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ARE CURRENTLY LEGAL
IN THE STATE AND ARE HARMFUL TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE REPORT. CALL
BACK AND TELL WHY. IT'S HARMFUL
REPLACEMENT HAVE HAPPENED
WITHOUT BASIC PROTECTIONS LIKE
WATER FILTERS AND WATER TESTING
. THERE IS A LARGE POT OF
FEDERAL MONEY TO FUND FULL LEAD
SERVICE LINE REPLACEMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FACT BUT
WITHOUT AB NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
STATE COULD STOP ON THE GIARDIA
DOT FUNDING. IN ABOUT NINETY
THIRTY ONE CALIFORNIANS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ON. EXPOSE THAT
IN THERE RANKING WATER. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK THIS
CAN TO A THAT PARTIAL. ARE
STOCKED FULL REPLACEMENTS ARE
FUNDED AND IMPLEMENTED AND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ACTIONS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL FIREMAN
AND WITHOUT IT OVER TO DOCTOR
OLSON THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS THREE OAKLAND I AM OF
THEM AN ENVIRONMENTAL
ENGINEERING PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN. MY
LABORATORY HAS CONDUCTED BUT
MONITORING FOR DRINKING WATER
INCLUDING DURING THE PLAN WATER
CRISIS. I'M SPEAKING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY
ONE. OTHER BIT SPECIAL
REPLACEMENT OF LEAD CONTAINING
SERVICE BONDS IN CALIFORNIA LEAD
PIPES ARE MOST OFTEN FOUND AS
LEAD GOOSE NECK AS THEY'RE
CALLED EITHER SHORT CONNECTOR
SEGMENT BETWEEN THE WHITE MAINS
AND SERVICE LINES ONE ORIGINALLY
CALLED HERE LET WITH HAND AT THE
MATERIAL LET QUITE BEND THE ONE
CLIMBERS SHAPE IT EASILY. AND A
GOOSE NECK AS ONE FREE WATER
PASSES FROM THE ME THROUGH THE
LEAD GOOSE NECK THOUGH THE WATER
AND FOR TOOK UP LET AND ONE
THIRTEEN FINE MATURE LIKE
GOVERNOR IRON ARE PER. SCREEN ON
THE GOVERNOR I THANK. SEVEN I
DARN OF PROBLEMATIC AS THE LEAD
SOURCE FOR TO. FIRST THE THINK
CODING ON NEWER GALVANIZED PIPE
CAN CONTAIN UP 22% LEAD AND
HENCE IT CAN BE A FORCE OF LET
ITSELF SECONDLY AFTER THE THINK
CODING CORRODES THE UNDERLYING
IRON ROCK. AND THOSE LAYERS.
VERY GOOD. LED FROM THE GOOD FOR
THIS GALVANIZED IRON IS KNOWN IN
AS THE DRINKING WATER PLUMBING
MATERIAL. MY HOME STATE OF
MICHIGAN REQUIRES THE GALVANIZED
IRON SERVICE LINE BE REPLAYED AS
PART OF IT READ LATE BY SMALLER
COP. FOR MANY COMMUNITY WITH GO
. IRON THERMOCLINE MAY NOT HAVE
A HISTORY OF CORROSION PROBLEM.
UNEXPECTED CHANGES IN WATER
QUALITY CAN CAUSE CORROSION
ISSUES. THE CITY OF FRESNO
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE WHICH
INTRODUCED SURFACE WATER SOURCES
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR SUDDENLY
EXPERIENCE CORROSION OF MANY OF
THE GALVANIZED SERVICE LINE.
LEADING GUY FIVE PIPE IN THE
GROUND AFTER. REPLACING THE LEAD
GOOD SNACKS WITH THE LOOMING
POTENTIAL LEAD EXPOSURE THREAT
FOR UNSUSPECTING COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEM. REQUIRING THE REMOVAL OF
DOWNSTREAM GALVANIZED SERVICE
LINE AT THE TIME THE DISCONNECT
IS REMOVED ENSURES THAT THE
THREAT IS ELIMINATED. ALL OF THE
IS ALSO COST EFFICIENT AND
COMING BACK MUCH LATER TO
REPLACE GALVANIZED PIPES MEAN
TEARING UP THE STREET PAVEMENT
YET A SECOND TIME. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF SO DO WE
HAVE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT
AND WAS ALSO ASKED TO VOICE
SUPPORT FROM POLICY LINK THANK
YOU. THE WATER CENTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND UNDER
EVENTER WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OKAY NEXT WE
HAVE DANIELLE LET'S SET. PLEASE
COME FORWARD IN OPPOSITION. WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT YOU WANT TO GO
TO SUPPORT ON THE PHONE NOW OKAY
YEAH WE HEAR PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
FIRST IT. IT'S GOING TO THE
PHONE. WHAT WE DO WHICH IF AFTER
AT THE SAME TIME. BUT WE'RE
GONNA FOR FRIENDS OKAY. OF GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF MY NAME'S
BLAST WITH MISLEAD IS. WE
REPRESENT FIFTY WATER PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES THAT SERVE 75% OF
CALIFORNIANS AWARE UNFORTUNATELY
OPPOSED AB NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
OUR MEMBERS HIGHEST PRIORITY IS
DELIVERING SAFE RELIABLE WHY
SUPPLY THAT PASSED INCLUDING ALL
OF ANY LEAD PIPES WITHIN THEIR
SYSTEM. CALPERS JOB WE PRETTY.
AUTHORS EFFORTS IN THIS AREA
HOWEVER AB NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
IS NOT THE RIGHT APPROACH TO
ENHANCE LEAD RELATED PUBLIC
HEALTH PROTECTIONS AND COULD
ACTUALLY CAUSE CONFUSION OR
POTENTIAL SLOWDOWN. EFFORTS TO
GET ANY REMAINING LED OUT OF THE
WATER SUPPLY. USEPA IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO FINALIZE
THE FIRST MAJOR UPDATE TO THE
LEAD AND COPPER RULE IN NEARLY
THIRTY YEARS THE NEW RULE
ENSURES PROTECTIONS FOR CHILDREN
IN COMMUNITIES FROM THE RISKS OF
LEAD EXPOSURE. ANY PA'S EVEN GO
FARTHER THE NEW REGULATORY
PROCESS CALLED LEAD AND COPPER
RULE IMPROVEMENTS. THE COMPLY
STATE. BY THE OPERATE IS TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND WHILE C. R. I.
MAYES. THE DAY IMPINJ. AB ONE
STILL TWENTY BEFORE THE TWO NOW
AND- EIGHT THE GLOBAL LEADER I
THE STATE'S LEADING COPPER RULE
TO COMPLY WITH THE FED REQUIRE.
AND THAT WORKING ALREADY UNDER
WAY. THERE'S ALSO A BIG STATE BY
OF OURS COMMUTER WATER SYSTEM TO
COMBAT IT INTO. OF KNOWN USER
SERVICE LINES WITHIN THEIR JUST
SAYS. AND IT HAS A TWO. AND FOR
LINE IN THOSE ARE. BUT MAY BE BY
TWENTY TWENTY. WATER SYSTEMS
THAT REPORTED ANY LEAD USER
SERVICE LINES. IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE NEW LAW RECEIVED IN
AMENDMENTS TO ITS PART HE WATER
OPERATING PERMIT THAT CONTAINED
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS PUTTING
THE CATION FOR. IN THE PLAYING
I'M SOME OF WHICH IS TO IN THE
BILL. ALREADY FOR CAL WATER'S.
FIRED HAS THIS YEAR SYSTEM
THROUGH PERMIT AMENDMENT AB
FORTY SIX AM WORK WITH CHILD
CARE. TO TEST THEIR WATER SO.
GIVEN THIS EXTENSIVE WORK TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PENDING STATE ACTIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS EIGHTEEN JAN THIRTY
ONE ASSEMBLY. TO WELL THE INTENT
OF VISION IN THE BILL SIMILAR TO
FEDERAL. THEY'RE NOT ENTIRELY
CAN STAND IT THE PARTS WILL.
WITH OR DO REGULATIONS. AS SO
THE BILL COULD ACTUALLY SLOW
DOWN AND- TO PROTECT AND. WE CAN
MEMBER. IN A MINUTE THEY ADDRESS
ONE OF THE CAN BUT ALSO. FURTHER
CONFUSION ARE FOUNDATIONAL
CHALLENGE WITH THE BILL REMAIN
WE URGE NO VOTE. THANK YOU-
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION. NO UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE PHONE LINES THIS IS A BE
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE THREE OF US
A COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS LEAD
PIPES- WE WANT TO HEAR YOUR NAME
POSITION. AND OR STATION ONLY-
EIGHTEEN T. PLEASE ASK FOLKS TO
TESTIFY HELLO OKAY. YEAH SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION- FIVE. AFTER
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JENNINGS
TERM WITH CALPERS WERE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY
ONE ALSO ACTIVELY SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR
CHEMICALS AND TOXIC FOR SAFETY
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
AND PORTANTINO CHILDREN NOW AND
CONTRIBUTE LEAGUE THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED. HELLO MY NAME IS LAURA
HAIDAR IF SUPPORTERS STILL. I'M
ALSO I'M GOING TO TRY EIGHT T.
SEVEN H. BTC. TWO FIFTY PLEASE
AHEAD TWO FIVE SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON WINDOW A WESTERN
CENTER ON MON TOP IN SUPPORT.
AND NO ONE ELSE IS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT- QUESTIONS
FOR EITHER SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
THIS COMMERCIAL G. THANK YOU OF
SINCE SIR MISTER BENNETT IS
FILLING IN FOR MISERY OF US ALL
DIRECT THE QUESTION TO- MS
LITTLE- SO- COULD YOU RESPOND TO
THE MINISTRY TILDES CONCERNED
THAT THIS BILL ACTUALLY SLOW
THINGS DOWN IN TERMS. BUT
ABATEMENT WELL ACTUALLY I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT ACCORDING
TO TIMELINE SUBMITTED TO THE
WATER BOARD AT THIS POINT THIS
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO ALMOST
HALF OF THOSE WATER SYSTEMS THAT
HAVE REPORTED LED LOCKS HAVE
ALREADY MOVED FORWARD AND
REMOVED THEIR LINES UNDER THE
SYSTEM THAT. YOU KNOW IT'S AN
WHAT WITHOUT. CONTROLS BY TWENTY
TWENTY SIX MORE THAN SIXTY SEVEN
ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF THE SYSTEM
WILL HELP SYSTEMS WILL HAVE
ALREADY REMOVED THEIR LINES. AND
THIS IS IN ADVANCE ESSENTIALLY
THIS HAPPENING PRIOR TO THE
FEDERAL. HIS ARE COMING UP. JUST
WHAT EFFECT TO TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR BEYOND AND IF THE SYSTEMS
HAVE REMOVED THEIR LEAD LINES
THEY WILL NOT HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH ANY FURTHER INVENTORY
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE FEDERAL
LAW I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT ONE
THING THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN- THE DESCRIPTION OF THE
LEAD LINE REMOVALS THAT THIS.
THAT- THAT AND PRESENTED AND ARE
. INTERPRETATION OF THEM IS THAT
BASICALLY WHAT'S WHAT'S LOOK
WHAT'S MISSING IN THE CALIFORNIA
FRAMEWORK- IT'S THAT THE SCHEME
OF BLOODLINE REMOVALS. IS THAT
GALVANIZE LINES ATTACHED TO LED
FITTINGS WHICH- DOCTOR OLSON
FROM MICHIGAN TALKED ABOUT.
THOSE ARE NOT CONSIDERED LEAD
SERVICE LINES IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE IN OTHER STATES LIKE IN
MICHIGAN AND SO DOES GALVANIZE
LINES THAT ARE NOW CONTAMINATED.
BY BEING A TOUCH LED FITTINGS.
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO REMOVAL OR
CONTROL OR CONTROL UNDER OUR
SYSTEM. THE WATER BOARD HAS
INDICATED THERE'S OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND REMAINING
GALVANIZE LINES THE STATE. AND
MANY AT THAT THEY KNOW OF AND
THAT MANY AND WE KNOW THAT MANY
OF THOSE WOULD BE. AT OR HAVE
BEEN AT. AND STATE IS NOT. TO
DATE AND THAT'S WHAT AB NINE
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE IS TRYING TO
DO BY EXPANDING THE DEFINITION
OF A LEAD SERVICE LINE THAT THAT
IS SUBJECT TO THIS OVERSIGHT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTIONS. SO
YOU'RE NOT CONCERNED THIS BILL
IS GOING TO SLOW DOWN EFFORTS
FOR LEAD ABATEMENT- NO NO. ACT
IT'LL IT'LL OUR POSITION IS THAT
IT WILL ACTUALLY- MOVE MOVE
THOSE SO MUCH HAS ALREADY BEEN
DONE BUT IN IN IN THE LIMITED
WAY RIGHT NOW THAT'LL ACTUALLY
MOVE- WILL MOVE THAT MOVE THE
LEAD ABATEMENT FORWARD BY- BY
REQUIRING THE SYSTEM WELL. THIS
COUPLED WITH THE POTENTIAL OF
THE FUNDING COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOW WHICH
ALLOWS SYSTEMS TO. PAY FOR IT
WILL BE OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
TO THE STATE WILL ALLOW SYSTEMS
TO PAY FOR FULL LEAD SERVICE
LINE REPLACEMENTS BUT IF WE
DON'T EXPAND THE DEFINITION THIS
WAY THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE TIMES SO WE
WOULD SAY THEY JUST AREN'T. MOVE
FORWARD AS COMPREHENSIVELY AS
POSSIBLE WITH THE ASSISTANCE TO
USERS THANKS AND ALL JUST APPEAL
THE DAY WERE. JACK BUT- IN THE
END THE WATER BOARD A ALL OF
THIS AND IF THEY DON'T LIKE IT
THEY WILL EAT LETTER KNOW OR
THEY'LL BE A VETO SO- HE SIGHED
WITH THE- PROPONENTS- BUT THE
WATER BOARD WILL BE THE ULTIMATE
ARBITER OF THIS SAID. I HATE I
HAVE THEIR FIVE VERY DEDICATED
COMMISSIONERS GREAT STAFF. I
THINK THEY WILL MAKE A FINAL
DECISION AS TO WHAT HAPPENS ON
THIS WE THINK WE ARE WE THINK
THIS BILL IS ON TARGET. YOU
THINK IT WELL AS BEST WE CAN
TELL REALIZE MY STAFF YEAH. AND-
YES AND MY STAFF HAS A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA- BUT
AGAIN ULTIMATELY IT'LL BE THE
WATER PORT THAT WILL DECIDE AND
THEY'LL EITHER LIKE THE BILL OR
THEY WON'T. AND SO I'M NOT. IF
FOR SOME REASON. IT WOULD SLOW
IT DOWN THE WATER BOARD TO KNOCK
IT ALLOW PETS AND I BELIEVE AS
WAS JUST STATED HERE THAT'LL
SPEED UP AND YOU THINK IT'LL
SLOW IT DOWN AND- YOU KNOW I
THINK WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
AS CHAIR FEKIR BOB ON ON BEHALF
OF- OF THE AUTHOR BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THIS EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF RIGHT OF WHAT IS
COVERED IT THEREFORE EXPANDS THE
REVENUE THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
THE ENTIRE VERSION. THAT IS A
WAY TO SPEED UP AB NOT MAY NOT
BE SPEEDING UP STUFF THAT WAS
ALREADY PLANNED BUT JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE DOING SO MUCH MORE YOU'RE
SPEEDING UP STUFF THAT WOULD NOT
HAVE GOTTEN DONE AT ALL BECAUSE
IT EXPANDS. APPRECIATIVE THAT
COMMITTEE STAFFERS NODDING THEIR
HEAD THAT I GOT THAT RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE MYSTERY OF US
RIGHT NOW AND THERE IS ALSO TIME
TO WORK. WITH- THEY WERE. CEASE
M. THE AUTHOR AND ARE I HOPE
THAT YOU COULD COME TO AN
AGREEMENT BUT- SINCE THE
AUTHORIZATION HERE I WILL SPEAK
FOR HER AND SAY I KNOW SHE'LL
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS. ALL RIGHT
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT- WELL THEN
WILL WE TAKE WHAT YOU JUST SAID
IS A CLOSE- I HAVE- YOU HAVE A
CLOSE AND SO I THINK I SHOULD
SAY THAT SENSITIVE FOR BIG WORK
TARGET IT. ONE IS SLATED TO
RECEIVE BILLIONS DOLLARS THE
FEDERAL BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW FOR THESE
REPLACEMENTS. THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING IS UNPRECEDENTED AND
MUST CAPITALIZE ON THIS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY. THERE ARE MOVING
PIECES TO THIS BILL AND- I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MY
OPPONENTS THE WATER BOARD IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD JUST.
ADVANCE DAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL WHICH TRIGGERED. SO I
THINK THIS BILL GOES IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR REASONS
STATED BY PERMANENT- AND LET'S
SEE WE HAVE A MOTION YET. OKAY
ARAMBULA GARCIA- CHAU LET'S GO.
THIS IS ITEM TO. AB NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE LUCENT REVISE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORK BY CORK I
SMITH. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I KALRA
. KALRA I'D BENNETT AYE BENNETT
AYE CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I MATHIS. WHAT SAID SHE
WANTED TO CHECK AYE WALDRON. SIX
WE HAVE SIX VOTES SO THAT'S OUT-
GRADUATIONS. VERY GOOD AND THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING THAT BELL
MISTER BENNETT. OKAY MYSTIKAL.
SIR YOU HAVE A LONG HISTORY.
YEAH YEAH. THIS.
IN HERE. I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- WE HAVE CHAIR COURT. A.
B. TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE. WHEN
OKAY ALL RIGHT. WELL THANK YOU
CHAIR PRO TEM. AND MEMBERS- AND
AGAIN YOU KNOW WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING WITHOUT OUR STAFF BOTH
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- MY STAFF
MARIE CANAL WHO WAS BECOME AN
EXPERT. OR AT LEAST TALK TO THE
EXPERTS- HAS FOUND OUT A LOT
MORE ABOUT THE BAY DELTA ESTUARY
THEN I KNEW THAT WOULD LIKE TO
FIND OUT- SO THE- ESTUARY IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE
PARTICULARLY WHERE I LIVE IN THE
AREA. IT TWENTY NINE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS IRRIGATION TO FOUR
AND A HALF MILLION ACRES OF
FARMLAND. AND CRITICAL HABITAT
FOR MANY NAY FOR NATIVE SPECIES
. STATE WATER BOARD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROTECTING THE
WATER IN THE BAY DELTA BY
ADOPTING AND IMPLEMENTING WATER
QUALITY OBJECTIVES AS PART OF
THE BAY DELTA WATER QUALITY
CONTROL PLAN OR WE'LL JUST CALL
IT THE BAY DELTA PLAN. HOW ARE
THE LAST MAJOR UPDATE TO THE
PLAN WAS ADOPTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
AGO. IN FACT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
UPDATED EVERY YEAR THREE YEARS
AND- THAT'S NINE UPDATED MISSED
NINE UPDATES MISSED. UP SINCE
THEN THE IMPACT OF DROUGHT AND
CLIMATE TO A CRISIS HAD BEGUN TO
WRECK HAVOC ON THE DELTA COUPLED
WITH OTHER FACTORS. THIS IS
TRIMMING SOME NATIVE FISH TO THE
BRINK OF PART OF- THANK CHEN AND
SOME TO EXTEND. WHEN THE WATER
BOARD STARTED THE MOST RECENT
UPDATE TO THE BAY DELTA PLAN IN
TWO THOUSAND DIED. THAT'S WHEN
THEY STARTED THIS PROCESS SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIRTEEN
YEARS AGO. YOU COULD STILL FIND
DELTA SMELT IN THE DELTA. BUT I
REMEMBER HEARING FROM EXPERTS
THEY SAID IF YOU DON'T DO
SOMETHING RIGHT AWAY THE SMELTER
GONE. AND THE SMELTER GONE- WILL
SMELL TO HAVE NOT BEEN FOUND IN
THE DELTA OF THE WILD FOR FOUR
YEARS THEY DO HAVE SOME IN THE
TANK. BUT CHAD THEY THIS IS ONE
OF THESE. SPECIES THAT EXISTED
IN VERY LARGE NUMBERS NOT AT ALL
CLEAR YOU COULD BRING THEM BACK
BY PUTTING IN A STARTER
POPULATION WHEN. IF THE DELTA IS
EVER GOING TO BE BETTER SO THEY
MAY BE GONE FOREVER. REPORTS BY
WHAT OUR LAW EXPERTS AND
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE HE
FOUND THAT UPDATES DEBATE OUT TO
PLAN. ARE URGENT NEEDED TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA MAKING WATER
DATA FISH AND THE WATERSHED
ITSELF FROM WORSENING THREATS
CLOSE BY THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND
DROUGHT. THE LACK OF MODERN
WATER QUALITY STANDARDS ALSO
HURTS LONG TERM PLANNING FOR
WATER PROJECTS BY CREATING
UNCERTAINTY IF THERE'S A PLAN
YOU CAN SAY I WANT TO DO X. AND
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE PLAN.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A PLAN THANK
YOU DO A- YOU YOU YOU REALLY
DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S GOING TO
BE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
WATER BOARD WANTS TO DO. SO THIS
BOAT THIS BILL CO DEFIES THE
CURRENT GOAL OF THE STATE WATER
BOARD STAFF TO ADAPT AND
IMPLEMENTED UPDATE TO THE BELT
BAY DELTA PLAN BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. IF THE
DEADLINES THIS PLANNER MESS THE
WATER BOARD. NOW UNDER THIS BILL
. YOU KNOW. IT'S TAKEN THIRTEEN
YEARS TO GET TO THIS POINT IN
THE MEANTIME WE'VE HAD ONE
SPECIES. COACH TANKED AND
SEVERAL OTHERS ON THE BRINK OF
EXTINCTION. SO IF THE DEADLINES
MIX MR GAS AND WE WERE JUST SAID
HERE IS YOUR DEADLINE. IT IT
JUST IT COULD IGNORE IT SO WE
HAVE A CONSEQUENCE. AND THAT
CONSEQUENCE IS THE THIRD BE A
PAUSE IN ISSUE WE KNEW WATER
RIGHTS THAT WOULD A DISH THAT
WOULD DIVERT ADDITIONAL FLOW
AWAY FROM THE DELTA. OUR HOPE
WOULD BE THAT HAVE THE PLAN DONE
IS STAFF SAID THEY COULD. I
THINK END OF THIS YEAR- BUT IF
THEY DON'T THEN THIS WOULD COME
INTO EFFECT WE FEEL THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD IN FACT-
SPUR THE- THE WATER BOARD TO
COME TO THE CONCLUSION. THIS
TEMPORARY MORATORIUM AXES AN
INCENTIVE TO COMPLETE THE AB-
ADAPTION OF THE BAY DELTA PLAN
AND ENSURES THAT THESE WATER
RIGHTS PERMITS CAN BE ASSESSED
USING CONTEMPORARY STANDARDS. SO
ONCE YOU HAVE A PLAN YOU CAN
THEN SAY- YES THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE PLAN WE CAN ISSUE THE
WATER RIGHTS. MOVING FORWARD I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE OPPOSITION
TO AVOID UNINTENDED IMPACTS
PROJECTS IF POSSIBLE. AND AGAIN
WE- WE ARE ALLOWING RENEWAL OF
CURRENT WATER RIGHT SO IF YOU
EVER CURRENT WATER RIGHT YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE THAT
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY'VE COME TO THE NEW PLAN BUT
HOPEFULLY THEY WELL AND NONE OF
THIS WILL EVER GOING TO AFFECT.
IT YOU PROBABLY A NUMBER OF
YOU'VE DONE WHAT I DO WHICH IS
TO SET A DEADLINE FOR AN AGENCY
AND IT JUST DOESN'T HAPPEN. WITH
ME TOO. CLIFFORD LEVY WHO
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
FOR FORTY YEARS. IN PERSON OR
ISSUE IS OKAY FROM WHAT COMES
DID YOU SO MUCH- DOCTOR CORK
AND- MISTER LEE. PLEASE
EVERYBODY YOU MAY GO AHEAD AND-
AND TESTIFY. SO THERE YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER. AFTERNOON A-
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBER
ARE- AMONG PERSONAL I WANT TO A
THIS SUMMER BY BY THE CHAIRMAN
IS EXCELLENT HI I'M JUST GOING
TO CUP COVER UP A COUPLE OF
SHORT ISSUES MY NAME IS CLIFF
LEE AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE. I'M A
RETIRED CALIFORNIA DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS. OVER FORTY.
FOR YOUR WATER BOTTLE.
REPRESENTING AGENTS OF STATE CAL
- INCLUDING THE STATE COURT
LITIGATION OVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ONLY TWO
PRIOR WATER QUALITY CONTROL
PLANS. UP TO DENY SO. AND WHEN
IT DOES NOT NINETY FIVE ALL
WHICH RESORTED IN RESOLUTION IN
FRONT COURT OF APPEAL DECISIONS
ALTHOUGH ALTHOUGH I'VE DONE MOST
OF MY PROFESSIONAL WORK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE I'M
HERE ON MY BEHALF AND NOT ON
BEHALF OF ANY AGENCY THE CITY
CALIFORNIA OR- POINT. RECENTLY I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
A GROUP OF WATER RESOURCE
SPECIALISTS MANY OF THEM
ACADEMICS BUT OTHERS WERE WATER
PRACTITIONERS ON A PROJECT TO
REVIEW CALIFORNIA WATER RIGHT
SMALL FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. FIFTY THREE THE GROUP
RELEASED ITS REPORT WHICH
INCLUDES A RECOMMENDATION TO SET
A DEADLINE FOR COMPLETION OF THE
BAY DELTA WATER QUALITY PLAN UP
. EGGMAN AND IN THE CHURCH OF B.
TWENTY SIX THIRTY NOT. I WOULD
LIKE FOCUS ON ONE KEY REASON
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION. BY
PROVIDING REGULATORY CERTAINTY
FOR PROPOSED PROJECTS THAT
DIVERT FROM THE BAY DELTA
WATERSHED. AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
THIRTY NINE ALLOWS WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN THE
STATE TO MOVE FOR MORE PROMPTLY
TO COMPLETION IMPLEMENTATION NOW
WHY IS THAT SO- VIABILITY OF A
WATER PROJECT BUTTE A DIVERSION
TO GROUNDWATER STORAGE. WILD OR
SIR RESTORE. THE PROJECT A SPOON
OPERATING QUITE. JACKIE TO THE
COURSE PROD BENEFITS ARE IN THIS
LINKED TO PROJECT OPERATING
CRITERIA THE BAY DELTA WATER
QUALITY OBJECTIVES ARE AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF THE
OPERATING CRITERIA FOR ANY
PROJECT TO DIVERT FROM THE INTEL
TO WATERSHED THEREFORE THE
VIABILITY OF ANY PROJECT
AFFECTING. THAT AFFECTS ALSO
DEPENDS UPON THE RESOLUTION OF
THESE OBJECTIVES. BY SETTING A
CALENDAR DEADLINE FOR THE BAY
DELTA PLAN UPDATES AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY NINE PERMITS THE PROJECT
ASSUMPTIONS REGARDING OPERATING
CRITERIA TO MOVE FROM GUESSWORK
AND SPECULATION THE ACTUAL
REALITY THUS ALLOWING FOR THE-
INFORMED CONSIDERATION OF WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT ARE
NEEDED TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
WATER FUTURE. FOR THAT KEY
REASON I WOULD URGE BUT THIS-
COMMITTEE- TO APPROVE AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR LEE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY NINE. ONE ZERO
ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOUR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS ALREADY
OPEN. WHAT THREE. MY APOLOGIES
DI<c.cyan> KEEPER OPPOSITION. OKAY</c>
WHOA WHOA BUT WHEN YOU GO AHEAD
AND STATE YOUR NAME TITLE
OPPOSITION STARTING ON THE LINE.
YEAH THANK YEAH SURE KALRA SORRY
FOR THE CONFUSION RIGHT EXACTLY
WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY- OPPOSE OR NOT THANK
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THREE
GO AHEAD. ALL ARE YOU SURE
NUMBER KAREN LYING ON TOP OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE FOX AND
WORKING AGAINST BOTH IN
OPPOSITION THE BOSTON. THANK YOU
. TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE CONTACT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS GAIL BELL HANNAH WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION I'M
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ERIN WOOLLEY
ON BEHALF OF SPHERICAL
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SIX THREE NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FOUR ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
NATALIE ACT ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ACTION FUND IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SIX THREE NINE. THANK
YOU. ONE ZERO SEVEN. SHE'S JOHN
MCMANUS WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SIX THREE NINE. THANK YOU
. TEN FOUR FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS WITH NINETY BAKER WEST
PLAYING CONSERVATIONIST BOXER OF
THE OFFICE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE SACRAMENTO RIVER COUNCIL.
THE END OF THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SURE FIVE POINT. THE. FIFTY ONE.
TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANA FERREIRA ON BEHALF OF
MODESTO IRRIGATION DISTRICT WE
ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. TWO SIX TWO. CAROLYN JENSEN
WILL BE HAPPY BUT TURNING IT FOR
WATER DISTRICT OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU. TWO
FIVE SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MARTIN DOCUMENTS ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT SOMETHING THE SENATE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ZERO SIX.
MIKE JENSEN WITH PERCENT YOU'RE
ENGAGED DISTRICTS OPPOSE WHAT
MANTA THANK YOU. ZERO ZERO.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAURA
ROSENBERGER HAIDER'S SUPPORT IT
. THANK YOU. TWO FIVE FIVE.
CRITICAL I WOULD THREE VALUE
PRINCIPLE WATER DISTRICT OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND TWO FOUR FIVE. TWO FOUR
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ERIC TURNER ON BEHALF OF
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU. SIX
THREE. TWO SIX THREE. NINE
ENDING IN ONE ZERO EIGHT FIVE
NUMBER TWO SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM DAVID **** YOU WITH
THE BELLAVISTA WATER DISTRICT
CALLING TO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO BE
GOT- THE MIX OF THE CALLS IN
THERE THAT WANT TO COME BACK TO
THE ROOM FOR ANY PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. YEAH.
THANK YOU CHAIR KALRA IN MEMBERS
CINDY TECH WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND THAT IS
FOR THREE REASONS AND I'LL COVER
THE THREE. SO FIRST JUST THAT
SUBDIVISION C. BE DELETED
THERE'S ONLY THREE SUBDIVISIONS
IN THE BILL SUBDIVISION FEES
SHOULD BE DELETED. THIS IS THE
PROPOSED CONSEQUENCE FOR THE
SITUATION IF THE WATER BOARD
MISSED THE TWO DEADLINES FOR
PROPOSED ACTIONS UNDER THE BILL
. THE PROBLEM IS THE CONSEQUENCE
WOULDN'T AFFECT THE WATER BOARD
WHAT IT WOULD D IS PUT ON HOLD
A TOOL THAT WATER MANAGERS NEED
AND THAT IS THE ABILITY TO
OBTAIN A WATER RIGHTS. FOR THE
DIVERSION OF WATER FROM THE
WATERSHED TO SURFACE WATER
STORAGE. ONE EXAMPLE UNDER THIS
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS A
POSSIBLE DELAY FOR THE SITES
RESERVOIR THAT'S A PROPOSITION
ONE PROJECT WHICH WOULD BENEFIT
SALMON. WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DELAY OF PROJECTS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THAT
WOULD PROVIDE OR HELP PROVIDE A
RELIABLE WATER SUPPLY FOR
COMMUNITIES IN THE VALLEY
PARTICULARLY WHEN THERE'S-
DECREASING GROUNDWATER PUMPING
UNDER SIGMA. SO THAT'S THE FIRST
ISSUE THE SECOND ISSUE IS THAT
THERE'S A SUBDIVISION AIM BE
GIVE PROPOSED DEADLINES FOR
WATER BOARD ACTIONS AND OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THE DEADLINES DO
NOT AFFORD ENOUGH TIME FOR
INCORPORATION OF WHAT WE WOULD
CALL AN INTEGRATED APPROACH
THROUGH AGREEMENTS. AND YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN JUST RECENTLY THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED THIS WAS ON MARCH
TWENTY NINTH A KEY MILESTONE FOR
THEIR WORK IN THIS AREA YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT FROM MR
LINK. WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PROPOSED DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE
DEADLINE FOR THE ADOPTION OF THE
FINAL BE DELTA PLAN UPDATE WE
THINK THAT WOULD. IN A LONG TIME
TO GET TO THIS FOR BUT WHEN
YOU'RE AT THE END YOU DON'T WANT
TO RUSH THE PUBLIC PROCESS FEES
THAT HAPPENED. AND WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT TO PROCESS ABOUT
ON STAKEHOLDER INPUT INTO THE
PROCESS SEES AND ONE OF THE
PROCESS USES THE SEEK WHAT PART
OF THIS THAT'S- A CRITICAL. THE
THIRD ISSUE IS THAT THERE'S A
PROPOSED DEADLINE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PLAN
AMENDMENT THAT HAS BEEN ADOPTED
RECENTLY AND TO PLANT AMENDMENT
FOR THE LOWER SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
AND ITS TRIBUTARIES. AND FOR
THAT PLAN AMENDMENT THURS
ONGOING LITIGATION RIGHT NOW AND
WE THINK THAT THE AMENDMENT
IGNORES AT LITIGATE AND- TO GET
TO WHERE WE ONLY.
HONOR IS WORKING FOR. SO WE
RECOMMEND AMENDMENTS AS NOTED IN
OUR LETTER TO SUBDIVISION A AND
B. AND DELETION OF SUBDIVISION
C. BUT WITH THE BILL IN THE
CURRENT FORM THAT'S BEFORE YOU
TODAY WE URGE A NO VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS
ACURALINK WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION-
CINEMA QUICKLY WHEN IF IT SAY
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
AND SEE IF WE CAN FIND A
WORKABLE SOLUTION THAT BENEFITS
ALL- WE DO CONCUR WITH DOCTORS
ASSESSMENT AND STILL OF AN
OPPOSING. AMENDED ON AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY NINE. WE HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS THAT THE BILL WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE RECENTLY
SIGNED HABITAT AGREEMENTS.
BENEFITING FISH WILDLIFE IN THE
BACK ELTA. CINDY MENTIONED IN%
TWENTY TWENTY TO. COALITION
WORKING SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SIGNED A HABITAT INSTREAM FLOW
AGREEMENT AND- YOU IN ATTENDANCE
WITH THE GOVERNOR. BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES CDFW CDFA NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER- MATT STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY AND MANY OTHER WATER
ORGANIZATIONS AND SOME WILDLIFE
ORGANIZATIONS ALL WORKING TO
INCREASE SALMON AND MIGRATORY
BIRD POPULATIONS AND BETTER
DELTA WATER QUALITY. THE
AGREEMENTS SHOULD BE AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE BAY DELTA PLAN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD'S
MODELING HABITAT AGREEMENT
PROJECTS THESE BENEFITS WILL
INCLUDE. UP TO EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND ACRE FEET
OF A BUFFALO TO AND THROUGH
DELTA SOMETHING WE POLICY IS
BENEFICIAL. TWENTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF ADDITIONAL FLOODPLAIN
REARING HABITAT BENEFITING
SALMON AND MIGRATORY BIRDS
TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES OF FLOODED
RICE CROPLAND TO PROVIDE SU
PLANKTON GROWTH WITHOUT CREATING
SOUP SOUP TO FEED JUVENILE
SALMON VIA THE RIVER RAIN FOOD
WET. THOUSAND EIGHT. THE
WETLANDS AND ASSOCIATED
FLOODPLAINS THAT DIRECTLY
BENEFIT ENDANGERED LONGFIN SMELT
ENDANGERED SALT MARSH HARVEST
MOUSE AND THE MILLIONS OF
THREATENED AND ENDANGERED
MIGRATORY BIRDS UTILIZING THE
BAY DELTA. LASTLY THIRTY THREE
NEW ACRES OF SPAWNING. IN STREAM
AND FLOODPLAIN HABITAT FOR
JUVENILE SALMON RING- HABITATS
GIVE ME THESE HABITAT AGREEMENTS
WILL ONLY INCREASE OPPORTUNITIES
SIMILAR TO LAST YEAR'S SOLID
RETURN OF WINTER RUN SALMON-
MORE OF THE CDFW REPORTED OVER
TEN THOUSAND SALMON RETURNED
UNSPON A HIGH IN FIFTEEN YEARS.
PLEASE INCORPORATOR AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED A COALITION LETTER SO
THE TIMING WORKS FOR THIS
EFFECTIVE AND INNOVATIVE HABITAT
AGREEMENT- WHICH WILL THEN WORK
FOR HEALTHY RIVERS HEALTHY FARMS
HEALTHY LANDSCAPES. PAUL TO
BENEFIT PEOPLE COMMUNITIES FISH
AND WILDLIFE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF HIS
EARLIER CALL WAS JUST FOR
SUPPORT WE GOT SOME OPPOSITION
TO MAKE ONE MORE CALL FOR- ANY
OPPOSITION ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK
YOU THREE ONE. OUR MAIN THING
ABOUT THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SIX FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HELLO THANK YOU
TACKLE RIGHT MEMBERS THIS IS
KRISTIN OLSON ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY DOCUMENTO THE WATER
AUTHORITY WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FOR THE RECENT
PREVIOUSLY STATED BY THE AQUA
AND NOT CLASS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU AND THEN TO
CONTINUE TO DO THINGS IN RANDOM
ORDER ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
OF THE ROOM. I'M JUST I'M JUST
LIKE YOU TO BE ON THEIR TOES
HERE. PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS BRENDA BASS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY I
THINK THAT'S ALL THE PHONE CALLS
AND PEOPLE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL BRING IT
BACK UP TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MOTIONS.
THAT'S JUST JUST JUST ONE QUICK
COMMENT ABOUT WHAT WHEN YOU HAVE
DIFFICULT THINGS TO DO- HE IS
ALWAYS EASY TO SAY WE NEED MORE
TIME WE NEED MORE TIME AND WELL
INTENTIONED PEOPLE. CAN FIND
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY'RE TRYING
TO PULL LOTS OF DIFFERENT GROUPS
TOGETHER BUT- I THINK WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELVES WE'RE WAY PAST
DEADLINES AND WHERE WAS THE
SENSE OF URGENCY. WHEN WE WERE
COMING UP ON THOSE LINES THIS
WAS IT. TELL ASSEMBLY LIKE
DOCTOR CROKES BURKE ACTUALLY
COMES UP WITH A CONSEQUENCE AND
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT THAT
THIS IS NOT A CONSEQUENCE FOR
THE WATER BOARD BUT CERTAINLY IF
THE WATER BOARD WANTS TO MAKE
SURE ALL OF THOSE NEGATIVE
THINGS YOU IDENTIFY THAT WON'T
HAPPEN- DON'T HAPPEN THEY NEED
TO GET MOVING AND M. AND- WORK
ON THE PLAN AND- SO I JUST THINK
AT SOME POINT TIME YOU HAVE TO
DRAW A LINE IN THE SAND AND HAVE
A CONSEQUENCE RATHER THAN JUST
HAVING AGENCIES. WITHOUT ANY
CONSEQUENCE AT ALL DISTRICT NOR
VIRTUALLY IGNORE DEADLINES- S.
AS A HAVE SO HIGH IN THIS AREA
IN PARTICULAR I THINK WE SEE
THIS JUST PATTERSON A GREAT DEAL
FIVE OF THE AUTHOR FOR TRYING TO
COME UP WITH A CREATIVE WAY TO
INFUSE SOME SENSE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY GET TO THE
PROCESS THANK YOU. THE OKAY. YES
MY MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER PART
TIME SHARE- I. BEING AVAIL GUY
A. DEFINITELY HAVE VAST CONCERNS
WITH THIS EXPRESSION AS WE LOOK
AT WATER SUPPLIES WITH THE KID
FOLLOWING 30% OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION- WE LOOK AT WHAT
UKRAINE IS DOING WITH FOOD
SUPPLY GLOBALLY- AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME IT AT THIS TIME
TO THINK OF. US PASSING ANY
MEASURE. THAT COULD POSSIBLY
CHANGE ANY FLOWS OF WATER SOUTH
INTO OUR AGRICULTURAL LANDS
ESPECIALLY. WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT FOOD SECURITIES GLOBALLY. YOU
KNOW PART PART OF ME IS REALLY
THINKING WE NEED TO BE DOING
MORE TO GET MORE WATER SUPPLY
DOWN THERE. AND LOOKING AT
INCENTIVES AND OTHER THINGS ON
THE AGRICULTURE SPACE TO COVER
DOWN WHAT WE'RE LOSING GLOBALLY.
AND MAY I KNOW THE THIS BILL AS
WELL INTENDED. I THINK MISTER
BENNETT'S POINTS ABOUT. KICKING
THE AGENCIES A LITTLE BIT TO GET
THAT ACTUALLY DO BUSINESS IS A-
MULTI. I DO THINK THIS IS SOME
THAT COMES TODAY- BECAUSE WE
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
WATER FLOWING IN CAN'T HAVE
THINGS GETTING IN THE WAY OF
THAT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'M IS THAT.
TRANSACTION IN A MOTION AND A
SECOND DR CORPUS ARTICLES YES
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS BOB THIS
WOULD NOT AFFECT ANYTHING IN THE
CURRENT WATER SUPPLY- IT TOOK IT
WOULD AFFECT NEW- TAKING FROM
THE DELTA BUT IT SHOULDN'T
AFFECT YOUR AREA. IN THE LAST. I
UNDERSTAND YOUR OPPOSITION- THE
OTHER THING I'LL SAY IS THAT-
YOU KNOW THE OPPOSITION IS SAID
THIS CAN'T BE DONE ON TIME- THE
WATER WE HAVE- OPEN PHONE LINE.
TO THE WATER BOARD. THEY COULD
TELL US ANYTIME THAT THEY DON'T
LIKE THIS DEADLINE AND I WILL
CHANGE. OF WE HAVE AN OPEN LINE
TO THE GOVERNOR. IF THE WATER
BUT FEELS THAT THE VISA ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP BY THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AGENCY CAN'T
BE RESOLVED IN TIME I'M SURE
THEY WILL LEAVE THE LET US KNOW
WHERE THEY WILL VETO IT. SILENCE
IS GOLDEN SO FAR NO ONE IS
SUBJECTING TO THE TIMELINE WE'VE
SET. UP THAT'S AS FAR AS I CAN
GET- UP WITH THE STAFFERS SAID
THEY CAN HAVE THE WORK DONE. AND
IF THEY OBJECTED IF THEY HAVE A
CONCERN THEY WILL REACH OUT TO
US OR THEY WILL VETO THE BILL SO
I'M NOT WORRIED. ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT YOU BROUGHT UP
BECAUSE I THINK THE WATER BOARD
IS JUST AS ANXIOUS TO HAVE THIS
ADDITIONAL WATER TO THE DELTA
JUST AS AS YOU ALL ARE. SO I- I
FEEL THAT THIS IS YOU KNOW
THEY'LL LET US KNOW IF IT CAN'T
BE DONE YOU GOT YOU GOT AN AYE
VOTE GET RAIN WATER. OKAY I WON
FIVE. ALL RIGHT. I DON'T. I
DON'T KNOW LET. AB TWO. THE
MOTION AND PASSED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORK BY CORK ICE
METH. SMITH NO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
NOT VOTING KALRA KALRA AYE
BENNETT BENNETT I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA HI MATHIS
. MATHIS NO MOTIVE TO CHEAT
MURATSUCHI AYE WALDRON. OKAY ALL
RIGHT TAX WE WILL NOW GET
ADELINE YES JUST ONE MOMENT AND
I WE WILL ADAM. OKAY PEOPLE HERE
BUT OKAY. OF THE PEOPLE WEBER WE
ROLE DEADLINE. OKAY. IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A- I'M. WATER FOR THE. THIS IS FOR ONS CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT ZERO WILD WALDRON
EINER ZERO ON THE CAN CALENDAR
ONE. IS EIGHT. IS AT SIX TWO. AT
WALDRON I. SEVEN TWO ITEM TWO AB
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE. THE VOTE IS
SIX ZERO SMITH SMITH NO MATHIS.
THIS IS ITEM TO AB NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE THREE OF US. MATHIS
NO WALDRON WALDRON NO SIX THREE
. ITEM THREE AB TWENTY TWO OH
EIGHT KALRA. THE VOTERS AT SIX
TWO WALDRON WALDRON NOW SIX
THREE. ITEM FOR AB TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN CRISTINA GARCIA THE
VOTERS AT SIX TWO WALDRON.
WALDRON NO SIX THREE. ITEM FIVE.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN BRIAN
THE VOTERS AT SIX ONE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO SIX TWO. THAT SPRING
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN ITEM SIX
AB TWENTY FORTY ONE. THE VOTE
SETS AT SIX ZERO BENNETT'S.
BENNETT I WOULD HAVE TO G. ITEM
SIX AB TWENTY FORTY ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA. MURATSUCHI I WALDRON
WALDRON HIGH SO THAT'S. NINE
ZERO. ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SEVEN THE VOTE SAID THAT
SIX ZERO BENNETT. BENNETT I
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE NINE ZERO.
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN BLOOM. THE VOTERS AT SIX
TWO WALDRON. WALDRON HI SEVEN
TWO. I DON'T NINE WAS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM TEN. I
SAID THAT AT SEVEN ZERO BENNETT
. THIS IS AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
NINE MATHIS ITEM TEN BENNETT.
BENNETT I WALDRON WALDRON AYE
NINE ZERO. I AM ELEVEN AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY NINE. THE VOTE IS AT
FIVE TWO. WALDRON WALDRON NO.
FIVE THREE. THAT WAS AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY NINE CORK ITEM ELEVEN
. ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. THE VOTE STANDS AT
FOUR ZERO SMITH. SMITH NOT
VOTING ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA NOT
VOTING KALRA KALRA I. WHAT A TO
G. FIVE MINUTES THE GI WALDRON.
WALDRON NOT VOTING. SO THAT SIX
ZERO THAT'S ITEM TWELVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN SIX
ZERO. SMITH ARAMBULA AND WALDRON
NOT VOTING. IT'S EVERYTHING.
HELLO ALL RIGHT SHOW ALL VOTES
HAVE BEEN RECORDED FOR A VERY
PRODUCTIVE DAY THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND GOOD NIGHT ALL.
THIS IS A GREAT JOB.